Herzlich willkommen bei Bum Zack Return!
Zack, zack! Was ist los?
Hier so ein bisschen leiser.
Das stimmt.
Ich hör mich selber nicht, aber ich hör dich sehr.
Ja, das geht alles. Entschuldigung, ich hatte hier gerade so ein bisschen Miespult durcheinander. Bim, bim.
Eins.
Ich höre mich noch sehr laut. Ich höre mich auch.
Herzlich willkommen. Also eigentlich sind wir ja noch gar nicht Bum, zack, return.
Nee.
Erstens haben wir das nicht beschlossen und zweitens würde dafür jetzt, sagen wir mal, die gesamte sonstige Infrastruktur noch nicht stehen, aber vielleicht passiert das ja. Wir haben enorm viel Feedback bekommen, unter anderem diesen großartigen Intro-Jingle. Ganz, ganz klasse. Macht Lust auf mehr, oder?
Haben die das im Chat jetzt überhaupt gerade gehört? Da reagiert gar keiner.
Wie?
Wir haben wahrscheinlich Delay.
Jetzt kommen sie wieder mit, das würde knistern. Ich weiß nicht, was da knistert. Das muss irgendwie an einer, wenn da irgendwas knistert, dann...
Ihr knistert doch!
Genau, wir knistern überhaupt nicht. Also das einzige, was hier knistern könnte, ist, wenn ich jetzt Diesel-Taste drücke, aber dann wird es auch nicht, das knistert nicht.
Das knistert nicht. Kannst du meinen Kopfhörer noch ein wenig, so ein Minimü? Was? Leiser machen.
Und die anderen auch alle?
Ja, so super, toll.
Echt, das sagst du, bevor ich dir überhaupt was gedreht habe?
Nee, ja, doch, jetzt, doch, ist schon leiser.
So, alle sind da. Max? Hucke?
Ja.
Dennis? Warum ziehst du dich gerade aus, Tim? Na ja.
Mal locker machen hier.
The Heat is on, würde ich sagen. We're diving right into it, oder wie man in Deutschland so schön sagt, wir baden gerade unsere Hände drin.
Genau.
In dem ganzen Themenfeld.
Sprudelt sauber, sprudelt frisch.
Blubber, blubber, zisch.
Eine Folge vor 60, oder? Sind wir auch?
Alle finden, es knistert. Es ist nicht übersteuert. Es kann nicht übersteuert sein, Leute. Ich weiß nicht, dann ist irgendwas mit der Streaming-Welt dahinter durcheinander, aber es ist einfach technisch nicht.
Dann habt ihr halt nicht die guten USB-Kabel für 1000 Dollar.
Die vergoldeten USB-Kabel.
Jetzt im Moment im Bumzak-Returnstore vorbestellen.
Ja, ich meine, ich sehe ja alle Pegel. Ich glaube euch ja, dass irgendwas knistert. Manche sagen, es knistert, manche nicht. Deswegen muss es irgendwas mit irgendeinem Re-Encoding zu tun. Mich würde mal interessieren, ob es bei irgendjemand knistert, der direkt... Ich weiß nicht, gibt es Re-Encoding?
Kommt da irgendwo noch Ork aus? Vielleicht liegt das ja irgendwo auf der Strecke beim Verteilen an die diversen Server, die da im Weg stehen.
Das kann ich jetzt auch nur vermuten, aber bei mir ist es so, wir haben hier zahlreiche Kompressoren drauf. Wir hören in unseren Kopfhörern das, was wir jetzt hören, von dem wir sicher sagen können, dass da nichts knistert. Wir hören dort das Signal, was rausgeht, beziehungsweise fast genau das Signal, das rausgeht. Das geht dann noch an diesen Finalizer. Der macht da allerlei Kompressionen und Tralala, aber das tut er auch schon seit Jahr und Tag. Der ist sozusagen bei Design so, dass er nicht übersteuert, weil das ist genau das, was dieses Gerät macht. Es macht halt laut, aber nicht zu laut. Und das, was da rauskommt, das geht dann wiederum digital an meinen Mac und von dort digital direkt in den MP3-Kanal. Also wir halten fest, Xenon knistert. No finger pointing. Ich sag nur, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich pointe Finger.
Ja, und meine Aufnahme, ich nehme das ja hier auch alles auf, da knistert halt auch nichts. Also insofern, tut mir leid, wenn es knistert, dann müsst ihr halt den Podcast fahren.
Vielleicht sollte man mal so eine Mobile Macs Limited Edition auf Vinyl machen. Die ist so richtig schön.
Schon vorbestaubt.
Genau, und dann so mit Apple News vor 100 Jahren.
Und dann hören wir die ersten DJs mit unserem Bum-Zack-Return-Trailer auflegen und mixen.
Ja, da könnte man was draus machen. So eine Vintage-Sendung. Ja, es wurde gerade der erste 4-Bit-Prozessor.
Wir sind auch schon alt genug dafür.
Das wird uns nur unterstellt. Dem ist nicht so. Ja, ich denke unsere Infrastruktur läuft mittlerweile. Ich kann das mal testen.
Meine Infrastruktur läuft nicht, weil ich hab hier nämlich meine Taste jetzt nicht. Ich hab schon mal wieder leere Akkus.
Die Ene-Loops sind schon wieder...
Die Ene-Loops sind schon wieder durch.
Hast du nicht die schwarzen reingemacht?
Ehrlich gesagt, mit den schwarzen und mit den weißen hier nicht sehr viel anders. Ja.
Also diese V-Modes.
Ja, Ausgabe Nummer 59. Noch heißen wir MobileMix. Und noch sind wir hier auch immer im alten Team. Und wer jetzt im Chat noch irgendwas mit knistert-extrem schreibt...
Hast du ein neues Team? Das ist jetzt hier wie beim Mubarak. Noch mit dem alten Team. Wir hören da schon genau hin.
Naja, wenn wir uns hier umbenennen, dann sind wir auch alle wie neu.
Nee, ich glaub das hab ich noch nicht so ganz.
Der Sommerreifen, er ist aber da nicht rumgekommen.
Das ist ja wie diese Galaxy-Tab-Interpretation hier.
Also, ich will das nicht widersprechen, aber du bist ja der Heldeste.
Du willst in die Themenwelt einsteigen.
Ich möchte in die Themenwelt. Na, es passt einfach so gut.
Ich hab heute die Themen sortiert. Vorsichtig, wenn du jetzt irgendeins aufmachst, dann heißt das, dass der gesamte Themenblock dran kommt. Damit wir nicht zwischen iPhone, Mac, Markt, Tralala, Technik, Basteln, Haverschmitteln und so weiter herumspringen.
Also, das ist jetzt quasi so ein Test. Tim hat probiert, die Themen zu sortieren, und wir müssen sie jetzt durcheinanderschmeißen.
Ich glaube, das würde nicht problemlos gelingen. Max, aber damit wir uns da retten können, habe ich dir deine Rolls-Ball-Taste wieder heilegebaut.
Ach, danke.
Dann kannst du auch...
Dann mache ich jetzt Daily und Galaxy Tab in einem auf.
Dann hast du jetzt das Recht zu schweigen.
Oh, jetzt habe ich mich ohne Rolls-Ball-Taste.
Galaxy Tab für 100.
Rolls-Band bitte nur mit Taste.
Ach so, so wie du das gerade so vorgeführt hast, wie man es nicht macht.
Wir müssen glaube ich hier mal ein bisschen Streaming-Testing machen. Mir ist jetzt vollkommen unklar, wo hier irgendwas...
Mach doch einfach eine Testsendung irgendwann mal. Sagst du im Twitter Achtung, jetzt Streaming-Testing.
Ja, das müsste ich mir machen.
Ach stimmt, Bummsagretör, das ist ein Podcast, der in Umfang und Länge weit über dem Durchschnitt liegt.
Das ist wahr.
Ist das unser Claim?
Nee, das habt ihr ja nicht gehört. Ihr müsst das eigentlich auch nochmal vorstellen.
Qualität statt Qualität, ja.
Wo kommt das denn her?
Das kommt aus NatSafe for Work.
Ach so, Cross-Podcast.
Cross-Advertising. Sich gegenseitig hoch pushen.
Ja, so machen das die klassischen Medien ja auch.
Ja logisch.
Man kann das halt immer nur Eigenwerbung machen.
Die klassischen Medien.
Klick und schon haben wir einen Trigger.
Ich starre gerade fast entsetzt auf mein Setup hier. Aber das kriegen wir schon alles hin. Ja Jungs, vielleicht schalte ich hier nochmal den Kanal nochmal aus.
Und auch noch in 20 Jahren wird Tim vor jeder Sendung das Ritual.
Ich hab's euch schonmal gesagt, also ohne Änderung kein Fortschritt.
Blut eine Kante. Ich hab mir heute mal eine Rede von Erich Honecker angeguckt auf YouTube. Also dieses, wo er sagt, vorwärts immer, rückwärts nicht mehr zum Schluss. Und Mann, war der fertig zum Schluss. Also das ging ja gar nicht. So total mit gebrochener Stimme. Und der hat ja überhaupt nicht den Punkt mehr rüber gekriegt. Da dachte ich mir ja, meine Herren.
Du meinst ungefähr so wie der aktuelle Pressesprecher von Barad.
Der ist halt noch so richtig so.
Damit uns keiner zuguckt, wie wir hier podcasten. Weil nackt Podcasting zieht ja dann auch immer eine Menge.
Gruppis an, vor allem im Prenzlauer Berg.
Naja, das ist schlimm hier.
Dann stehen die Mütter mit den Kinderwagen.
Ägypten war, the revolution is being televised, sag ich nur. Irgendwie hieß es ja immer, die Revolution würde ja nicht übertragen werden im Fernsehen, aber diesmal sieht es ja wirklich ganz anders aus.
Ja, per Stream halt. Nicht im ganzen Fernsehen.
Vielleicht ist es ja gar keine Revolution.
Das kann auch sein.
Vielleicht werden sie ja auch gerade in diesem Moment alle wieder niedergeschossen und das war's.
Aber selbst das könntest du im Stream sehen. Aber es ist halt nicht das ganze Fernsehen. Es ist halt ein Sender vor allen Dingen, der da ganz schön performt und mit kreativen Lösungsansätzen es schafft, auch in wildrigsten Umständen da irgendwie noch Bilder über den Globus zu senden. Was eigentlich doch echt erstaunlich ist.
Ja, das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Also ich hab jetzt nicht zu viel Zeit damit verbracht, aber ich glaub so ein, zwei Tage hab ich jetzt mal so ein bisschen zugekickt und das ist schon mal wirklich so, man hat so das Gefühl, die Medieninnovation findet jetzt im arabischen Raum statt. Also Al-Tazira hat ja nun schon früh angefangen, da den anderen Butter vom Brot zu nehmen, aber das so, gut, ich mein sie haben natürlich einen riesen Vorteil dadurch, dass sie da bilingual rangehen können, dass sie da natürlich da einfach ihr Netz haben. Das ist jetzt nicht so der Ort, wo BBC besonders gute Voraussetzungen hat.
Ja, aber ich mein, es ist ja trotzdem so, dass zwischendurch war es ja, als es da so richtig losging, irgendwie hieß es ja erst so, ja jetzt hier haben sie uns vom Satelliten geschmissen, jetzt sind sie bei uns im Büro, jetzt haben sie unser Equipment mitgenommen und du guckst da auf den Stream, ja läuft er noch. Und irgendwie kam halt immer so irgendwelche Meldungen und jetzt sind sie gerade im Büro, jetzt machen wir kurz aus, machen wir kurz aus, haben sie irgendwie Nachrichtenschleife gebracht oder was auch immer und dann zack wieder auf dem Satelliten und jetzt sind wir auf dem und jetzt gehen wir zu Hotbird und dann hier mit ihren Telefon-Reportern, als sie da nicht mehr vor Ort mit Kamera irgendwie Leute hatten und so. Also sie waren echt agil sozusagen, ja, in der Coverage muss man schon sagen. Die sind da allen Unwegsamkeiten und sie sind ja immer noch, sie senden einfach konstant 24-7 aus dem Gebiet.
Und im Irak hat das, haben das die westlichen Medien auch noch ganz gut hingekriegt, um Live-Breakerstattung auf die Bande zu stellen.
Ja und vor allen Dingen halt beeindruckend auch finde ich nach wie vor, dass die halt auch so die Band, also dass sie den Traffic einfach durch die Welt gepumpt kriegen. Also klar setzt der Stream hier und da mal aus, aber ich mein, als das da so richtig losging vor ein paar Tagen, da haben bestimmt hunderttausende Leute da geklickt. Die haben ja auch über Fernsehen gesagt, gleich geht unser Upstream aus, jetzt klickt mal alle Webstream erst mal.
Also da, nach meiner Erfahrung hat das da überhaupt nicht mehr funktioniert. Ich hab da da vorgesessen, ständiger Bildausfall, ständiger Tonausfall, Flash war fertig, also das war schon.
Bei mir ging es die ganze Zeit, das Flash rödelt hier auch die ganze Zeit mit 136%, aber mein Lüfter geht ja nicht an. Also der Vorteil von so einer i7 CPU ist tatsächlich, selbst wenn das Flash 140% CPU verdreht, dann streamt das.
Ach, dachte man das?
Ja genau, juckt den Rechner gar nicht. Nicht mal Lüfter geht an. Naja, nee, aber der würde ja sozusagen bei theoretischen 400% toppen. Also der fährt jetzt sozusagen auf eine Arschbacke, nee auf einer halben Arschbacke fährt er sozusagen. Das Flash da. Also ich hab schon die Load von, also ich hab schon 350% CPU Load bei meinen Koden von irgendwas hinbekommen. So, ein bisschen sustained. Das heißt, wenn er dann 130 braucht, gut, ist ein Drittel, also ja. Das reicht noch nicht, um ihn zum Lüften zu bringen.
Ja, das erinnert mich an mein neues Gerät. Und ich bin ja so dermaßen glücklich, das könnt ihr euch überhaupt nicht vorstellen.
Live von, jetzt von Ägypten direkt hart auf deinen Schalttisch.
Ich weiß nicht, gibt's da noch was zu sagen?
Ich meine, ähm, nee, da gibt's nix mehr.
Ich meine, das ist Kontext-App. Es gibt da diese Al-Jazira-Applikationen, das läuft halt alles auch mit iPhone-Streaming. Das kann man nochmal erwähnen.
Genau, das ist nämlich irgendwie, da gibt's zwar Apps, aber es gibt auch für Android und iOS-Geräte hier m.livestation.com. Da gibt's sowieso ein paar Fernsehsender. Weiß ich auch nicht, aber die haben halt so Euro-News und so ein paar andere Sender, von denen man noch nie was gehört hat, aber man kann dann auf der Webseite über iOS und Android einfach auf Watch Now klicken und das kommt dann als Webstream angeflogen.
Und du wirst es da auch.
Ist da auch auf der www.english.aljazira.com-Seite verlinkt, glaube ich, mittlerweile alles.
Interessant. Da sieht man mal wieder diesen Tod von lokalen Frequenzen. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt hier so Fernsehen hätte, also auch schon mit Kabel und so, da gibt es ja kein Aljazeera Englisch. Da gibt es dann irgendwie RTL und was weiß ich, wahrscheinlich so 10 verschiedene Shopping-Kanäle und diesen ganzen Kack.
Was man halt so braucht als Allgemeininformierter Bürger.
Genau. Also eigentlich ist Internet wirklich die einzige nennenswerte Empfangsfrequenz.
Über Satellit würdest du es jetzt auch noch kriegen, aber...
Wenn du auf den Richtigen zeigst.
Genau, das ist dann noch das Problem, wenn sie dann sagen, wir sind jetzt auf Hotbird, tüpti, tüpti, tüpt, ja, mal kurz den Schraubenschlüssel holen und aus dem Fenster krabbeln.
Naja, aber ein gewisser Bezug ist schon da. So schnell, wie die jetzt mal eben hier die ganzen UMTS-Frequenzen und Telefonnetze abgeschaltet haben in Ägypten und wie schnell die da...
Ich frag mich so...
In der Diktatur ist das ja auch nicht so schwur.
Naja, aber so Visa und Paypal und so, die hatten jetzt auch in demokratischen Ländern nicht so ganz große Probleme, die Wikileaks-Zahlungsannahme präventiv abzuschalten.
Nee, das ist aber ein bisschen Äpfel und Birnen. Also ich meine, so die gesamte Internetinfrastruktur und einen Kunden ausschließen bei einer Firma ist jetzt mal nicht so direkt vergleichbar.
Naja, aber wenn jetzt die Bundesregierung nachfragen würde, freundlich bei Telekom, Vodafone, O2 und E+. Übrigens, wir hätten da ganz gerne, da ist böser Cyber-Terrorismus unterwegs, sperrt mal diese Webseite. Ähm, braucht da auch kein Gesetz für, oder? Meint ihr, die würden da extrem lange brauchen um zu sagen, ach, kriegen wir hin?
Naja, ich meine, das haben sie ja nun versucht, diese Infrastruktur in Place zu kriegen. Da ist ja so ein bisschen an den Netzbürgern gescheitert. Bitte?
Infrastruktur ist da, glaube ich, das.
Na wo denn? Ich kenne genug Provider, die haben so eine Infrastruktur nicht. Ich meine, wenn sie das nur bei der Telekom ausknipsen, dann sind die alle 0,0 Nix schnell mal bei einem anderen Provider. Also nicht von heute auf morgen, aber zumindest von...
Und solange es Proxys gibt. Also wegkriegen so richtig kriegst du es nur, wenn du wirklich ausmachst.
Ja, insofern war das ja extrem konsequent, was sie da gemacht haben. Also nicht, wenn ich sagen gut, sondern aus ihrer logik, ihrer queren, bekloppten Logik heraus haben sie halt einfach mal alles abgeschaltet. Nur, ich glaube nicht, dass sie wirklich damit auch erzielt haben, was sie eigentlich erzielen wollten. Das mag zwar kurzfristig bestimmte Effekte gehabt haben, aber mittelfristig wird es einfach ihr Tod sein. Jetzt ist ja das Internet soweit ich weiß, weitgehend wieder in Place, wenn auch mit Zensurfiltern. Vielleicht haben sie es auch erstmal komplett runtergefahren, damit sie an ihren Zensurfiltern arbeiten können, aber das ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen doof, weil Internet muss man ja eigentlich am zuckenden Objekt zensieren, da kann man ja mit so einem toten Internet auch irgendwie nichts testen. Das funktioniert ja alles nicht.
Wahrscheinlich sind dadurch, dass das Internet weg war, überhaupt erst die Leute auf die Straße gegangen.
Also das war doch auch so ein witziges Twitter-Kommentar dazu, von Conan O'Brien, der meinte irgendwie, ich weiß nicht mehr genau wie es war, aber es war so nach dem Motto, wenn du willst, dass die Leute zu Hause auf dem Sofa sitzen und irgendwie chillen und nichts tun, dann machst du doch nicht das Internet aus. Also, ne?
Ja, wir meinten ja auch, auf Spiegel glaube ich so einen Bericht, unser Facebook ist jetzt auf der Straße und so. Nach dem Motto, es gibt ja kein Facebook mehr, dann muss man ja jetzt uns auf der Straße treffen und direkt unterhalten.
Eigentlich sind die alle nur da, um zu gucken, was mit ihrem WLAN los ist. Hast du auch keine Fragen mehr?
Woran liegt denn das? Ach, das hat dieser Mupark ausgeschaltet. Was? Nieder, nieder!
Und dann war ja jetzt hier noch kurz vor zwei Tagen, dass Google irgendwie eine Telefonproxy nach Twitter macht. Haben Sie da Mechanic Turk-Kapazitäten gecastet, damit aus dem Drakadakamohamadji...
Na, Finanzamt für Körperschaften 2, sag ich mal. Die haben einfach ihre Sprichrückung schon eingeschaltet.
Für Arabe, schätze ich mittlerweile.
Keine Ahnung, was die da alles auffahren können. Aber zur Not haben sie das mal eben gecode'et. Da sind sie ja irgendwie immer ganz gut, der Google. Also da können sie ja schnell mal Kapazitäten freischalten und auf Desaster reagieren. Das machen sie ja immer gerne. Auch so mit Google Maps und Katrina seiner Zeit. Also wir haben da immer verstehen, dass es sozusagen für Sie auch als Unternehmen natürlich eine super Werbung ist, wenn Sie mit solchen Dingen ankommen. Negative News hat ja Google derzeit genug. Ja, aber so dieses Twitter, ich würde gerne mal so ein paar Tweets sehen, die da auch dann dabei rauskamen. Das ist natürlich bei Spracherkennung so ein bisschen so wie mit der Wortkorrektur auf dem iPhone. Also wenn man jetzt hier so Autokorrekt.me auf dem Web anschaut, hinter das da ist ja auch so von von Failblog irgendwie immer so schöne SMS-Dialoge, wo die Leute sich irgendwie eigentlich normales Zeug schreiben. Aber dann macht halt das iPhone Schweinkram drauf.
Beim letzten Mal habe ich das doch erzählt, wenn man einfach nur da ständig X drückt und so immer irgendwelche Buchstaben wiederholen, was da für Bullshit bei rauskommt.
Hatten wir das auch hier mal, da gab es auch mal wirklich so diesen Fall, war das in der Türkei, wo sie dann wirklich so ein Zeichen falsch geschrieben hat und dadurch wurde dann irgendwie ein ganz furchtbares Schimpfwort und das endete dann echt alles in Mord und Todschlag. Also wirklich so ein Vertipper. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt die Korrektur war oder falsch getippt. Kann ja auch sein. War wohl nur so ein Zeichen, was dann einem Wort einfach ganz andere Bedeutung...
Na bei T9 gab es ja auch schon schöne Sachen. Da konnten bloß noch keine Screenshots machen. Oder wenn man mit T9...
Ach du meinst dieses Awkward-Zeicheneingabesystem.
Genau. Wenn man da, ich glaube, Bierkiste eingegeben hat oder sowas, dann kam Hitlerjugend raus.
Also wirklich sowas.
Ja, aber bring noch mal eine Bierkiste mit, das hat teilweise eine ganz negative Auswirkung.
Ja und schon sind die Trigger an hier bei den Telekommunikationsunternehmen.
Und was machst du dann? Hast du kein Bier mehr und hast die Hitlerjugend vor dem Haus?
Aber das fände ich auch interessant, dass Google sozusagen explizit für Twitter einen Dienst geschaltet hat.
Also nicht Buzz.
Gibt es das noch? Wirklich?
Na ich hab...
Es ist so gut, dass wir Max haben, sonst würden wir von so bestimmten Teilen des Internets überhaupt nichts mitbekommen.
Hier unser Legacy-Reporter.
Also ich nutze das mehr versehentlich. Es gibt ja diesen Share-Button in Reader, mit dem man Informationen mit anderen Leuten sharen kann. Und da hab ich auch ein paar Follower, so 100, 150.
Du hast Follower?
Ja, auf Bass. Und das pumpen die dann automatisch immer noch in den Bass rein. Und dann hin und wieder kommt da auch mal eine Antwort. Also.
Du bist so ein Gross-Poser.
Jaja, ich mach da nicht alles hier nur über Twitter oder so. Das ist schon.
Übrigens, denn in dem Zusammenhang vielleicht noch für alle, die noch nicht diesen einen Twitter-Feed haben, wo die meisten News eigentlich zu dem Thema auch noch durchkommen. Also ich hab mir so einen extra Account gemacht, damit das nicht meine normale Timeline voll schnattert. Ist Sultan Al-Kasmi. Ich paste das mal in den Chat und du kannst das ja gleich noch in die Show-Notes dann vielleicht später tun. Das ist auf jeden Fall so der Twitter-Feed für die Arbeit, wenn man halt nicht Stream gucken kann von Al-Jazeera. Hier muss man followen oder wie? Ja, da sind so die up-to-date News, wenn man mal irgendwie im Augenwinkel noch mitverfolgen will.
Wie das Spiel steht so.
Wie es so abgeht, ja.
Wir fühlen mit euch.
Genau.
Wir haben jetzt hier nicht so viel unmittelbare Einflussnahme, aber wir sind Gedanken bei euch da unten. Macht mal einen Topf zu da. Füllt mal das Internet ein, nahe in den Osten, das fände ich jetzt mal gut. Da gibt es viele hochmotivierte junge Menschen, die bestimmt voll Bock auf Innovation haben, wenn man sie nur mal lassen würde.
Die noch keinen Facebook-Account haben. Fragt mal Mark Zuckerberg.
Wie die keinen Facebook-Account haben. Ich glaube, das ist das Einzige, was sie alle haben. Okay, es mag auch noch welche geben, die noch keine Gelegenheit hatten, einen zu haben. Aber ich glaube, die, die eine Gelegenheit hatten, haben schon einen.
Ja klar, das hab ich mir neulich überlegt, dass Facebook wahrscheinlich das erste wirklich, also das wird noch weiter verbreitet sein, als Coca-Cola, was so Einkommensschichten und weltweit angeht und so was. Das ist so dieses eine verbindende Element.
Meinst du vom Bekanntheitsgrad der Marke?
Nein, nicht nur vom Bekanntheitsgrad der Marke her, sondern auch das...
Es wird häufiger benutzt.
Ist das wirklich?
Ja, es wird auch so häufig genutzt, und es wird vor allen Dingen, dass weltweit ein Produkt genutzt wird. Also das ist auch nicht das irgendwie, ja, du kriegst hier die guten Smartphones, und da gibt es nur die billigen Smartphones und so, diese Abwägungen, sondern es ist wirklich weltweit, sitzen alle am selben Facebook, bloß halt mit einer anderen Übersetzung obendrüber. Und wenn wir hier einen Feature kriegen, dann kriegen die das in Afrika genauso schnell. Also, außer dass sie natürlich langsam Modems haben, aber naja. Tja, außer halt in Ägypten, wo sie mit Offline-Facebook ausleben müssen.
Auf jeden Fall könnte man jetzt noch so abschließen, vielleicht zu der Geschichte sagen, wenn jetzt bei uns mal die Revolution anfängt, da habt ihr jetzt mal gesehen, was die Ägypter so für Maßnahmen ergreifen, was sie so alles abschalten, und dann kann man sich einfach schon mal jetzt Gedanken drüber machen, sich mal einen Satelliten-Ablink-Internet irgendwo klarzumachen oder eine von den Open Source, GSM-Base Stations und Netzwerken mal sich anzugucken, für den Fall der Fälle, damit man dann einfach sagen kann, nee, vielleicht doch mal den Freifunker beitreten. Genau, Freifunker, gibt's ja auch noch, so Mesh Networks und so.
GSM Netz, kann man sie auch schon selber bauen?
Genau, eben.
So für alle Fälle?
Eigene DVB-T-Sender, so für... Radio-Bausätze gibt's ja eh seit 50 Jahren schon in Elektronik, Bastelmärkten.
Im Club gibt's ja diese großartige Kunstinstallation, ich weiß gar nicht, wer die gebaut hat. Diese Kiste, wo dann diese, wie vor Vendetta-Maske, die Guy Fawkes Maske in so einem Teil, in so einer Vitrine drin steht und dann in Case of a Revolution, Break Glass.
Also so wie die Axt halt für, wenn ein Feuer ausbricht, wo man die Scheibe auch durchlegt und sich die Axt rausholt.
In Case of emergency.
Das fand ich wirklich einen verdammt coolen Joke. Ja, ja, ich weiß. Der Gedanke, dass wirklich so in allen Zimmern in Deutschland so eine Vitrine drinsteht, wo dann so eine Guy Fawkes und Foxmaske drin ist und dann bricht dann irgendwann mal so der Shitstorm los. Der deutsche Innenminister schaltet Internet aus und dann ziehen alle ihre Masken aus.
Danke, ja, aber ich hab ja auch so eine Maske.
Der finale digitale Radiergut.
Was ist denn der deutsche Guy Fawkes? Ist das der Eulenspiegel oder so eine Eulenspiegelmaske?
Revolutionäre, die irgendwie die Regierung sprengen wollten. Das hatten wir letztes Mal kurz vor den Zeiten der Nazis.
Da gab es ja diverse Kollegen, die das probiert haben.
Stauffenberg und so. Aber seitdem...
RF gibt es nur noch, die haben auch versucht, explosiv in die...
Aber ich weiß nicht... Hier lang lauf ich nicht, da werden sie konform. Ja, naja, da wird es nochmal eine andere Nummer.
So ein Notnehmen einfach Guy Fawkes.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist jetzt auch so das passende Memen. Da gab es ja auch diese schöne Grafik. Habt ihr das gesehen? So ein Tut-endlich-Amun-Maske mit Guy Fawkes-Optik. Worum liegen, weiß bestimmt der Chat. Falls die schon alle gegangen sind wegen des Knisterns. Was meinen ja auch ein paar Leute, es würde nicht knistern.
Ja, ihr habt einfach einen falschen Streaming-Relay abbekommen.
Ja, guckt doch mal genau, guckt doch mal, was eure tatsächliche Streaming-URL ist. Und dann pastet doch mal die und sagt, ob es knistert oder nicht knistert.
Wir sind so auf Scammer reingefallen, die einen umleiten.
Ja, die Nigeria-Connection. Genau, dann Werbung einblenden.
Also andere Werbung, als die normalerweise kommt.
Genau, das kann sein. Also wenn ihr zwischendurch einfach so... werbt oder so, ja, das könnte sein. Also wenn einfach zwischendurch Werbung kommt, dann wisst ihr, dass ihr auf einem falschen Stream seid. Aber so was würde natürlich jedenfalls passieren.
Oder?
Hast du eigentlich schon eine InneLoop-Batterien in den BC-2700 gesteckt? So, und dann ganz inspiriert von den Freiheitsgefühlen in Ägypten hast du ja schon vorausahnd dir ein Freiheitsenablerendes Notebook gekauft.
Die Überleitung des Abends.
Ich hab noch am Hinterkopf gehabt.
Weil man ja auf so einer Demo nicht so schwer schleppen will.
Genau, genau.
Sonst nicht so schnell rennen kann.
Jetzt ist Tim aber schon wieder total baff an dieser Überleitung und weiß gar nicht, wo anfangen soll.
Oh, er starrt schon wieder auf den Pegel.
Der gleich sagt, deswegen knistert es.
Nee, nee, ich äh...
Sag mal, wieso ist denn da der Rekordknopf nicht rot?
Es nimmt alles auf, keine Angst. Mein MacBook Air.
Ja. Das Tolle.
Ich hab ja letztes Mal, weiß nicht, letztes Mal hatte ich's schon.
Ja, hatte ich schon. Gerade frisch.
Genau, da kam's gerade frisch rein, da konnte ich noch nicht so richtig dafür zu sagen.
Ich geh gleich.
Aber jetzt ist es noch qualifizierter.
Na, jetzt hab ich schon so ein bisschen mehr Erfahrung. Ich überleg nur gerade, was sozusagen die relevante Erfahrung ist, die man so teilen möchte. Also zunächst einmal das Ding ist einfach leise. Also ich kann mich nicht erinnern, irgendetwas von diesem Gerät als Geräusch wahrgenommen zu haben, außer der Musik, die ich da vielleicht mal abschiebe. Aber so dieses Wuuuh, die Stoppsauger-Effekt.
Um es nochmal für unsere Hörer zusammenzufassen, da ist eine SSD drin und keine Festplatte, das heißt, das Geräusch fällt schon mal weg.
Ja.
Und das ist schon mal auch bedeutend.
Das trägt schon mal bei. Wobei die letzten Festplatte, muss ich sagen, sind ganz schön leise. Im Gegensatz zu früher ist das schon richtig gut. Aber dann haben wir ja, also bei meinem vier Jahre alten Ding hier, da sind ja Lüfter drin, zwei Stück, die mit 2000 Umdrehungen drehen, wenn er kühl ist. Was ist bei dir drin? Lüfter.
Doch, da ist glaube ich einer drin.
Aber läuft der oder hat der auch so einen Grundrauschen an?
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht so ein Tool installiert. Das müsste ich vielleicht mal machen, aber ich nehme nichts wahr.
SMC Fan Control, sage ich nur.
Ich nehme nichts wahr. Ich kann ja das Tool mal kurz installieren.
Das ist auch das, was ich bei meinem Rechner jetzt mit der SSD eben auch schon festgestellt habe. Das ist wirklich extrem leise ist. Und dieses, auch gerade so beim Aufklappen, wo es dann immer so klack, klack und das Laufwerk nochmal kurz zuckt und so, das hast du halt alles nicht. Du klappst es auf und es ist einfach da.
Aber in einem CD-Rom hast du das schon auch noch.
Ja, aber das macht auch nicht mehr diese Zzzzzz. Nichts.
Ich habe ja noch eine Festplatte zusätzlich zur SSD und wenn die immer hochfährt, das merkt man schon relativ deutlich, wenn es plötzlich laut wird im Raum.
Aber es wird mich doch mal interessieren, wie schnell die Lüfter bei euch so sind und wie die drehen und so. Deswegen, ich poste mal diesen SMC-Fan-Controller-Link hier in den Chat. Könnt ihr mal ja auschecken.
Da meint gerade, es wäre auf meinem Gerät noch nicht getestet, SMC-Fan-Controller. Stürzt doch gleich ab.
Also hier ist ein Lüfter drin. Ich habe mal, also ein Lüfter ist drin. Ich habe gerade bei ifixit.com mal schnell geguckt.
2000 Umdrehungen sagt er.
Und da ist ein Lüfter dabei.
Jaja, der hat schon einen. 2200 Umdrehungen pro Minute und macht hier 42 Grad Celsius.
42, nicht schlecht. Mein Rechner ist immer so bei 50, 56 so.
Ja, das ist wirklich, also das ist das Tolle. Was auch wirklich extrem großartig ist und was man gar nicht genug betonen kann, ist, wie leicht dieses Teil ist. Also das, was mir schon immer so total genervt hat, bei diesen ganzen Briketts, die er da rumschleppt. Ich sitze hier wirklich einer zwei 15er, ein 17er, starren mich an. Ich hab hier so dieses kleine Mini-Teil. Und es ist so, man kann es immer mal eben einfach so in die Hand nehmen, mit einem, mit zwei Fingern irgendwo hinstellen und beiseiteräumen und auch wenn man da irgendwie von Kindern bestürmt wird. Also es geht, es geht immer alles.
Ist dir schon runtergefallen?
Und vor allem dieses Einstecken mitnehmen. Man muss schon so richtig nochmal so double checken, dass man es auch eingepackt hat, weil es einfach nicht klar ist.
Weil man es nicht mehr am Gewicht merkt.
Weil man es einfach am Gewicht nicht merkt. Das ist schon echt klasse. Aber was dann insofern noch super ist, ist, wie schnell das Teil ist. Ich meine, da ist ja eigentlich ein relativ langsamer Prozessor drin. Ich meine, ich hab dann noch die schnellere Variante, also 1,6 statt 1,4. Das macht jetzt so viel auch nicht aus. Wobei man auch sagen muss, mit einer SSD hat natürlich so ein Gerät die Möglichkeit, die CPU auch mal wirklich zu nutzen. Also hier bei meinem iMac, das Gefühl, ob ich da einen i7 oder i5 drin hab, das macht wahrscheinlich keinen großen Unterschied. Klar, du hast mehr Kerne und so. Klar, wenn du Handbrake anschmeißt, geschenkt. Dann merkst du das. Aber so im normalen Betrieb wird das Ding in der Regel einfach immer von drehenden Scheiben ausgebremst.
Ich hab übrigens, da kann ich mir was zu sagen, weil ich hab mir da in der Uni, wo ich ja auch diese ganze Hardware da letztens schon von erzählt hatte, da kam jetzt ein Mac Pro an. Und ich hab ja so einen mittelstarken Mac Pro geklickt. Zwei Quad-Core Xeons, die anscheinend auch Hyperthreading hatten, weil als ich den Activity-Monitor gestartet hatte, starten mich da 16 CPU-Balken an. Das Ding hat 16 GB RAM und zwei Festplatten.
Das ist der mittlere, ja?
Und es geht ja noch viel mehr da. Und das war nicht so snappy wie mein Notebook. Und das muss an den Platten liegen.
Ja, das ist genau das Ding.
Und ich saß echt davor und dachte mir so, jetzt komm mal ran hier und hab mal so ein paar Sachen geklickt und es war nicht so snappy.
Also es ist wirklich die Platte und es gibt glaube ich keine. Also SSD ist wirklich eine Enabler-Technologie vom Herrn.
Wir können es gar nicht oft genug sagen.
Also wenn ihr wirklich das Gefühl habt, der Computer könnte mal zehnmal so schnell sein zur Abwechslung, SSD reinschrauben.
Leider nur gefühlt zehnmal so schnell, weil wenn man den Handbrake anschmeißt, ist es viel schneller.
Aber gefühlt ist ja genau der Punkt. Normalerweise fühlt man es ja nicht danach oder so. Diese Mikrolatenzen, dass einfach jeder Klick irgendwie einfach instantan ist.
Aber muss man schon dazu sagen, also Leute, wenn ihr euer Handbrake schneller haben wollt, dann nützt die SSD nichts, sondern müsst ihr wirklich einen dickeren Rechner kaufen. Nein, wir haben auch hier Hörer, die das vielleicht nicht wissen.
Wer wusste es nicht hier im Chat? Chat, sagt man.
Chat wissen immer alle, alle.
Instant Abstimmung.
Und zwar besser.
Und mehr.
Deswegen sind sie auch alle im Chat. Stimmt's? Was soll ich denn noch dazu sagen? Also dann diese Größe ist auch top. Vor allem halt diese Tiefe, die nicht vorhandene, was einfach so in der Bahn ganz hervorragend ist. So stellst du das halt auf so ein kleines Tischchen drauf und da ist einfach noch viel Platz drumrum. Allgemein empfinde ich dieses Gerät einfach grundsätzlich als sehr konvenientes Bildschirm, ist hell.
Ach so, genau.
Das performt nicht bei solchen Sachen wie Google Earth.
Was war da nochmal für CPUs drin? Ein Core 2 Duo, ja?
Ein Core 2 Duo mit 1,6. In meinem Fall. Standard ist halt. Ich meine, ich hab ihn dann auch gleich mit 4 GB geholt und ich hab ihn auch mit der großen SSD geholt. Also sozusagen die teuerste Option von dem billigsten Mac-Code.
Ganz tief rechts unten.
Genau. Was mich ja sozusagen interessieren würde, wäre ja eben die Displaygröße. Inwiefern das vielleicht doch mal im Alltag bei der ein oder anderen Sache stören könnte. Aber die Auflösung war ja relativ hoch.
Die ist relativ hoch, die ist halt so wie beim normalen 15 Zoller.
Wie beim 13.
Entschuldigung, beim normalen 13 Zoller. Und bei dem 13er ist es so wie beim 15er.
Genau.
Also beim 13er R ist es so wie beim 15er.
1440 hast du draus.
Ich hab 1366.
Das ist sogar ein bisschen mehr, oder? Hat nicht das 13 Zoll nur 1280 gehabt?
Nein. Nein, das hat 1440.
Nee, das 15 Zoll hat 1440. Das MacBook Pro. Das MacBook Pro.
Ja, aber das 13er R hat halt die selber Auflösung.
Ja, aber das 13 Zoll MacBook ohne R, mit Pro, hat das nicht nur 1280?
Das weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht auswendig. Da hat sich so viel getan, dass ich da nicht mehr so ganz durcheinander komme. Auf jeden Fall bin ich mit dem 11 Zoller mit 1366, 768. Das ist so diese HDTV-Auflösung. Das ist irgendwie völlig okay. Klar, da mach ich jetzt nicht einen Layout für eine Tageszeitung mit, aber das ist ja auch gar nicht die Aufgabe dieses Computers. Die Aufgabe dieses Rechners ist, dass ich einfach immer einen Mac dabei hab, wo ich meine Terminals aufmachen kann, wo ich meine Webbrausen kann, wo ich meine Mail lesen kann, wo ich alles chatten kann, tun kann. Und das tu ich damit. Was für mich die einzige nennenswerte Umstellung ist, die nicht so schön ist, hat gar nichts mit dem Gerät zu tun. Ich hab jetzt nicht mehr den Laptop als mein Primärrechner. Vorher war es so, dass ich meinen ganzen Podcastmüll auf dem Laptop hatte. Das hab ich jetzt auf mein iMac geschmissen. Das heißt, ich synke damit. Und dann kommt halt wieder diese Synkele. Bin ich mal zwei, drei Tage unterwegs. Bin ich nicht in der Lage, bestimmte Podcasts auf meinen Telefon zu kriegen, weil ich dafür einen Computer brauche. Und es gibt keine Möglichkeit, das mit dem iPhone zuverlässig immer zu laden. Sondern es geht nur, wenn es sich um Passwort-freie Podcasts handelt. Das sind zugegebenermaßen die meisten, aber ich hab halt auch ein, zwei, die eben...
Passwortgeschützte. Was bist du denn für eine Elite hier?
Ja, jetzt geht's ja ab.
Zuerst hier die...
Gated Community Podcasts.
Das ist wahrscheinlich, da sind die Probesendungen mit unsern...
Bist du uns ein Plus? Das ist ein Feed, da ist eine HTTP Authentication drauf. Und die geht halt nicht, die ist halt nicht im iTunes-Store drin. Was nicht im iTunes-Store drin ist, kann halt ein iPhone auch nicht laden. Obwohl das iPhone eigentlich alles hätte. Gut, ich kann jetzt so einen Podcast... Klar, ich kann jeden möglichen erdenklichen Scheiß machen, aber ich mach ja nicht deshalb Podcasting, damit es trotzdem irgendwie geht, sondern damit es einfach ist. Und das ist nicht einfach und das nervt einfach. Ich sag ja nicht, die Welt geht unter, aber es ist halt eine Umstellung, wo ich erstmal überlegen muss, was Sache ist, wie ich den Rand formuliere, der so einschlägt, dass bei Apple einfach die Glocken klingen.
Im Chat wird gesagt, du sollst mir erklären, was Bits und so ist.
Das ist ein Podcast aus München. Da wird auch über Macintoshes geschwatzt.
Aber ich hab jetzt gerade nochmal geguckt. Das hat tatsächlich, das 13 Zoll hat nur 1280 x 800 Pixel, mit anderen Worten. Das hat hier eine höhere Auflösung sogar. Das 13 Zoll Macbook Pro.
Ne, da hat der Tim sich bestimmt verdingst beim Kommen.
Ne, ne, das sind 1000.
Nein, ich verdingst mich hier überhaupt nicht, weil ich schaue gerade hier auf die offizielle Auskunft.
Ne, das hat mehr. Das hat 1366 auf jeden Fall, ja.
Das Rf Zoll hat mehr Auflösung als das 13 Zoll?
Als das 13 Zoll Macbook Pro. Ohne R.
Achso, das Alte.
Das aktuelle.
Das muss ja auch mal ein neues kommen. Womit wir beim nächsten Thema werden? Oder machen wir später?
Ja, Moment, warte mal. Lass mich mal kurz überlegen, was auch noch eine Unterlassung, also was auch noch weggefallen ist, was mich aber jetzt auch nicht mehr so sehr schmerzt, weil ich es nicht mehr so sehr brauche, wie ich es mal gebraucht habe, ist halt, es gibt halt keine optischen Ausgänge, das ist nur noch Analog-Audio. Aber halt auch rein raus über einen Teil. Die Kamera ist nicht sehr gut. Also das ist wirklich so eine FaceTime-Kamera. Da kannst du gerade so mal ein bisschen Video chatten, aber dafür High-Quality-Pictures taugt das nicht. Und du hast halt auch keine Hintergrundbeleuchtung mehr auf der Tastatur. Das ist so das Einzige, wo ich sagen würde, ist ein echter Kompromiss. Aber das Ding ist einfach super schnell und super schick und super leicht und super klein und super, super. Also ich bin total begeistert und ich verkaufe meinen 15 Zoll MacBook Pro. Ich hab's schon platt gemacht, hab schon irgendwie alles schön sauber geputzt.
Hast du auch mehrfach gesierut?
Auch mehrfach gesierut.
Wie oft denn?
1.768.000 Mal.
Glaub ich nicht, da wärst du noch nicht fertig.
Dann war's wohl etwas weniger.
Na, das ist nämlich die Sache. Das wissen ja auch viele nicht, dass hier so einmal Festplatte löschen. Das ist ja nicht gelöscht, das ist ja nur als gelöscht markiert.
Da gibt's ja dann die einschlägigen Optionen, wo man dann wirklich schön platt machen kann.
Also drei oder fünf Mal, das soll dann keinen großen Unterschied mehr machen, oder gar keinen.
Aber der Aufwand, die Daten wieder herzustellen, wird dann immer teurer.
Aber wenn du halt nur die Festplatte löscht, dann sagt er, ja, ist alles gelöscht, dann wird es halt nur überschrieben. Und wenn man nichts weiter macht, dann kann man die Platten einfach nochmal auslesen und man muss schon einmal die Nullen wirklich komplett Block für Block draufgeschrieben haben, damit das...
Ja, auf jeden Fall sind viele Nullen draufgekommen.
Weil das wär jetzt ja natürlich ein großer Schatz auf Ebay oder so. Tim Brittlaus privateste Privatfestplatte.
Da könnte man zum Beispiel schon die Probe-Podcast mit den neuen Co-Moderatoren hören.
Oder mein Sagen um wo bis nächstes Podcast-Projekt. Das könnte dann schon geleakt sein. Aber noch weiß keiner, was das ist. Trittileaks.
Ich zahl schon in die Wortspielkasse.
Dann kriegen wir den Friedensnobelpreis.
Dennis hat doch schon die Überleitung von vor 10 Minuten aufgeschnappt und wollte jetzt sagen...
Mit den neuen Macbook Pros beizahen. Also da gibt es ja einige News gerade so ein bisschen, die sich da verdichten am Horizont. Uns wurde irgendwo berichtet, ist ja egal wo, dass angeblich in Amerika schon in den ersten Stores die Macbook Pros knapp werden, was ja immer eine Deutung ist, dass irgendwie Apple nicht mehr so viele Alte hat, weil sie jetzt schon langsam auf die Produktion der neuen umstellen oder irgendwie so. Das ist dann der berühmt berüchtigte Abverkauf, nur dass Apple nicht billiger macht, im Gegensatz zu anderen. Also da könnte man sich jetzt freuen, dass neue Macbook Pros kommen, die ja mal längst überfällig sind, weil das letzte Modell ist, glaube ich, wirklich Mai 2009 oder so, das mit dem Dual-GPU in gleichzeitig. Also der von alleine umschalten konnte, das war die Neuerung letztes Jahr. Vorher musste man von Hand umschalten mit Auslangen und so. Bei dem, was letztes Jahr Mai rauskam, wurde dann einfach während des Betriebes automatisch umgeschaltet. Du musstest nichts mehr machen.
Mit 2010 kam das letzte raus, im April 2010.
April ist echt lang, es sind neun Monate inzwischen.
April 2010.
Sie haben ja schon ewig hier.
Von diesen Unibody-Geräten haben wir auf jeden Fall auch schon einige Serien immer so ein bisschen hochgebessert. Obwohl im Moment 15 Zoll, Late 2008 wurde das introduced.
Wie lange sind die Abstände zwischen den einzelnen Analyses?
Late 2008, dann gab es mit 2009.
Also auch schon so einen neuen Monat, oder?
Und jetzt mit 2010 war der letzte.
Echt? Das war auch ein Jahr lang? Verstehe. Also, ist krass, wie die das bei Apple hinkriegen. Also die ganze Computerindustrie irgendwie, gehst du in den Laden, kaufst den Rechner, gehst du den nächsten Tag hin, ist schon wieder ein neuer da, bei Apple hast du ein Jahr lang das gleiche Ding und die kriegen es glatt hin, ein Jahr zu dem gleichen Preis zu verhökern. Das ist schon ganz schön krass. Egal, also wir hoffen, ich hoffe, weil ich will einen neuen haben, dass bald mal ein neues MacBook Pro kommt. Aber jetzt ließt man gestern, glaube ich schon, oder heute, dass Intel den Chipsatz verkackt hat für, das ist dieser Sandy Bridge hier, ne? Genau, also wenn man davon ausgeht, dass Apple auch in den neuen MacBook Pros die Laptop-Variante von dem Sandy Bridge Chip einsetzt und auch den passenden Chipsatz, weil es gibt von Nvidia nichts mehr, weil die da Lizenz- Schwierigkeiten haben, da sie streiten sich da so ein bisschen. Deswegen gibt es nur Chipsatz von Apple, Quatsch von Intel dazu. Und dieser Chipsatz hat wohl gerade einen Hardware-Bug und zwar soll wohl ein minimaler Teil der Chipsätze nach einer Weile auch erst Probleme mit irgendwie SATA-Connection haben, sodass die Verbindung zur Platte langsamer wird, weil die haben dann immer mehr Fehler auf der Leitung. Also es funktioniert wohl weiterhin, aber die Fehler sorgen dafür, dass immer das neu übertragen werden muss oder irgendwie so und deswegen wird es einfach nur langsamer.
Also ich bin mal, ich hab bei Heise gelesen, so ja, ja, ist nur ein kleiner Prozentsatz betroffen im einstelligen Prozentbereich. Einstelliger Prozentbereich heißt im schlimmsten Fall 9%. Das ist jedes zehnte Gerät. Wenn das jetzt so zwei, drei Prozent sind, ich will das nicht wenig, dann sollen sie es schon mal austauschen. Ja, machen sie auch.
Also da gibt es einen riesen Rückruf. Intel sagt, sie gehen davon aus, dass sie 300 Millionen Dollar weniger Umsatz machen dadurch und gleichzeitig noch 700 Millionen Dollar Kosten haben durch diese Umtauschaktion. Die ganzen Hersteller rudern schon zurück und nehmen die Motherboards irgendwie. Da muss ja das gesamte Motherboard getauscht werden. Ziehen die schon aus dem Markt und so. Und wenn es halt der Laptop-Version des Chipsatzes auch betrifft, und das soll wohl der Fall sein, glaube ich, dann kann auch Apple gerade nicht releasen, weil sie erstmal alle Boards zurückgeben müssen. Und den korrigierten Chipsatz gibt es erst wohl auch ab Ende Februar. Also das heißt, das ganze Sandy Bridge Zeug verschiebt sich jetzt erstmal so ein bisschen. So gesehen um vier Wochen. Weil dann muss ein so genanntes neues Stepping her. Das betroffene Stepping ist B2 und das nächste bereinigtes Stepping wäre dann B3 und das kommt erst Ende Februar. So läuft das da.
Aber du hast doch schon mit dem letzten neuen MacBook erzählt, dass du, wenn eins kommt, dass du ja sofort holst. Dann hast du es dir nicht geholt.
Echt, hab ich das?
Wir schauen nach im Mobile-Mix.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Ich glaube, du erzählst doch von Anfang an, dass du jetzt beim nächsten neuen MacBook holst.
Ja, das ist bestimmt seitdem das Ding jetzt zwei Jahre alt ist. Inzwischen hab ich es schon auf vier geschafft. Es tut auch immer noch seinen Dienst. Es sieht aus wie Sau. Läuft aber eigentlich immer noch nicht schlecht. Ich hab immer mal wieder die Platte irgendwie abgedeckt. Hab jetzt hier so eine 640er drin. Und die tut eigentlich. Und ich könnte jetzt theoretisch nochmal fett irgendwie Money reinstecken und mir eine SSD holen. Das würde bestimmt nochmal eine Menge ausmachen. Aber dann wär nicht das schneller, was ich schneller haben will.
Du willst ja aber vor allen Dingen Grafikpower schnell, oder? Eigentlich alles.
Das muss ja dann höchstwahrscheinlich auch wieder 4 Jahre halten. Deswegen bin ich auch immer so ein Fan von rechts unten. Weil da hat man lange seine Ruhe und ist erstmal irgendwie zufrieden und happy. Und das Ding hier war auch ein rechts unten Modell, glaube ich. Und es rockt.
Also wäre mein Alter jetzt nicht durch diesen 9 so spontan ersetzt worden. Wäre der auch noch total super nach über 3 Jahren gewesen. Und der war auch damals rechts unten. Haben wir ja hier in deinem...
Ja, aber nach 3 Jahren ist es doch dieses... Die 200 Megahertz mehr, die machen eigentlich echt nichts mehr fett. Also ob dein MacBook jetzt hier 2,5...
Naja, aber so ein Unterschied zwischen i7 und Core 2 Duo ist schon da.
Ja, aber das ist ja nicht das rechts unten Modell Unterschied. Die haben doch alle ein i5 oder ein i7, oder? Also das ist doch, du kriegst doch... I7 ist schon das rechts unten Modell. Jaja, im Allgemeinen ist das doch dein Unterschied von so 200, 300 Megahertz zu schweben.
Und ein bisschen mehr Cache und Ditto und Ditto, ja.
Also nach zwei Jahren ist das doch so, naja, alles eine Larmheit.
Klar, aber du wirst dann sagen wir mal wieder erst ein halbes Jahr später von der aktuellen Generation überholt, weil du noch mal das Extra Plus hattest. Es geht schon, also klar. Wenn ich jetzt nicht rechts unten hätte, dann hätte ich jetzt wahrscheinlich nur 2 Gigahertz anstört. Was hab ich denn? 2,3 habe ich sogar noch. Oder nur?
Oh, was ist der alt?
2,33 habe ich genau.
Krass.
Sind auch 4 Gigabyte drin, von denen ich nur 3 nutzen kann, weil es noch alter Chipsats irgendwie, der konnten wir benutzen. Nö, mein RAM ist eigentlich gar nicht so ein Problem, also das geht eigentlich. Ich bin jetzt hier nicht so der, der andauernd hier seinen Virtual Box mit so einem dicken Windows hochzieht. Ich glaube, da bräuchte dann wirklich auch mehr, das ist aber habe ich keine Zeit.
Aber die Sache ist, sobald, also ich mache ja auch nicht viel gerade auf meinem Rechner, aber ich habe gerade auch nur vier Gigabyte frei, wobei, das ist ja auch immer so eine Sache, dieses inactive, aber er sagt jetzt tatsächlich, use 3,8.
Das Blaue zum Beispiel ist nur irgendwie so Plattencache, der auch, weiß nicht, bei SSD vielleicht fast auch noch ein bisschen überholt ist, wobei RAM immer noch schneller ist als eine SSD, so muss man es ja mal sehen. Also das heißt, das Blaue kannst du noch mal abziehen. Das sieht dann also mehr so nach einem Drittel aus, als du gerade brauchst von den 8GB bis bei 3GB.
Also ich hab hier von meinen 4GB sind noch frei 11,8 MB.
Wie viel ist denn wired? Wired ist ja das, was reserviert ist in 690. Das andere ist dann halt so noch in the flux. Also das Rote ist wirklich das, was so richtig hart...
Naja, aber er wird langsam. Also wenn ich jetzt nur 2 GB drin hätte, dann würde das Ding schon swappen ohne Ende. Und 4 GB will man schon haben. 8 wären mir echt lieber. Das ist so ein Grund, warum ich...
16,24.
Ja, okay, man kann es immer noch verdoppeln, das stimmt schon, aber so... Ich glaube, 8 wäre erst mal so... Damit wäre ich erst mal zufrieden. Da hat man erst mal wieder ein bisschen Luft nach oben.
Man ist nie zufrieden.
Wir wollen ja eh das... Das kündigen wir jetzt ja schon seit 3 Wochen an, oder folgen wir nicht. Wir wollen ja ein... Oh, der Hall geht gar nicht. Wir wollen ein MacBook Pro Air, genau.
Also, ist die Frage, entweder will man ein MacBook Pro Air oder ein MacBook Air Pro.
Ich hätte lieber ein MacBook Air Pro.
Ich weiß nicht, ein MacBook Pro Air?
Wieso, was ist denn an deinem nicht Pro?
Ich weiß nicht, MacBook Air an meinem ist nicht Pro. Es hat keine hintergrundbeleuchtete Tastatur, es hat keinen optischen Ausgang und da fehlt halt so einfach so ein bisschen bei dem, was ich eh schon sehe, ist halt nicht alles eingeschaltet. Ich habe eine Tastatur, aber sie leuchtet nicht. Ich habe irgendwie einen Audio-Port, aber er ist nicht digital.
Der leuchtet auch nicht.
Genau, das ist überhaupt das Problem. Das Gerät leuchtet einfach zu wenig.
Aber der Apfel leuchtet. Das ist schon mal ein Anfang.
Der Apfel leuchtet. Das wäre nochmal ein Feature, das auch mal abschalten zu können.
Nein, das geht ja nicht.
Klar geht das.
Dann drückst du F1, hältst noch weiter fest, ist aus.
Das heißt, das geht nicht.
Natürlich geht das, wenn man das reinbaut.
Aber dann würde es ja noch mal länger brauchen.
Was?
Dann würde es ja dicker werden automatisch. Dann bräuchte es noch mal extra Lämpchen dafür.
Da sollen sie was einfallen lassen. Ist mir doch egal, wie sie das implementieren.
Man kann auch so elektronische...
Schatten, LCD, Dürber bauen, irgendwas dunkel machen, dimmer. Gibt es so viele Leute, die kleben das Teil ab, wenn sie das auf Performances benutzen, so DJs und so? Die wollen ja nicht die ganze Zeit so fünf Äpfel in ihr Publikum reinstrahlen.
Über blaue LEDs herziehen, aber den Apple separat beleuchtet haben wollen.
Naja, so eine tolle Kamera und so weiter. Also ich könnte mir schon so ein paar Pro-Features für meinen R vorstellen, aber ich möchte vor allem, dass es ein R ist. Ich möchte vor allem, dass es leicht und klein ist. Dann gibt es aber so ein MacBook Pro. Das soll vor allem Pro sein, aber dann halt so R, wie es geht. Verstehst du, was ich meine?
Also ich hätte auch gerne mein Pro.
Pro R, das kommt.
Jetzt hat gerade mein Bumper mein iPhone gerettet.
Oder sein iPhone dein Bumper, je nachdem.
Also ich meine, beim R ist ja auch der Formfaktor ganz entscheidend. Ist ja klein auch. Und ich hätte ja gerne so ein 17 Zoll ohne CD-ROM und so weiter. Hat man ja alles schon. Ein leicht. Also so ein 17 Zoll so leicht wie möglich und so Pro wie möglich.
So Pro wie möglich.
Ich hätte gerne so ein ausfaltbares MacBook, was man so in die Hosentasche problemlos, so Streichholzschachtelgröße, was man dann so ausrollen kann. Oder aufblasen. Aufblasen wäre auch okay.
MacBook Pro.
Das wäre mal ein echtes MacBook Air hier.
Ich putze mein iPhone, guck nicht so.
So und jetzt bin ich aber sehr gespannt, was in diesem Themenkomplex, den wir jetzt so angefangen haben, denn noch so alles an wunderschönen Dingen drinne steckt.
Oh, ist das schick sauber jetzt.
Naja, die Frage ist, ist das Themenkomplex jetzt gerade Hardware im Allgemeinen oder Mac?
Jetzt musst du dich entscheiden. Tor 1, Tor 2 oder Tor 3.
Willst du mit dem Mobile-Max-Helikopter?
Hab ich wieder irgendeine Fernsehsendung gesehen?
Für Soundboard brauchen wir Herzblatt. Zusammenfassung von Susi.
Das hab ich neulich in einem Meeting gehört, dass irgendjemand sagte, ich mach dann mal die Susi. Ich wusste nicht, was das bedeutet. Ich schreib die Zusammenfassung.
Kennst du Herzblatt, die Sendung?
Die kam irgendwann mal vor 20 Jahren mit Rudi Carell im ARW-Vorabendprogramm.
Dann haben sich die Kandidaten so mit komischen Fragen beschnuppert. Dann musste sich der eine, der es sich aussuchen konnte, eine Zusammenfassung bekommen von einer lasziv sprechenden Susi, die dann noch mal die letzten Fragen... Jetzt musst du dich entscheiden.
Möchtest du den...
Achso, den willst du das schlanke MacBook Air mit Elfzoll haben? Mit seinen kleinen, süßen, weichen Tasten und den schliffigen zwei USB-C. Du, ich hab mal bei Beate Use gearbeitet, da gewinnt man sich einen gewissen Stil. Oder möchtest du die Power-Maschine, das MacBook Pro, den Tanker unter den Performance-Schweinen, der ist dir so richtig besorgt? Herzblatt Pro.
Spätestens jetzt muss...
Man kann direkt anrufen, 0172-400-412 und nochmal die 4. Was? Susi Müller, so heißt er.
Und dann?
Dann hat man es aber abgeraten, weil wenn die ihre Nummer hier verbreitet, ihre Büronummer...
Wieso, handelt es sich um eine richtige Person, oder was?
Das kannst du sagen, man hat es aber abgeraten, wahrscheinlich.
Dann kannst du sagen, sprich doch für uns mal den Bummsack-Return, Sendungszusammenfassungs...
susimüller.de Ich könnte dir so lange stalkern, bis sie dir das freiwillig und für umsonst macht.
Stimmt nur von Herzblatt.
Jetzt sind gerade alle froh, die ihn knistern hatten.
Jetzt hast du alles versaut. Jetzt ruft da keiner mehr an.
Jetzt war ich auch gar nicht vorbereitet. Das hab ich gar nicht antizipiert.
Die will ja auch ein bisschen Kapital schlagen.
So ist es ja nicht. Aber so ein Snippet von ihr hätte ich gerne. So Tim, jetzt musst du dich entscheiden.
Die hat doch bestimmt auch irgendwann mal Tim gesagt.
Du meinst die höfliche Art des Tim-Out?
Ich bin schockiert.
Was ist denn nun schon wieder? Das hat mich jetzt einfach aus der Spur geworfen.
Susi hat so viele aus der Bahn gebracht.
Wir haben gerade den Timme 20 Jahre zurück katapultiert. Der braucht inzwischen eine Weile, bis er wieder nach vorne kommt.
Wollen wir wieder über Technik reden und Geräte und so? Ich hab ja, also ich bin ja, ihr erinnert euch ja noch an diesen Fuck-Up mit dieser Time-Capsule.
Das war doch vor zwei, drei Sendungen schon, oder?
Ja.
Wir brauchen auch noch am Anfang, bei Mobamex, so wie bei Lost so. Previously on Mobamex.
Quicktime ist scheiße.
All Events occur in real time.
Wenn mir nicht gleich Web-M-Codex in Cellius breng ich dich auf.
Aber dann einfach so als Preview. Ich meine, das wäre dann wahrscheinlich auch wieder was, was von den Hörern kommen müsste. Aber das ist ja nicht zu leisten. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall. Dachte ich mir dann so in meinem Jugendlichen Leichtsinn, also eigentlich bin ich ja mit diesem Feature Set als Internet-Router von der Time Capsule nicht zufrieden. Und zwar, was die Summe an Features betrifft. Ich bin allerdings relativ zufrieden gewesen mit der Qualität der Features, die es hatte. Das ist ja dieser typische Apple-Effekt. Du hast irgendwie nicht so viele Features, aber dafür sind die paar, die es dargibt, die sind dann in der Regel ja auch zu Ende gedacht. Oder zumindest zu Ende implementiert. Die Ausnahme bestätigt dann natürlich wieder die Regel, wie auch immer. Dann habe ich halt diesen Fuck-Up mit diesem Multicast festgestellt und dann war das Ding für mich erstmal so ein bisschen diskreditiert, weil ich irgendwie keinen Router haben will, der nicht bootet. Jetzt habe ich erstmal keinen Multicast mehr in meinem Netz. Jetzt weiß ich auch, dass es das Problem ist, sodass ich das auch wieder umgehen könnte, sodass ich theoretisch diese Time Capsule auch verwenden könnte. Aber die ist ja auch langsam als Backup-Medium und so. Und deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob das Ding nicht vielleicht on its way out ist.
Und deswegen ist jetzt dein anderer Kasten wieder am Start.
Anderer Kasten?
Na, wie heißt der hier? Der Drobot.
Den Drobot habe ich eh, weil das für mich nur ein Auslagerungsgerät ist. Es ist kein Backup-Gerät. Aus den bekannten Problemen mit diesem Drobot, dass es ja immer mehr Mind-Platz zu haben, als tatsächlich da ist. Und deswegen kannst du das für Time Machine ja nicht benutzen. Weil er dann anfängt, mehr Daten zu schreiben, als da sind. Und dann fängt das Ding an zu threschen. Und das ist jetzt irgendwie nicht so richtig das, was ich eigentlich haben will. Wie auch immer, andere Diskussionen. Dann hab ich mich halt so umgeguckt, was es so gibt. Ich hab dann auch während dieser Periode, wo ich hier so unzuverlässige Netzsituationen hatte, allerlei Geräte mal einfach so bei meinem Lieblingshändler rausgetragen und angeschlossen, um irgendwie zuverlässig Netz zu bekommen. Und hab mal die Realität wieder gesehen, wenn man irgendwie so diese hässlichen Geräte benutzt. Dann kam mir als erstes so ein Cisco Linksys irgendwie an die Leitung. Da hab ich wirklich gestaunt. Also, dass man sich sowas im Jahre 2011 noch leistet, so ein User Interface zur Konfiguration. Ich hab da überhaupt nicht durchgeblickt. Das war so ein technisches Geschwurbel. Wie kann man sowas bringen? Klar, ich kannte so die meisten Begriffe, aber so ein paar waren mir auch so ein bisschen unklar. Also Sachen, die wahrscheinlich ganz anders heißen, aber dann so in ihrer Lingo eben so und so sind. Ich kann jetzt keine Beispiele bringen. Das Ding ging auch relativ schnell wieder raus. Und dann dachte ich mir so, naja, nimmst du mal eine Fritz Box. Hat ja nette Features. Da sind ja auch einige Sachen drin, die ich sehr sinnvoll finde. Zum Beispiel finde ich es einfach sehr angemessen, heute ein Gerät rauszubringen, was einfach Telefonie-Funktionalität mit reinbringt. Jetzt wo wir da so Internet-IP-Konvergenz haben.
Wo das eh alles schon VoIP ist.
Ja, und da ist dieser Fritz-Box-Ansatz wirklich gut. Weil du kannst da einfach Rufnummern konfigurieren, du kannst da deinen ZIP-Account rein konfigurieren, dann bist du da auch instantan mit dieser Nummer erreichbar. Kannst das aber genauso auf deine analogen und per ISDN angeschlossenen Telefone durchschalten lassen oder eben auch deckt, was auch noch mit drin ist. Wie eben auch deine normale ISDN-Leitung, wenn du eine hast. Ich hab dieses 7390, dieses rechts unten Modell, von dem wir mal hier hingestellt, zum Testen. Und dann hast du auch noch einen Anrufbeantworter drin und der schickt dir eine Mail. Und dann hast du irgendwie ein Faxgerät drin und der schickt dir das Fax als Mail. Das ist doch das, was man die ganze Zeit will. Früher hat man sich da immer 1000 Geräte für gebaut und ist wahnsinnig geworden. Und jetzt steckt das halt in so einer kleinen Büchse drin und dann denke ich mir so, okay. Na ja, es war halt erst mal so die Experience, alles mal irgendwie ausprobieren, alles mal anklicken und es ging eigentlich auch irgendwie so im Wesentlichen. Ich hatte am Anfang Probleme mit dem Teil, ich habe so ein Firmware-Update gemacht, dann bootet der irgendwie nicht. Also ich habe immer noch so den Verdacht, ich habe immer nicht so viel Zeit, das permanent zu testen. Man will ja auch nicht die ganze Zeit sein Internet immer wieder ausschalten. Aber ich habe zum Beispiel noch so ein Issue, dass ja einfach Softbooting bleibt da irgendwie hängen, muss ich irgendwie Kabel rausnehmen, also Strom entziehen, dann bootet er irgendwie zuverlässig. Das sind schon so Sachen, wo ich mir denke, so...
Do not want.
Do not want, aber immerhin geht es.
Der Strom habe ich, denke ich, noch relativ selten abgezogen. Ich glaube noch nie.
Na, weil er wahrscheinlich bei dir einfach bootet. Aber wenn er halt nicht bootet und es nur so geht, dann würde es das auch häufiger tun. Na ja, so. Und dann hatte ich alles erstmal eingerichtet. Man merkt ja dann immer erst nach einer Weile, was eigentlich ist. Kommen wir zu den Sachen, die ich wirklich schwierig finde. Also, also erstmal, du kannst deinen DNS-Server nicht einstellen.
Was?
Nicht im Web-Interface zumindest.
Say what?
Ja, genau. Das ist ja so dieser Level mit diesen komischen Alice-Plaste-Boxen, die sie dir, wenn du so ein Alice-Account klickst, dann kriegst du ja auch so ein Polo-Router, wo du das auch nicht einstellen kannst. Wo ich mir denke, klar, natürlich wollen sie das nicht, weil dann können sie ihren bekloppten Alice, du hast hier falsche Domäne eingegeben, willst du nicht Werbung sehen, Dienst einbauen, den hatte ich natürlich dann auch erstmal wieder vor der Nase, den habe ich jetzt schon seit Monaten nicht mehr gesehen, weil ich diesen Alice-DNS-Router, den DNS-Server nicht benutze. Dann kam das irgendwie, ich klickte halt rum, wo kann man denn hier den DNS-Server einstellen? Ging nicht. Ja, geht nochmal gecheckt, dass ich auch im Experten-Modus war. Gibt es ja auch noch so einen Experten-Modus. Aber auch für Experten scheint der DNS-Server dann doch ein bisschen zu anspruchsvoll zu sein. Dann habe ich rausgefunden, wie das geht. Und zwar musst du ja sowieso, also eine Fritz-Box muss man mit an einem Telefon betreiben. Also du brauchst ein Telefon, um dieses Gerät zuverlässig betreiben zu können, weil so bestimmte Funktionalitäten, wie zum Beispiel ein Rücksetzen auf die Betriebseinstellungen, also die Auslieferungseinstellungen. Was heißt das?
Da brauchst du ein Telefon, wieso?
Werkseinstellungen.
Weil es da keine Taste gibt, mit der du das machen kannst oder sonst irgendwas, sondern du musst das über das Telefon machen, abnehmen und dann, genau, Werkseinstellungen. Und dann irgendwie... Im Webinterface?
Ja.
Ja, aber das Ding bootete ja nicht.
Ach, das hat man ja nicht...
Ich wollte es in irgendeinen definierten Zustand bringen, es bootete nicht.
Ach, das war einfach kaputt?
Ich wusste nicht, was es war. Es bootete nicht und irgendwie so... Ging irgendwie nicht.
Multicast.
Geht das im Web auch? Hab ich da was übersehen?
Also ich glaube da, also zumindest, die letzte Fritzbox, die ich geklickt hatte, aber das ist auch schon ein Jahr her.
Ja, ja, das ist bei Zurücksetzen.
Zurücksetzen.
Und da gibt's...
Tatsächlich Werkseinstellungen. Nicht jetzt, nicht jetzt bitte. Ich weiß nicht, ich hatte halt intuitiv einfach so einen kleinen, wo man so seinen Kugelschreiber reinsteckt und dann hält man den zehn Sekunden gedrückt, irgendwie weiß ich jetzt, ich war wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen Applekrank. Was man aber jetzt tun muss ist, man braucht jetzt trotzdem das Telefon, um nämlich den DNS-Servo einzustellen, brauchst du das Telefon. Ja, weil es dann nämlich so eine Kombination gibt, die ich jetzt nicht mehr auswendig weiß, weil sowas vergisst man natürlich, aber es war irgendwie sowas mit Lattenzaun, 96 Sterne, 7 Sterne oder irgendwie sowas. Und dann macht er kurz Toot und dann läuft ein Telnet-Server auf dem Teil. Nein. Und dann kannst du dich mit Telnet einloggen, triffst eine Shell.
Das kannst du auch, wenn du eine Konfigurationsdatei hochlätst.
Hochladen.
Du kannst über dieses neue Firmware installieren, kannst du auch eine spezielle Konfigurationsdatei hochladen, die dir das auch freischaltet.
Na guck an. Ich behaupte auch nicht, dass ich alles weiß. Wenn ich sie fritzbrücke, dann sag ich, das war meine Experience. Das war so, wie dieses Gerät auf mich zukam. Und DNS Server konnte man nicht einstellen. Dann Telnet, dann irgendwie CD, war Flash, VI. Und dann wirklich...
Dann hast du ein kleines Glied noch so drauf.
Und dann konnte man dann so ein DNS Server über eine Textkonfiguration machen. Also da dachte ich mir auch so, Leute, echt, also wirklich. Dann macht noch neben den Experten-Modus, macht noch so ein Pritt-Love-Modus, wo man einfach alles einstellen kann.
Internet-Operator-Modus.
Aber Tim möchte einfach sein, das router selber kaputt machen. Wobei DNS Server einstellen ist tatsächlich, dass es nicht so geht, einfach über das Interface.
Das ist essentiell. Du hast ja vorhin gesagt, die bringen hier schon die Infrastruktur für die Zensur an den Start. Vielleicht gehört das dazu, bei Fritz zu sagen, lasst mal diese DNS-Optionen raus. Das ist nicht gut.
Du fährst ja auch zu Hause einen eigenen DNS, richtig? Hatten wir mal hier in der Sendung vor zwei Sendungen, glaube ich?
Ich hab diverse eigene DNS-Server. Ich hab einen Public-DNS, den alle benutzen, theoretisch können und auch viele benutzen. Habe ich letztens nämlich mal umgestellt, von bind auf den anderen und da kann man jetzt geile Statistiken sehen. 200.000 Leute pro Stunde. 200.000 Queries pro Stunde.
200.000 pro Stunde.
Also schon richtig viel pro Sekunde.
Die Stunde hat 3600 Sekunden. Das ist ja, ich rechne mal kurz, geteilt durch 200.000, 20.000.
Und willst du noch mehr User haben, dann musst du dir die IP-Adresse sagen.
Ja, die steht sogar, glaube ich, auf ccc.de, aber ich paste die einfach mal in den Chat.
55 Request die Sekunde.
1-9-4-9-5-2-0-2-1-9-8.
194.95.202.98.
Kann man sich ja total einfach merken.
Ja, naja, ist halt...
Willst du DNS ohne Limitierung? Kannst du haben. Direkt hier bei uns auf der Line. Ich wähle 194.95.202.198. Und da kriegst du es einfach direkt besorgt. DNS-Pakete rund um die Uhr. Mit IPv6 und Almpi-Papo.
Ja, also... Das turnt ihn an.
Ja, ich finde, man muss auch mehr Sex in diese ganze Internet-Geschichte reinbringen, weil sonst ist das einfach alles zu langweilig. Ich meine, stell dir mal vor, diese ganze Sache, die wir toll finden, wäre immer nur so diese Vision von so asexuellen, verschwitzten Nerds.
Stimmt, wenn das Internet eins braucht, dann mehr Sex.
Also auf jeden Fall kann das.
Im Chat meint jemand IPv6.
Das Internet braucht mehr Sex.
Nee, aber eigenen Nameserver installieren hatte ich ja letztes Mal schon anmoderiert und ich hab auch in meinem Blog schon einen Artikel geschrieben, wie man lokal auf seiner Kiste mal einen public, also einen lokalen Resolver hat, um sich ganz unabhängig von...
Ich bringe das DNS-Thema mal zu Ende. Ich bin noch nicht ganz fertig mit meiner Fritzbox, aber vielleicht ist das jetzt auch mal gut.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Also ich sag nur jetzt an der Stelle einfach kurz, dass es relativ einfach ist, sich einen eigenen DNS-Server zu installieren. Also wenn man einen Server hat mit Route-Access, ist es easy, dann DNS-Resolver hinzusetzen. Auf seinem lokalen Rechner kann man das auch machen. Das ist nicht wirklich sinnvoll, weil zentrale DNS-Server haben halt den Vorteil, dass man den Cache her benutzen kann und dadurch das sehr schnell wird. Weil schon tausend Leute spiegel.de aufgerufen haben, dann musst du nicht auch nochmal durch die ganze Resolver-Chain durch, um spiegel.de zu resolven. Das ist einfach im Cache und Bumzack-Return sozusagen. Aber wenn man sich halt ganz unabhängig machen will und immer für alle Fälle lokal einen hat und irgendwas geht nicht so, wie man jetzt stehen bleibt, startet man seinen eigenen lokalen Nameserver. Hab ich drüber geblockt.
Und womit verbindet der sich dann im Server-Server?
Der macht halt ganz normal...
Schreib mir mal deinen Blog-Post-Link.
Der geht halt direkt auf die Root-Server, die einzelnen Buchstaben, die es gab. Die Root-Server sind ja dem Alphabet nach durchgedingens weltweit verteilt und der fragt dann halt die ab.
Ach so, die zentralen hier.
Das ist dann die Master-Root-Server. Eigentlich soll man die ja nicht so benutzen. Das heißt, die großen Provider sollten die Root-Server nicht an die Endkunden ausliefern, sondern das zwischendurch abfedern. Aber wenn halt so ein paar Freaks wie wir das machen, dann ist das nicht so schlimm.
Ja, wie gesagt, das ist auf jeden Fall super easy aufzusetzen. Und ja, also jeder sollte meinen Nameserver auch...
Ich nehme mir das deswegen ein, weil ich bin ja von Alice zur Telekom und habe auch gedacht, Scheiße, jetzt schicken wir ja neue DNS-Server. Und jetzt muss ich erst mal gucken, was die mir da so schicken und so weiter. Und dann fiel mein, äh, shit, habe ich ja auch schon längst umgestellt. Ich nutze die von der Telekom gar nicht, sondern mach das halt auch so wie Hucke. Wir könnten auch so internationale Beziehungen aufbauen und uns gegenseitig so irgendwie abfragen.
Durchruten. Ruf mich an, damit ich dich mal so richtig durchruten kann.
Der hat ja heute Modus, oder?
Jetzt sehen wir auch gleich den Film aus.
Angetix Zartes hier.
Kommen Sie sitzen wir hier nackt rum?
Ich finde das immer super, wenn ich mich an so einem Gerät abarbeiten kann. Ich muss noch ein bisschen was zu dieser Fritzbox sagen. Ich bin ja auch wirklich, also ich will gleich sagen, ich will das jetzt gar nicht in, also man kann das betreiben. Es gibt allerdings ein nachhaltiges, technisches Problem, was mich derzeit wirklich, wirklich, wirklich ärgert. Zunächst einmal zu den guten Seiten, abgesehen von diesem Feature Set als solchen. Also was ich gut finde, auch wenn ich es noch nicht zum Einsatz gebracht habe, noch nicht genau weiß, mit wieviel Hürden das so ist, man kann halt auch wirklich Routen konfigurieren. Das geht dann wiederum im User Interface. Den Establer kannst du nicht einstellen, aber Routen kannst du irgendwie machen. Das verstehe ich nun wirklich überhaupt nicht, aber meinetwegen. Das heißt, du kannst dann auch mal so, was weiß ich, noch ein zusätzliches Netzlokal haben. Das wäre zum Beispiel eine Lösung hier für meine Multicast-Probleme unter Umständen, weiß ich nicht. Das fehlt ja bei den meisten Routern. Man kann das Ding auch in so einem DSL-Modem-Only-Betrieb machen. Das heißt, ich kann dann, wenn ich mit dem NAT zum Beispiel vielleicht nicht ganz so zufrieden bin, das vielleicht nur so als Modem benutzen und was andere macht dann irgendwie PPP und das eigentliche IP, das wäre auch noch eine Variante.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, da hat man nur noch.
Dann ist es wirklich nur ein Modem. Da kann man so ein Teil immer noch im Regal liegen haben, falls mal ein Modem kaputt gegangen ist. Kann man das Ding dafür auch noch benutzen.
Was ich ganz geil finde, was es hat, was kaum ein Router hat, ist Port-Prioritisierung. Also man kann sich sein Port 22 richtig schön schnell machen und muss sich dann nicht vom Torrent kaputt machen lassen oder so.
Stimmt, das hab ich gesehen, das hab ich aber noch nicht probiert.
Das funktioniert super. Also man kann einzelne Rechner prioritisieren oder einzelne Ports prioritisieren.
Ja, aber was ich nicht verstehe, ist zum Beispiel mit diesem merkwürdigen, das finden die wahrscheinlich lustig, mit diesem Fritz.box, was du da eingibst. Was ja sozusagen auch erst mal nur funktioniert, wenn das Ding dann auch dein DNS-Server ist sozusagen.
Er ist ja noch unter der RP erreichbar.
Ja, aber was ist das denn? Bonjour ist jetzt wie alt? 10 Jahre?
Gefühlt zumindest.
Gibt es irgendwas, was dazu eine Alternative sein könnte, was man stattdessen verwenden sollte? Nein.
Mit dem Fritz.box, ich finde das okay. Ich finde es bei den Telekom-Geprineten...
Wenn du dann so zwei Geräte nebeneinander stehen hast, dann...
Ich habe ja so eine Telekom-Geprinete Fritz.box und die heißt dann Speedport irgendwas, mit einem ganz furchtbaren User-Interface. Und die ist dann unter speedport.ip zu erreichen. Und zwar nur da. Also wenn du die IP-Adresse direkt eingibst, dann mach dann redirect auf speedport.ip. Und das ist total nördlich, weil wenn du dann einen eigenen DNS-Server hast, kommst du halt auf das Scheißding nicht mehr drauf. Das ist Telekom-Intelligenz.
Ja, aber ich meine, was spricht dagegen, einfach mal da Bonjour einzubauen? Ja, kannst du alles machen, finde ich der Developer davon. Einfach Punkt local und fertig. Und dann meldet sich das Ding über seine Mac-Adresse Punkt local. Und dann kannst du es halt immer sehen. Dann ist es einfach da, egal in welchem Zustand das ist.
Man muss auch mal sagen, wenn man so einen Bonjour-Browser anhat, der einem alles meldet, was er so Bonjour sagt, das scrollt auch Linux und BSD und Windows-Kisten und wird nicht alle da alle durchscrollt. Also kann halt auch keiner erzählen, dass das jetzt nicht verbreitet wäre.
Ja, in der Linux gibt es das alles. Das ist echt nicht das Problem. Das ist nur so ein, weiß ich nicht, hat noch keiner verstanden, dass das mal wichtig sein könnte.
Aber wie kriegt man denn Bonjour in einen Web-Browser rein?
In den Web-Browser? Das war nicht in den Web-Browser. Dieses Gerät soll sich per Bonjour melden und sagen, dass es da ist.
Na, wem sollst du das sagen? Dem Web-Browser doch.
Zum Beispiel.
Genau, und wie gebe ich das dann? Muss ich doch da wiederum die Adresse?
Nein, dann startest du einfach dein Safari und gehst in das Bonjour-Menü.
Wenn man es in Safari eingeschaltet hat zum einen.
Oder du machst halt fritzbox.local.
Wenn du es nicht ausgeschaltet hast.
Fritzbox.local ist doch... Das ist eines wenigstens genormt.
Und kann das irgendjemand außer...
Das eine geht nur, wenn du das Gerät selbst bereits als DNS-Server verwendest. Nur dann. Kannst du es nicht einfach auf den Tisch stellen und dann sagt es Hallo, ich bin ein Gewähl, benutze mich.
Das übliche Prozedere wird ja sein, dass sich der Mensch, das aufbaut, das Ding, verbindet per WLAN mit dem...
Das ist mir das übliche Prozedere.
Das übliche Prozedere bei Apple...
Bei den Apple-Geräten ist genau das.
Du steckst die Apple Base Station ran und in deinem Airport-Utility erscheint die, weil das Ding halt Bonjour spricht.
Ja, wenn du einen Mac hast, aber wenn du was anderes hast, wenn du irgendwie ein Windows hast, dann hast du keine Chance dafür.
Gibt es nicht...
Wenn du iTunes installiert hast, hast du auch Bonjour.
Ja, du hast dann Bonjour, aber du hast dann nicht dieses Airport-Utility. Oder gibt es das für Windows? Du musst es halt extra installieren. Hier muss ein Webbrowser aufmachen, da steht dann auf der Karte drauf, gib Fritz.box ein und du bist drauf auf dem Ding.
Wenn du es bereits als DNS-Server verwendest, aber wenn du es eben nicht als DNS...
Ja, wenn du mich einfach mit dem WLAN verbunden hast, ist das doch...
Ja, aber wenn es nicht konfiguriert ist und noch nicht da ist und du auch nicht das WLAN benutzen willst, sondern du es einfach da in ein Internetkabel reinsteckst und dann eine lokale 169er-Adresse hast, mein Gott, das ist einfach Internetstandard. Das hat man einfach so zu tun. Da würde ich überhaupt gar nicht darüber diskutieren. Klar, wenn die sich alles Mögliche einfallen lassen. Jeder kann sich alles Mögliche einfallen lassen, aber die Fritzbox ist nicht das Zentrum der Welt. Was ist mit dem nächsten Hersteller? Der macht dann, was weiß ich, Hasenbärchen.pfotenhase. Ist doch ganz einfach. Musst du nur Hasenbärchen.pfotenhase eingeben. Bist du blöd? Ist doch ganz einfach. Ja, und das nächste Gerät erfindet das Internet dann wieder neu. Am besten noch neue IP-Adressen.
Die haben das Internet erfunden, die tragen halt eine default DNS-Nahme ein.
Tut das denn jetzt so weh?
Ich will aber nicht IP-Adressen eingeben und ich will auch nicht irgendwie...
Darum sollst du ja auch Fritzbox eingeben.
Das geht aber nur, wenn dieses Gerät bereits für mich der DNS-Server ist. Ja, das ist es halt nicht immer.
Wie gesagt, ich hab jetzt unsere Frage gekuckt.
Ich find hier nicht mal... Also um das jetzt mal vielleicht so als Mediator. Also ich muss ja schon auch sagen, dass ich es nicht schlecht finde, wenn alle Geräte einfach mit einem Punkt Local, die lokal halt im Netz sind, zu erreichen werden.
Ich sag ja auch gar nicht, dass es schlimm ist, aber...
Ich will diesem Gerät einen Namen geben. Ich will nicht, dass die alle Fritzbox heißen. Ich möchte dem Teil einen Namen geben, das heißt ein Lumpi und dann soll es Lumpi.Local heißen. So wie mein Mixer Mixer heißt und mein iMac heißt Eris und mein Laptop heißt Antares.
Der whiskymixer, mixwürzigen whisky mit dem whiskymixer.
Ich will Freund sein mit dieser Fritzbox, aber sie ist der Meinung, sie müsste mir da so ein System überstülpen und da bin ich einfach nicht dafür. Wie auch immer. Popularisierung, okay meinetwegen, aber jetzt kommt es hart. Was das Ding nicht kann, ist es kann kein Nutt-PMP. Also ich kann natürlich denken, aber es hat doch UPNP, der Microsoft-Standard. Der kann doch alles. Ja. Vielleicht. Kann sein. Ich höre auch von Leuten, die haben damit kein Problem, aber seitdem ich hier mit dieser Fritz-Box ins Internet angeschlossen bin, funktioniert für mich einfach back to my Mac nicht zuverlässig. Bis in der Regel gar nicht. Diese Teile kommen hier nicht raus, die kriegen ihre Ports nicht freigeschaltet. Das ist einfach die Realität. Ich starte hier meinen BitTorrent-Line und der sagt mir, ich hätte jetzt gern diesen Port, konnte ich aber nicht freischalten. Dann starte ich das Ding nochmal neu und dann mache ich irgendwie 50x Randomize und irgendwann ist es dann grün. Und dann beenden und dann wieder starten. Ich hab hier irgendwie Podcast per BitTorrent, wollte ich irgendwie anbieten, wie ich das hier immer mache. Ich starte einfach meinen Client, ich mach da diese Datei rein, dann gehe ich irgendwie nach Hause und das Ding lädt halt einfach schon mal gemütlich hoch und wenn es 100% hat, dann haben es auch alle schnell. Und hier saß ich dann da und das Teil macht irgendwie 0 Bits Upload und ich frage mich halt natürlich warum und der Grund war, dass da irgendwie nicht in der Lage ist, mit anderen Peers direkt zu connecten. Ich muss halt warten, bis die dann irgendwie connecten, was dann auch irgendwann vielleicht mal einsetzt, aber das ist nicht so genau, wie ich mir das eben vorstelle.
Dafür hat man noch eine Firewall, du gibst einfach den Port frei.
Ich will auch nicht für jeden einzelnen Computer und jedes einzelne Programm, was ich starte, einen Port freischalten.
Na ja, für alle Programme, die eine Verbindung von außen haben wollen.
Ja, viele Programme wollen bei mir eine Verbindung von außen haben. Zum Beispiel will hier jeder Computer mit Back to my Mac erreichbar sein und ich will hier Screensharing drauf machen und Peep a Po.
Was war denn nochmal der Microsoft-Standard?
Universal Plug and Play.
Und die Apple-Dinger machen dieses N?
Also Moment, UPNP ist ein riesiger Klumpatsch von Zeug. Da ist auch irgendwie Medien-Streaming und alles Mögliche drin. Und unter anderem auch dieses Port-Freischalten in Firewall. Oder in einem Nut, also Nut-Traversal. Sodass du sagen kannst, Hallo, ich bin eine Applikation und ich hätte gerne auf diesem Port Access to the Internet. Hätte ich gerne Access to the Internet. Ich hab das jetzt noch nicht so richtig zu Ende gedebuggt, aber ich hab halt auf einer Fritz-Box dann mal dankenswerterweise haben sie auch so eine Liste der aktuell freigeschalteten Ports. Das zeigen sie einem an, sowas hat ja wiederum Apple nicht. Penner. Und hab dann aber so doppelte Einträge gefunden. Also für denselben Computer derselbe Port mehrfach drin. Wo ich mich frage, warum? Also warum? Was mich den Eindruck macht, mit dass da irgendwas schief läuft. Weil warum sollte dieser Eintrag zweimal da drin sein? Also es funktioniert einfach nicht zuverlässig. Ich hab auf dem Netz gefragt, ob das für jemanden bei Leuten funktioniert und ich hab sehr unterschiedliches Feedback bekommen. Manche meinten, ja geht schon immer, noch nie ein Problem gehabt. Ich hab dann von IPv6 Native und probier's mal selber aus, auf immer Tunneln umkonfiguriert. Dann machte es auch kurzfristig den Eindruck, dass es sich verbessert hätte, aber ich komm irgendwie nicht durch. Also es ist auf jeden Fall unklar. Und ich wäre ganz froh, wenn sie einfach mal NAT PMP machen. Das sind irgendwie zwei UDP-Pakete. Da sagt das Programm, hallo, ich hätte gerne den Porten. Und dann sagt der Router, ja bitte hier. Und dann willst du ihn wirklich. Und dann sagt das Programm, ja, will ich wirklich. Und dann ist alles super. Und nicht dieser riesige UPnP-Riesen-Klumpen.
Weil ich hab gesagt, ich möchte überhaupt nicht, dass irgendwelche Programme in meiner Mutter die Firewall deaktivieren können, zerlöchern können.
Wofür hab ich denn das Ding?
Nat ist keine Firewall.
Ich kann mir sicher sein, ich möchte gerne wissen, welche Verbindungen von außen nach innen gehen.
Ja, es gibt diesen Use-Case, es gibt auch den Use-Case Convenience und wir tun mal so, als gäbe es das Nat-Problem nicht und wir saßen im echten Internet. Also das gibt es durchaus auch diese Wünsche. Gerade bei BitTorrent-Clients und diversen anderen Sachen, die hinter Nat einfach so eher scheiße funktionieren.
Ja, Webcam-Software. Ich will einfach Programme haben, die selbst sagen können, dass sie jetzt da einen Port haben wollen. Die wollen einfach empfangen. Warum sollen sie das auch nicht können? Das sind Programme, die im Internet sind und Internet ist rein und raus.
Aber welcher Standard ist denn verbreiteter?
Na, UPNP natürlich.
Und die Apple Base Stations machen aber nicht PNP oder wie ist das?
Die machen beides. Achso, das weiß ich jetzt. Warte mal, macht die auch UPNP? Ich vermute ja, ich weiß es jetzt gerade nicht.
Kann man es abschalten?
Ja, das kann man auch.
Jaja, gut.
Jaja, das kannst du alles abschalten. Gute Frage, warte mal.
Zum Beispiel auch ein ganz cooles Feature. Angenommen, wenn irgendjemand von deiner Familie kein IPv6 hat, wie ich zum Beispiel, dann könnte die Remote Desktop trotzdem starten, also Entfernte Anmeldung. Du könntest dich trotzdem drauf connecten und müsstest halt nicht manuell im Router erst mal Ports verworren, von denen du eh nicht weißt, welches genau sind und so. Das würde dann halt einfach so automatisch in dem Moment funktionieren. Also dafür ist das schon...
Ja, vor allem die Programme beenden sich und dann verschwinden diese Einträge auch wieder. Sonst hast du da einfach permanente Löcher und dann konfigurierst du mal irgendwas um. Mein Transmission hat auch am laufenden Meter andere Ports. Ich hab da extra eine Randomize-Funktion drin, dass man da halt nicht geblockt wird und so.
Ja, also hier auf der Seite...
Funktioniert halt irgendwie nicht gut. Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, ob das, ob ich da nur irgendwas falsch konfiguriert habe, dann wüsste ich nicht, was. Oder ob das halt einfach generell schwierig ist, ob das an diesem UPNP liegt. Vielleicht liegt es ja auch an meinen Clients, wobei ich glaube, dieser Transmission, der benutzt diese Lip... Lip-PNP oder Lip-UPNP sowieso, wo dann Nut-PNP und das UPNP mit drin ist.
Das war dieses Tool, was irgendjemand mal rausgebracht hat, mit dem man sich Löcher durch die Fireball schießen kann, mit UPNP. Da gab es auch so ein Satellon-Programm und so eine Open-Source-Library. Für einen Mac?
Du meinst das, was die Coding Monkeys mal gemacht haben?
Genau, das meine ich.
Na, die haben so ein... Ah, erinnere ich mich richtig. Ich glaube, das war nur so ein Wrapper, genau, so ein Coco-Wrapper für diese Library. Oder haben sie das als Nativ geschrieben?
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht. Aber irgendwie gab es so so ein Lip.
Verzeih Dom. Oder was Martin? Ich weiß gerade jetzt gar nicht. Naja, also das ist sozusagen mein Rand. Aber ich muss sagen, ich finde das extrem erstrebenswert, dass es so ein Gerät gibt, was so im Prinzip dieses Feature Set hat von dieser Fritzbox. Also das wäre ganz toll, wenn es mal so was instabil und ordentlich gäbe.
Stabil ist es, also da kannst du wirklich nichts sagen. Also meine läuft seit, ich weiß nicht, seit Monaten durch.
Na dann probier mal halt mal auf deine Rechner von außen zuzugreifen oder Ports von innen freizuschalten, gucken wie stabil das ist.
Ich habe dieses UPnP abgeschaltet, weil ich nicht möchte, dass irgendwelche Rechner in meinem Netz hier mal eben mal nachbedienen.
Wenn du das Internet auch nicht so nutzt, Max.
Wenn du kein Internet-Power-User bist, dann können wir dir leider auch nicht helfen. Dann musst du halt hinter deinem vernagelt und vernatteten Router sitzen.
Ja, ich will mich doch nicht ausschließen lassen da vom Internet.
Ich habe mich bisher nicht so ausgeschüttet.
Ich brauche da nichts zu befürchten.
Also in der Uni haben sie wieder so einen, hatte ich ja schon erzählt, diesen X-Surf mit 10.5.8, der wurde ja auch wieder von Malware befallen.
Ach ey, von Malware?
Ja, irgendwie so ein Zeug, so ein Trojaner, der so ein Irrbot hat sich da eingenistet. War auch nicht runterzukriegen mit, habt ihr in allen möglichen Stellen rausgeschmissen, gelöscht, keine Ahnung, war es neu gebootet?
MacOS ist ein Server.
Ach echt? Ich hab mal ein bisschen rumgelesen, angeblich ist das über den Remote Desktop Agent wohl passiert, also zumindest sagte man im Netz, dass dieser Bot wohl darüber kommt, aber in der Uni, wenn du das Ding wirklich 24-7 Jahre lang anhast, passiert das schon mal, dass da einer mal vorbeikommt und sich einistet.
Schlimm genug, dass es überhaupt...
Das ist hier der Anfang vom Ende. Das geht abwärts.
Naja, ich mein, das ist halt auch so ein bisschen fahrlässig, also dieses Remote Desktop Zeug, das könnte man auch einfach nur über VPN machen und dann wär's schon wieder gegessen. Da wär der Drops schon gelutscht sozusagen security-mäßig, aber...
Trotzdem, die müssen ihre Kiste, die müssen sie irgendwie dicht kriegen.
Aber jetzt haben sie jetzt ja einen NSA Security Expert geheiert. Mit dem ja alles...
NSA wie Not Safe at Apple oder was?
Na, immerhin hat der ja schon einen ganz guten Ruf, also ist jetzt kein totaler Security Nobody. Frag mich bloß, für welches Gebiet er in Einsatz kommt, ob es wirklich sich nur um iOS dreht oder ob er auch den Mac jetzt mal mit Full-Disk-Encryption und hast du nicht gesehen, beglückt.
Also meine Vögelchen sagen ja immer wieder, dass so die Leute, die da so bei Apple für Security zuständig sind, sich nicht ausreichend geliebt fühlen.
Also ich hatte früher mal einen ganz coolen Typen, der war auch bei den Cypher-Punks mit am Start. Und der hat ja so ein Plugin für die Macs geschrieben, dass man bei, wie heißt das hier, bei Apple Talk Connections, so File Sharing früher mit Apple Talk noch, da gab es so ein Plugin, dass man seine Pgp-Schlüssel dafür benutzen konnte. Habe ich mal bei Pixel Park gemacht. Das war eigentlich ziemlich cool. Aber dann ging es ja alles so den Bach runter, weil der dann Richtung OS X und dann ging das Plugin nicht mehr und so weiter und so fort. Aber der war ganz vorne mit dabei, was so eine Sache betraf. Und das war auch sein eigenes Produkt, das war nicht von Apple, sondern das hat er halt so nebenbei entwickelt.
Für Apple Talk oder für Apple Share? Also File, Transfer, AFP sozusagen, mit PGP.
Ja, Winnie, Mos, Key, Rolluto oder irgendwie so hieß der. Ich weiß gar nicht so genau.
Na ja, erzähl doch mal lieber was mit hier deinem nur so letztes Mal was erzählt hier mit IPv6, irgendwie Private Extension, tra la la, richtige IP-Adresse einschalten, dass ihr die MAC-Adresse nicht mehr in die IPv6-Adresse einblendet. Ich hab das mal ausprobiert, das hat irgendwie nicht so funktioniert.
Das hat man in der letzten Sendung, kurzer Zusammenriss, das heißt irgendwie IPv6 Privacy Extension sorgt dafür, dass die MAC-Adresse nicht mehr in der IPv6-Adresse drin vorkommt, wenn man so eine automatisch zugewiesen hat, also dieses ADHCP von IPv6, wenn man das mal so nennen kann, dieses Router Advertisement. Und da gibt es halt auf den verschiedenen Betriebssystemen gibt es ja so Sys-Controls, die kann man so setzen. Und dann gibt es auch eine Datei in etc.sysctl.conf, wo man die darauf setzen kann, dass die beim Boot auch wieder gesetzt werden. Und dann haben wir natürlich Freebies, die Linux und Apple so ein bisschen unterschiedliche Sys-Control-Namen. Die sind auch immer so durch Punkte getrennt, so eigene Domains. Und die bei Apple sieht halt ganz bisschen anders aus als das, was ich aus Google geklaut hab. Und deswegen ist da so ein bisschen die Falsche angekommen. Und ich kann jetzt noch mal kurz die Richtige in den Chat pasten und die können wir dann später irgendwo aufnehmen. Oder ich lese ja auch nochmal vor.
Kann noch jeder googeln.
Kann noch jeder googeln. Jedenfalls, was ich letztens vorgelesen hab, ist wohl falsch und das heißt net.inet6.ip6.useUnderlineTempAddr1 T-E-M-P oder T-E-M-P? T-E-M-P. Ich poste das jetzt hier nochmal in den Chat.
Aber die falschen!
Ja, also wie gesagt auch OSX.ipv6.privacy.ext Google bringt gleich auf der ersten Seite.
Ja, dann linken wir lieber gleich da, dann kriegen sie gleich mit Erklärung und alles müsst ihr auf Headshatter.
Ich paste hier nochmal, zack.
Nee, nee, das heißt nicht zack, das heißt bumm, zack und dann drückst du Return.
Achso, Moment, probieren wir gleich nochmal. Also das ist das Kommando, um es instantan einzuschalten.
Kannst du das mal in den Chat werfen?
Ja, hab ich doch schon hier.
Oh was, Viva.
Das taucht hier massenhaft schon auf.
Ja und das soll funktionieren. Genau und dann, was man in diesem Post, das dann die Hörer des Podcasts später in den Show Notes finden werden, in die sysctl.conf schreibt, dann ist es auch nach dem Reboot immer da. Naja, wie gesagt, googelt einfach im Zweifel nach OSX, IPv6, Privacy Extensions.
Und nächste Woche lesen wir die Post-Fix-Konfiguration verteilt vor.
Ja genau, da könnte man auch mehr Sex reinbringen.
Also das ist von diesem Apple-Typen. Der Apple-Typ hieß Viti Moscaritolo, war früher halt Security-Chef, oder nicht Chef, aber auf jeden Fall einer der Security-Mitarbeiter da bei Apple und das Ding hieß PGPUam. Und ich poste nochmal die Link mit der alten Software auch in den Chat, könnt euch ja da rausklinken, wenn ihr das braucht. Und das war zumindest nicht so schlecht. Da fühlte man sich so ein bisschen vorne.
Damals in Klondike.
Damals. Ist von 98 das Tool, also Dezember 98. Naja, da war ja PGP auch irgendwie groß, irgendwie innen so. Wer da schon einen Key hatte.
Wo wir jetzt sowieso gerade auf der Kommando-Zahl angekommen sind. Ich hatte ja neulich mal wieder, war ich mal wieder so Opfer von... Wo wir neulich doch... Neulich hatte ich... Was hatte ich? Ich hatte wieder so PDFs runtergeladen, die so verschlüsselt waren. Dieser ganze pure PDF. Du darfst nicht drucken. Scheiß. Wo man dann so da sitzt und sich fragt, warum.
War das bei diesen Dokumenten, die da hinten an der Wand hängen?
Genau, diese Bahn-Netzteile habe ich gesucht. Dann fühlte ich mich ein bisschen wie so ein dummer User, weil ich irgendwie nichts dagegen tun konnte. Und Apple ja ganz brav in seinem Preview dann auch We Obey the Authorities spielt. Wenn Adobe sagt, das darf nicht sein, dann darf das nicht sein. Na ja, dann habe ich irgendwie festgestellt, es gibt so ein Tool, das kann ich noch gar nicht auf mein Haupt, aber es gibt QPDF. So ein einfaches, schnell installiert. Und da sollte man einfach irgendwie rein mit dem Dokument, raus mit dem Dokument und dann ist es irgendwie befreit. Und vor allem, was ich mit dem QPDF dann auch hinbekommen habe, das war nämlich überhaupt der Anlass, dass ich damit mal ein bisschen rumgetestet hatte. Ich hatte wieder so ein Manual von irgend so einem Gerät, was ich bei mir noch gefunden habe, runtergeladen. Man findet so ein Gerät dann erstmal im Internet fragen, gibt es denn da ein Handbuch dazu, dass man mal weiß, was damit ist. Und da wird man ja auch relativ schnell fündig. Und dann kriegst du ja so PDF-Dateien von so obskuren Taiwan, Chingeling, Hongwei, Schnacker Schnacker, Butterfly, Flower Power.
Ho Chi Minh Flower Power Enterprises.
Genau. Und die haben schon wirklich merkwürdige Generatoren. Auf jeden Fall dieses PDF raffte einfach mein Browser dahin, Preview dahin, also die PDF-Engine von Mac OS X hat ganz offensichtlich damit nichts anfangen können, alles crashte, ich war nicht in der Lage, mir dieses Ding anzuzeigen. Dachte ich mir so, jetzt Adobe Reader installieren? Nein, also nur über meine Leiche. Und dann hab ich einfach dieses QPDF ausprobiert und hab einfach mal so in-out, einfach lies es ein, schreibs wieder raus, plimm, und schon hast du so ein sanitized PDF.
Das ist irgendwie nur Command Line oder was?
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, ob es da nicht noch ein nettes Interface für gibt, hab ich jetzt gar nicht geguckt, aber ich hab einfach so Brew & Style QPDF und dann hast du da einfach so ein Werkzeug, mit dem du einfach deinen ganzen PDF-Mumpitz schnell heile bekommst. Passwort da raus, kaputtes PDF raus, liest alles, also was weiß ich, ich hab's alles liest, aber es hat zumindest diesen Scheiß da gelesen. Vielleicht ist es ja auch ein valides PDF gewesen. Ich vermute aber mal nein.
Das war einer, der die Adobe PDF-Bibliothek, die ja so einen gefühlten Meter in der Breite hat, wenn man sie ins Bücherregal stellt, wahrscheinlich nur zur Hälfte gelesen hat.
Ja, war das vielleicht dieses PDF von jailbreakme.com oder?
Ich weiß nicht, hab ich jetzt auch Malware auf meinem Rechner?
Ich hatte auch irgendwie mit der Commandline wieder große Freude kürzlich und zwar ein Tool, das immer wieder mal auch mir schon bei Audio und Video größere Schmerzen weggenommen hat. Das ist ja FFmpeg. Also es ist halt schon ein Schmerz, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen und alle Commandline-Parameter in der richtigen Reihenfolge herunterbeten zu können und zu finden überhaupt erst mal. Aber meistens kann man sie sich doch ergoogeln und dann wird so Unmögliches plötzlich möglich, was mit keinem GUI-Tool geht. Also konkret hatte ich jetzt zum Beispiel den Fall, hatte Video, MKV H264, hatte dazu einen extra DTS-Audio-Stream und konnte das nicht abspielen und wollte das jetzt eigentlich in AAC oder AC3 mit ins Video-File mit reinmachen. FFmpeg erstens wieder die rettende Kraft und dann gab es noch ein anderes Tool, MKV-Merge, wo du halt genau das machen kannst. Audio-Stream, Video-Stream, Bumzack, Return und der macht dir ein schickes Video-File draus mit beidem drin, weil VLC und Mplay konnten irgendwie keinen MKV mit extra DTS-Stream abspielen. Fand ich auch erstaunlich.
Warte mal, was genau ist MKV-Merge?
Das ist ein Kommandozahlen-Tool, mit dem man alles Mögliche Tolle hinbekommt.
Also da gibt es so eine Toolspeed. MKV-Merge ist eins davon, es gibt auch MKV-Split.
MKV-Tool nix.
Mit dem Split habe ich mal ein Audio-Stream rausgenommen. Da war Russisch und Englisch drinne in einem Film, den ich back-upen wollte. Ich wollte das Russisch raushaben, weil Russisch default war und damit jemand nicht umgehen konnte.
Also das ist bei denen auch, dachte ich, oh Gott, jetzt die Doku voll scheiße und die Man-Page, keine Ahnung, was ich da jetzt anklicken muss. Und da war es aber auch genauso. Da habe ich einfach MKV-Merge, Video-File, Audio-File, Ziel-File und dann hat er irgendwie hier mit meinem Rechner bei 350% CPU-Crunch-Crunch, 8 GB, in wenigen Minuten dann zum MKV gemacht, wo das DTS dann mit drin war. Also das AC3 dann später.
Anders als bei FFmpeg wurde ja wirklich, um eine Datei von einem Format ins andere zu bekommen, schon erstmal acht Seiten.
Ja, aber das war halt der Punkt, also das Audio konvertieren und so Video konvertieren, das geht wiederum mit FFmpeg halt immer so irgendwie dann doch.
Aber immer nur irgendwie, also ich hab bisher noch keinen wirklich verbindlichen Standard gefunden, wie man da irgendwas hinbekommt.
Ja, das Problem ist halt irgendwie tatsächlich, dass auch so diese Video- und Audio-Tools, also wir haben jetzt ja schon oft so über Dinge gesprochen, ich hab ja auch gleich wieder Sapla ausprobiert oder Sapla hat ein paar Updates bekommen und ist jetzt noch zuverlässiger geworden. Aber das ist ja nur für MP4, das ist ja zum Beispiel nicht, um MKV jetzt wieder zu muxen oder zu diensten.
Um bei MKV loszuwerden.
Und Paramute hatte ich ausprobiert, das ist gleich gecrashed und ich hab auch gestaunt, dass sowieso so wenig Tools mit diesem DTS so spontan agieren wollten. Also ich hätte ja auch erwartet, dass M-Player und VLC einfach sagen können hier Video, hier Audio bitte los geht's. Ging aber nicht. Tja, Command Line Tools to the rescue. Und dann, wo wir gerade hier auch noch bei Texteingabe sind, letztens hatte ich einen Shortcut gesucht. Voll spektakuläre Geschichte. Schnallt euch schon mal an. Also ihr kennt das ja, ihr habt mehrere Pfeils in einem Folder und selektiert die so und drückt dann so Apfel I, um zu wissen, wie viel das zusammen ist. Und dann gehen so tausende Fenster auf und dann freut man sich, dass es Apfel Alt W gibt, um die auch alle ganz schnell wieder zuzumachen.
Und das Apfel Alt I entdeckt.
Genau, ich hab Apfel Alt I entdeckt, weil ich dachte früher hat er das automatisch gemacht.
Früher hat er das auch mal automatisch gemacht. Das haben sie dann irgendwann wieder abgeändert.
Weißt du, dass er dann, du markierst mehrere Dinge im Finder, drückst Apfel I und dann hat er dir nur einen Info-Dialog gezeigt und zusammengefasst, wie groß es ist. Heutzutage macht er dann 23.000 Fenster auf.
Und dann dachte ich mir, hm, der macht da so eine Palette auf, das ist eine Palette, die kannst du jetzt auch offen lassen mit Apfel Alt I und dann kannst du, egal was du ankriegst, du kriegst immer noch so eine kleine Rahmen und dann kannst du immer ein neues Icon drücken und der updatet das in diesen Fenster.
Man, übrigens heißt es gar nicht mehr Apfel-Taste, Freunde, aber doch, denn es hat noch eine, wir können noch Apfel Alt I sein.
Propeller meinste?
Propeller, ja, Command.
Warum sie da den Apple runter geschmissen haben, das war das einzige verbindliche Merkmal, auf das man sich einigen konnte.
Steve, das Apple-Logo changen demnächst, das ist immer...
Ich glaub ja eher, dass er irgendwie mal nachgezählt hat, wer es gestellt hat, dass da auf so einem MacBook irgendwie fünf Apple-Logos sind und jetzt...
Und das darf nur eins sein. Oder willst du ändern demnächst?
Das glaub ich eher nicht.
Zum Thema Shortcuts war es auch noch was Beisichtes.
Aber es fände sich ein schönes Gerücht, was man in die Welt setzen könnte.
Ja, es fängt immer langsam an so, weißt du, und dann...
Jetzt kommt Tims Shortcut der Woche.
Ja, also ich bin ja sowieso gerne so ein Tastaturbenutzer.
Ja, ich bin gerne so ein Tastaturbenutzer.
Also, ich lehne zum Beispiel Software ab, die sich nicht gut über Tastatur bedienen lässt. Das ist für mich eine echte Pein, weil ich merke immer wieder, wie viel ich mit der Tastatur mache. Zum Beispiel eine der ersten Schritte, wenn ich einen Mac neu in Betrieb nehme und mal wieder so ein... Full keyboard access, das ist das erste, was man macht, dass man einfach überall durchtappen kann. Und wenn dann mal wieder so Düsselprogramme kommen, die da irgendwie dran vorbei programmiert, die GUI da designt haben, dass du dich auf Buttons tappen kannst, da werde ich wahnsinnig.
Oder noch schlimmer, die Tab-Reihenfolge von den Feldern in irgendeiner chaotischen Reihenfolge haben.
Geht gar nicht. Und man, abgesehen davon, dass das auch eine scheiß Idee ist, weil das natürlich auch für so Accessibility-Sachen meistens der Tod ist, also hier Blinden-Support, etc. Voice-Over, diese ganzen Sachen, ist es auch einfach anstrengend. Aber darüber wollte ich gar nicht reden, sondern es gibt so einen anderen Shortcut, der da so mit rein spielt. Weil wenn man erst mal angefangen hat, viel mit Tastatur zu machen, dann will man sich natürlich auch so lange wie möglich mit der Tastatur rumhangeln. Und wo es immer schwierig wird, ist natürlich so Fenster wechseln. Und es gibt natürlich Alt-Tab, und das benutzen wahrscheinlich viele, um eben durch die Programme durchzugehen. Aber es gibt ja auch noch einen anderen Standard-Key, den wenige benutzen und den ich permanent benutze. Das merke ich immer dann, wenn ich irgendwo gegen eine Wand fahre damit. Genau, Cycle Windows, das benutze ich permanent. Und ich glaube, viele Leute tun das nicht, und ich glaube, man muss einfach mal darauf hinweisen, dass es das gibt. Jetzt ist die Frage, auf welchen Key? Also, was macht es? Man drückt die Taste und er geht von einem Fenster des Programms zum nächsten Fenster des Programms.
Und mit Shift wieder zurück.
Genau. Und auf welcher Taste hast du das liegen?
Na, ich hab's auf der, auf der es eigentlich schon immer war. Also es ist ja auch schon immer auf Zweinen, glaube ich sogar. Aber es war halt auch schon immer auf Apfel-Spitze-Klammer.
Genau, da war's nämlich mal.
Und da haben sie es weggemacht. Und jetzt ist es auf Apfel-Backtick, was irgendwie auf US-Keyboards wahrscheinlich günstiger liegt oder so.
Keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall ist es auf der deutschen, also zumindest auf der deutschen Tastatur schwierig.
Apfel-Backtick?
Na, hier da.
Diese sinnlose, überflüssige Taste da rechts oben. Wenn sie mal wirklich eine Taste entfernen wollen, die ganze Zeit werden nützliche Taste entfernt.
Also im Terminal ist das Apfel-Cursor übrigens.
Ja, ich glaub, da wären die Franz-Schules ein bisschen sauer.
Genau, das geht auch noch gelegentlich. Wie Apfel-Cursor? Apfel-Cursor geht auch noch im Terminal zum Beispiel, ja. Das stimmt.
Apfel-Cursor.
Apfel-Cursor, Tasten links, rechts und so.
Ach nee, echt?
Aber der Standard, also der Standard-Shortcut, zumindest war es eben, ewige Zeiten so, war schon Apfelspitze-Klammer und Apfelspitze-Klammer.
Und das gilt für alle Programme, weil es ist vom US-gesteuert, weil nämlich das Apfel-Terminal, Apfel-Körner-Ding geht nur im Terminal, das hat mich immer geärgert.
Ja, genau.
Nee, das hier geht auch bei Postbox zum Beispiel.
Und auch im Safari?
Und auch im Safari, in allen Fenster, das System.
Aber, und jetzt komm ich zu meinem Punkt, wenn du, also, diese Apfel kleiner größer ist bei deutschen Keyboards super, weil das liegt einfach so links unten, so, ich weiß nicht, wie ihr so arbeitet, aber ich hab eigentlich so meine linke Hand ist immer unten so in diesem Feuer, Feuer, Feuer-Bereich so. Caps Lock, FN, also auf dem Laptop, Control-Alt, da ist einfach alles. Und da möchte ich mit einer Hand alles machen. Und deswegen ist natürlich dieses Command kleiner größer eigentlich extrem naheliegend. Dann kam aber Apple mit iWork und hat dort Command kleiner größer auf Zoom rein rausgelegt. Also machst damit dein Document Zoom.
Was normalerweise Plus und Minus ist.
Was, naja gut, Plus und Minus ist, muss man auch sagen, unkonvenient. Ich meine, das kann man sich zwar irgendwie merken, aber das ist halt quer über die Tastatur verteilt.
Wieso, das ist hier rechts?
Das ist schon okay. Es geht doch alles. Eine Taste dazwischen.
Ja, wie auch immer. Man kann es aber nicht ummappen. Ich habe mich immer gewundert, was Sache ist. Und dann bin ich auf eine gute Idee gekommen und jetzt habe ich das bei mir auf allen Rechnern auf Command carré gelegt.
Was ist denn carré? Carré. Carré.
Carré. Carré.
Lass euch Zeit.
Nee, also da kann man sich dran gewöhnen. Das ist halt unter Escape. Kann man auch mit einer Hand machen, muss man noch nicht mal die Hand so zusammenklemmen. Ich finde es in gewisser Hinsicht sogar noch ein bisschen praktischer, weil der Abstand ganz gut ist. Damit kann ich jetzt super arbeiten. Nur, wenn ich gleichzeitig noch Shift drücke, dann ist es so ein bisschen... Man könnte es natürlich auch mal mit einer Funktion probieren.
Also mit Shift finde ich ja...
Dann nimm mal den kleinen Finger.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist Move to Next Window in Application ein super Shortcut. Sowieso lohnt es sich bei den Keyboard-Preferences durchaus mal durch die Keyboard-Shortcuts, die es überhaupt vom System her gibt, durchzuschauen.
Aber zum Wechseln zwischen Fenstern eines Programms finde ich ja das kleine ShareValue-Till-Witch ganz, ganz, ganz hervorragend. Da kann man dann für jeden Scheiß direkt Tastaturkürzel festlegen. Also erstmal hat es so ein Menü. Das sieht dann so aus wie bei Apfel-Tapp, wo man dann für tatsächlich jedes Fenster, was man offen hat, sieht man hier so einen kleinen, sieht man den Namenseintrag und so. Und jetzt mach ich hier mal irgendwas, viele Fenster auf, so. Und dann, wenn man hier so Apfel-Tapp drückt, dann kann da so eine Vorschau des Fensters noch dazu pappen, wenn man mag. Also wenn man so Photoshop und so was, auf so was steht. Und man kann halt ziemlich detailliert bestimmen, ich möchte mit der Tastenkombination nur innerhalb des aktuellen Programms und alle nicht minimierten Fenster und alle minimierten Fenster und nur das vorderste Programm und kann man, kann man sich, also ich hab da alles, was ich habe, zwischen dem Programm des vordersten Fenster hin und her springen, mehr brauch ich nicht. Aber dafür ist es super. Und es funktioniert auch da, wo, nehme ich hier so das App, Windows-Switchen über die Tastatur nicht geht. Das biegt sich überall rein.
Dir fällt man das ab.
Das ist super. Das will man.
Ich hab früher sehr viel mehr mit Funktionstasten gearbeitet. Diese ganze Default-Belegung hat mir so das so ein bisschen versauert. Aber wenn man sich dran gewöhnt, dass so die kleiner heller dunkler, kleiner lauter leiser und so weiter, also die ganzen Sachen mit FN ansteuert, was ich derzeit noch nicht so mache, dann hat man ja im Prinzip 12 Tasten frei auf so einem Laptop, mit dem man eben auch lustige Sachen machen kann. Aber es ist alles so absurd doppelbelegt auch da oben.
Ich programmier ja gerade so eine Auftragsarbeit, wo ich auch Funktionen auf die Funktionstasten legen soll. Dann hab ich das alles so programmiert und drück ich so durch, ob alles geht, komm so bis F7, alles funktioniert, drück F8, zack, expose. Scheiße. Und ich hab zu Hause halt hier so eine externe Tastatur. Da suchst du auch so die Funktion-Taste, die FN-Taste. Ich hab da keine FN-Taste. Das heißt, ich kann nur F-Tasten von 1 bis 7 benutzen. Die neueren Tastaturen haben irgendwie eine FN-Taste über der... Ach, du hast jetzt eine große, du hast nur die Kleinen am Start.
Genau, beim Num-Lok ist die.
Beim Num-Lok ist irgendwie was, aber ich hab halt so eine alte noch, weil ich find die ein bisschen cooler. Nicht diese flachen Alu-Dinger, sondern die eine davor. Oder zwei davor, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht. Und da ist keine FN-Taste.
Die Kümmelfalle?
Ja, der Aschenbecher, genau. Genau, diese Glasbande. Da ist keine FN-Taste. Wo steh ich da?
Ich mein, es gibt einen Keyboard-Control-Panel. Gibt's doch dieses...
Ja, ich kann ja den Kunden von dem Programm die sagen, Jungs, ihr müsst jetzt alle eure Tasten umstellen, weil mein Programm benutzt halt F1 bis F10.
Also ich meine, das ist ja auch auf jedem Laptop genauso. Also ich meine, wenn ich hier auf F1 drücke, dann ist es etwas flacher.
Ja, aber hier kann ich ja FN drücken, da kann ich ja dann weitermachen und...
Aber wenn du keine FN-Taste hast, dann ist halt...
Aber wer hat denn keine FN-Taste?
Na, Leute mit alten Tastaturen.
Wie alt?
Na, diese weißen, dicken, mit den dicken Tasten noch so. Mit so richtig Hub, wo man noch so richtig...
Wie vor den Alus?
Ja, der Aschenbecher.
Hast du gerade so ein Film gehabt?
Hast du getrunken, Tim?
Was?
Wir haben das gerade schon 2 Stunden debattiert.
Ja, ich hab vielleicht... einfach über andere Sachen nachgedacht. Ich arbeite einfach ein bisschen da dran, dass mehr Sex ins Internet kommt. Das ist auch manchmal ein bisschen unkonzentriert.
Ach, du hast ja jetzt auch ziales...
Ein bisschen siehst du so aus, als ob Sex aus dem Internet rauskommt.
Warum denn bei diesen Tastaturen... Das ist schon irgendwie echt merkwürdig. Eigentlich müsste dieses... Das ist irgendwie alles eben konsistent. Ich meine, Apple hat wahrscheinlich festgestellt, dass diese Funktionstasten eigentlich kein Schwein benutzt. In der Regel. So, weil das ist ja unüblich. Unter Windows, Alt-F4, lalala, da haben einfach viele Funktionstasten so eine bestimmte Bedeutung.
Ich glaube, so viel ist es auch nicht mehr. Ach doch, F5 Reload immer noch.
Ja, drücken Sie F5 und so, das steht sogar in Programmen.
Das geht auf dem Mac auch.
Was geht auf dem Mac auch mit F5?
F5 Neuladen. Ah nee, nicht in Firefox geht das, das geht auch auf dem Mac mit F5. Ja, nun krieg ich ein Jahr.
Sind sich auch wirklich nichts zu schade, oder?
Die machen Windows-Shortcuts einfach so auf dem Mac.
Ja, Cross-Plattform. Ich will diese anderen Plattformen nicht auf meiner Plattform. Will ich einfach nicht. Weg!
Jetzt will ich auch noch meine FN-Tastengeschichte erzählen. Ich finde es nämlich furchtbar, furchtbar, furchtbar, dass jetzt bei diesen neuen Tastaturen, dass die lauter-leiser Funktionstasten hier hinten sind, nämlich von F10 bis F12. Na, lauter und leiser ist F12. Ja, bei dir auch da hinten. Und ich hab die F-Tasten als F-Tasten und ich muss FN drücken, um an diese Funktion ranzukommen. Und das Einzige, was ich davon halbwegs häufig benutze, ist heller-dunkler, klar, und diese total weit hinten liegenden lauter-leiser Funktionen. Weil dieses ganze Dashboard und Musik an und aus und weiß-der-Teufel-was, das kann mir alles gestohlen bleiben. Und irgendwann haben sie das danach ganz hinten verlegt, was ich total ätzend finde, wenn man nämlich einen Film guckt und einfach nur mal rasch lazy rübergreifen will und den Ton lauter machen will, muss man beide Hände bemühen. Doch, ich hab eine, aber die hol ich da nicht extra.
Also es ist schon irgendwie auch nachvollziehbar, warum sie das da in diese Funktionsriege mit reingemacht haben, weil dann haben die Tasten wenigstens auch mal eine Funktion. Nur leider haben sie sich keinen eleganten Weg einfallen lassen, wie man sagen kann, dass wenn ein Programm Funktionstasten haben will, dass es dann auch wirklich accessible möglich ist. Also das, was Dennis erzählt hat, ist ja im Prinzip voll der Dealbreak. Dass es Tastaturen gibt von Apple, auf denen man das dann irgendwie nicht realisieren kann, zwischen diesen zwei Ebenen hin und her zu schalten. Und da müsste das eigentlich, ja, weiß ich gar nicht, anders sein. Das war schwierig. Ja, weiß ich nicht, so in Abhängigkeit von der Tastatur. Ich meine, die wissen ja auch, was für eine Tastatur da dran ist.
Ja, das wissen sie in der Tat. Eigentlich wissen sie auch, was für ein Bildschirm am Rechner dran ist. Sie bauen ja schließlich da die ganze Scheiße selber und trotzdem wissen sie nicht, wie groß... Also das ist ja auch so ein Ding, was...
Wie groß was?
Na ja, die wissen zwar, was für eine Auflösung du hast, aber die wissen nicht, wie groß die Pixel sind sozusagen. Das heißt, sie können nie dir Fenster oder Dinge gleich groß auf unterschiedlich dimensiviertes Bild schicken.
Doch, ich glaube schon, dass sie das wissen.
Ja, aber sie nutzen es nicht, das Wissen.
Bist du sicher, dass es keine AP gibt, dass man das auslesen kann? Ich glaube, dass das so ist.
Ne, sie versuchen es, aber es klappt nicht.
Also bei Quick-Fraud-Seiten, da gab es das noch. Da kamen in beide Richtungen immer 72 raus. Da konntest du nämlich sogar noch horizontal und vertikal abfragen, falls die Pixel unterschiedliche Höhen und Weiten haben sollten.
Aber auf jeden Fall ist das nach wie vor so ein Problem auch. Generell in der Computerlandschaft, dass das Betriebssystem keine Ahnung hat, wie groß die Pixel sind. Also wie groß das Display physikalisch ist.
Ich glaube, auf den Desktop wird das nicht mehr kommen. Ich glaube, auf Smartphones wird es standard werden.
Du hast halt so digitale DVI-Display-Ports, was auch immer. Die werden auch irgendwie da drüber vielleicht nochmal...
Ja, aber der einzige Fall, wo du es brauchst, ist doch, wenn du Print machen willst. Und Print ist ja eh tot.
Nee, es ist auch so hilfreich, wenn du zwei unterschiedlich große Monitore hast und du willst irgendwie ein Fenster auf das andere ziehen und nicht, dass das Fenster auf dem anderen Monitor plötzlich größer ist oder das User interface.
Aber ich möchte doch, dass das vernünftig ist. Ansonsten, ich möchte nicht, dass das verwaschen ist oder so halb skaliert wird, dann bloß weil ich es auf einen anderen Bildschirm schiebe.
Tja, schwierig.
Naja, das ist ja eben aber die Sache. Du hast dann vielleicht auf deinem 24 Zoll eine höhere Auflösung als auf deinem 15 Zoll. Aber trotzdem ist das Verhältnis von der Größe der Fenster und so, das steht in keinem Verhältnis.
Vorher sollen sie erstmal die Tastenkombination für Tabwechsel vereinheitlichen. Das finde ich ganz furchtbar bei diesem ganzen Apple Programm.
Jetzt sind wir in der T-Sektion.
Bildschirm und Shortcuts.
Tim, lass uns doch jetzt mal aus dieser Mecke-Ecke wieder raus. Moderier doch mal den nächsten Themenkomplex.
Ich dämpfe dafür, dass ihr immer solche Randtypen seid.
Bei wem wir uns das voll abgeguckt haben.
Na, da wir heute sowieso schon so schön Unique Suite sind. Voll auf der Kommandezeile, oder? Heute kann man mal was dazulassen. Weil ich nämlich auch, ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich mir das hier notiert hab. Ich glaube, ich bin mal danach gefragt worden und es ist mir aufgefallen, dass ich das noch nie erzählt habe. Nämlich die Frage, wobei das gilt für Mobamex, über, naja, eingeschränkt. Also es gibt BitTorrent. Wenn ich die selbst noch nie gehört veröffentliche, dann biete ich auch immer einen BitTorrent-Link an. Sehr löblicher. Was löblich ist, was ich aber auch erst ab dem Moment getan habe, wo ich eine Infrastruktur hatte, wo ich auch sicherstellen konnte, dass eine Datei, die ich eben einmal über BitTorrent anbiete, auch immer läuft unter BitTorrent. Also dass mir die SIDA nicht wegsterben. Weil es ist natürlich ein Leichtes zu sagen, ok, jetzt lad ich's mal hoch, dann lass ich 24 Stunden meinen Klein starten und dann ist es wahrscheinlich so, dass nach, was weiß ich, ein, zwei Tagen immer noch irgendwelche Leute mitlaufen lassen, sodass volle Kopien im Netz sind. Aber wenn dann halt der letzte Seeder gegangen ist, dann würden Leute halt versuchen, über BitTorrent runterzuladen und dann, naja, dann hast du halt keinen Seeder mehr. Also muss man sicherstellen, dass man einen hat. Und dann habe ich eine Weile nach Software gesucht, die das tut. Die einfach, der man sagt, hier hast du eine Datei Seedasy. Hab ich festgestellt, es gibt dann solche Software nicht. Es gibt einfach in der ganzen BitTorrent Landschaft nichts, mit dem du einen BitTorrent Server machen kannst. Es gibt natürlich allerlei Download-Programme, die auch so Kram haben, wie alle Torrents in diesem Directory automatisch öffnen und immer seeden und sowas. Klar, das gibt es alles. Aber trotzdem gehen die Programme immer davon aus, dass du eigentlich immer erstmal downloadest und danach noch so eine Seeding-Phase hast. Und nicht, dass du wirklich mit Seeding anfängst, sondern dass es auch das Einzige ist, was du tun willst. Das Tool muss ja zum Beispiel überhaupt nicht runterladen können, es muss nur anbieten können. Sowas gab es nicht und schon gar nicht gab es etwas, was meine existierende Dateistruktur akzeptiert. Also im besten Fall gibt es halt sowas mit, hier hast du so eine Watch-Directory und da kannst du alles reintun. Aber wenn du jetzt einen Fileserver hast, der irgendwie wohlsortiert 20.000 Dateien in 500 verschiedenen Sub-Directories vorrätig hat und das möchtest du einfach alles anbieten und nur genau diese Files und sonst keine, dann stehst du da.
Und dann runter, ey, lass eine Hose.
Ja, total. Aber richtig. Schniedeln an der Luft. Und dann, weißt du nicht, ja, mehr Sex.
Schniedeln an der Luft ist mehr Sex?
Weniger Sex.
Und dann fand ich das irgendwie, dann fand ich das alles ganz furchtbar und dann war ich auf dem Easter-Hack und hab mein Leid geklagt. Und Gott sei Dank saß vor mir Astro, der schaut nämlich ganz...
Oder ist eingefunden, dass er nicht mehr hören konnte.
Nö, ich hab Astro einfach das Problem geschildert und Astro war ganz super Hacker und sagte, hack ich dir. Hört man ja immer mal wieder so. Aber manchmal gibt es ja auch so Determined Hacker, die sind dann auch einfach mal Performant. Ja, er hat das innerhalb eines Tages gehackt und es lief. Also nicht so, dass er nicht später...
Geskriptet oder gehackt? Also hat er Fremd-Tools genommen, die er sich zusammengescriptet hat oder was hat er gemacht?
Alles frisch, from the start programmiert.
Weil er hat ja jetzt kein bitter und klein programmiert. Richtig, das ganze Protokoll irgendwie...
Den Teil, der mit Upload zu tun hat. Ohne Krypto. Also das Tool nimmt eine Liste von Dateien, die existieren und du sagst ihm, hier ist das Torrent-File und hier ist das Verzeichnis, in dem die Dateien dieses Torrent-Files sind. Also nicht ein Dateiname, weil es können ja mehrere sein. Und das ist einfach so eine XML-Datei, da stehen die halt alle drin. Und die liest er sich dann ein, so eine Seed-Liste. Und dann bietet er die alle an. Und der hat den ganzen BitTorrent-Stack, der dafür nötig war, hat er neu gehackt und das Ganze in Erlang.
Der Channel-Server.
Und das Teil rockt wie Sau. Vor allem, weil es Erlang ist, performt es einfach wie Blöde. Es sagt stabil und funktioniert einfach. Und falls jemand von euch dasselbe Problem hat, dass er mal irgendein Filespace definiert anbieten möchte, es hat ja auch den Vorteil mit einer Seed-Liste, da hast du ja auch sozusagen auch gleich Material für eine Whitelist. Das Einzige, was diesem Tool noch fehlt, das ist quasi der Disclaimer, es enthält noch keinen Trecker. Das ist etwas, was ich hoffe, was noch kommt. Ich habe da einfach Open Trecker benutzt und aus dieser Seed-Liste, ich habe da noch die ganzen Hash-Values von den Torrents mit reingeworfen und dann eben auch gleich noch eine Whitelist dazu gehackt, sodass eben, wenn der Datei rausfliegt, dass dann eben auch das Ding nicht mehr getreckt wird, so kannst du dann eben auch Dateien zurückziehen. Und so ist das dann verbunden. Dem fehlt sozusagen noch der Trecker, aber der bitteren Teil, der ist halt komplett und super performant und alles, was man dafür braucht, ist Erlang. Ja, das gibt es auch im Source, falls jemand Lust hat, sich das mal zu installieren. Das ist auf GitHub. Ist das so? Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht.
Also sein Account ist SlashAstro.
SlashAstro, ja warte mal, ich guck grad mal. Dauert das hier alles wieder lange. Das Internet ist langsam.
Nee, du bist zu langsam.
Ich bin zu langsam. github.com SlashAstro Slash Prittorrent. So hat er das dann nämlich genannt.
Echt? Das ist ja hier schon voll rausgescrollt, oder was? Ach nee, das da alphabetisch sortiert, oder wie?
Wo, was, wie?
Nee, Prittorrent.
Prittorrent. Ja, letztes Jahr. Krass. Und, also Easter Egg halt. So, und das ist irgendwie ordentlichen Software. Und weiß nicht, falls uns jemand zuhört, der auch so guter Erlang-Hacker ist und der Bock hat, da noch den Trecker-Teil mit einzubauen, was jetzt so schwierig auch nicht ist, weil dann musst du so ein bisschen HTTP machen und dann halt so ein bisschen Pakete durch die Gegend schicken und IP-Adressen vermitteln. Dann wär das sozusagen auch so ein Point-and-Shoot-Teil, wo du sagen kannst, hier ist die Liste der Dateien, startest das Ding und hast eben Trecker und Server in einem. Naja, und so funktioniert das eigentlich. Ich hab das dann so mit meinem, bei chaosradio.ch.de mit meinem ganzen Podcasting-Generator verbunden. Und dann erzeug ich halt diese Seedlist gleich automatisch. Muss halt natürlich so Hash-Wert und den ganzen Kram eintragen und auch das Torrenfall noch selber machen. Aber das war's dann eben auch schon. Und ab dann wird das Ding einfach automatisch geseedet.
Gibt's einen Applaus.
Ja, der Applaus geht an Astro, weil der ist nämlich einfach mal ein super Hacker. Hast du nicht irgendwie auch mit Erlang Software rum? Erlang gespielt?
Ich hab mir auf jeden Fall Erlang auch schon mal durchgelesen. Also zumindest Bücher dazu. Und ist auf jeden Fall schon ganz lustig. Und jetzt hab ich ja aus der Not heraus, dass unser geliebter Jabber-Server aus dem Club rumzickt, hab ich mir mal den derzeit einzigen sinnvoll zu betreibenden Jabber-Server mal selber installiert, um meinen eigenen Jabber-Server zu benutzen. Und das ist halt E-Jabber, die heißt die Software. Und das ist halt auch in Erlang geschrieben. Und das ist seit mehreren Jahren eigentlich die Jabber-Server-Implementierung TM. Oder XMPP könnte man auch sagen, aber...
So die Referenzimplementierung eigentlich ein bisschen, ne?
Ja, das ist halt die einzige, die wirklich vorne mit dabei ist, dauernd abgedatet wird und eben auch in Erlang geschrieben ist. Und dadurch auch... Also bei Jabber ist ja eben auch die Dezentralität ein großes Thema. Das heißt, jeder kann seinen eigenen Server haben und es können Leute auf den unterschiedlichsten Server sein und trotzdem miteinander sprechen, weil dann, wenn du eine Nachricht an jemanden an einen anderen auf einem anderen Server schickst, dann sprechen die Server untereinander und klüngeln das alles aus. Und das ist natürlich für Erlang quasi eine Paradeaufgabe, weil das eben genau für solche Sachen besonders gut funktioniert. Naja, weil das halt so designt ist. Erlang kommt ja aus der Telekommunikationswelt.
Erlang ist einfach ein Mensch, der hieß mal Erlang.
Aber bei Ericsson haben sie das auch genutzt, richtig?
Was?
Ericsson hat das ganze...
Mathematiker, das ist der Typ, der das Erlang erfunden hat. Also der Herr Erlang war derjenige, der den mathematischen Algorithmus erfunden hat, wie man eben die verfügbaren Kanäle, also die benötigten verfügbaren Kanäle, also die, die man tatsächlich an Kapazität real bereitstellen muss, in Abhängigkeit von den daran angeschlossenen Menschen. Also wenn du ein Wohngebiet mit N Leuten versorgen willst, dann kann er dir ausrechnen, wie viele K-Leitungen du tatsächlich an wirklicher Verbindung parallel zur Verfügung stellen musst, damit das irgendwie hinhaut. Und das haben halt alle, vor allem auch dann später die Mobilfunkbetreiber, das war dann sozusagen der Industriestandard in null Komma nix, wie man eben seine Kapazitäten richtig berechnet. Und da gibt es halt auch dann die Einheit Erlang. Ein Erlang heißt halt, du hast eine durchleitbare Leitung. Also zum Beispiel so ein ISDN-Anschluss, den du heutzutage hast, der hat halt zwei Erlang. Weil du eben zwei B-Kanäle hast, die du gleichzeitig benutzen kannst. Du kannst natürlich zehn Telefone anschließen und theoretisch bis zu zehn Leute mit der Telefonanlage bedienen. Du hast halt nur zwei Erlang, das heißt, es können halt nur zwei gleichzeitig tatsächlich auch wirklich telefonieren. Und da kommt das halt alles her. Und Erlang, selbst die Programmiersprache, ist bei Ericsson von so einem Team erfunden worden. Da gibt es auch dieses schicke Video, da haben wir auch schon mal darüber geredet, oder? Und das performt einfach enorm. Es hat einfach super, hat mich jetzt auch ein bisschen mehr reingelesen. Eine große Stärke von Erlang ist halt durch dieses eingebaute Pattern-Matching, das ist auch sehr binärfreundlich. Das heißt, es eignet sich hervorragend, um so bitorientierte, komprimierte, kleine Pakete zu parsen. Dafür ist es einfach perfekt. Und vor allem diese ganze Parallelität, also das Light-Wide-Processing vor allem. Also Prozess starten ist einfach extrem leichtgewichtig. Du kannst da Tausende von Threads starten und es dauert einfach alles nur wenige Millisekunden. Du hast also extrem wenig Overhead und kannst alles parallel laufen lassen und du hast eine sehr zuverlässige Methode, wie du eben abgestürzte Prozesse gleich wieder einfangen kannst, neu starten kannst, sodass dir eben auch dein System läuft. Du hast das auch automatisch verteilt im Netz und du kannst zur Laufzeit Code aktualisieren und so weiter, ohne die Software runterfahren zu müssen.
Und was halt auch noch cool ist, ist halt sehr interprozesskommunikationsfreundlich und nicht nur lokal halt in deiner VM, sondern eben auch übers Netz so, dass da halt mit anderen...
Und das wird bei dem E-Jobber, die auch schon benutzt?
Mit Sicherheit. Also das ist...
Es geht ja nur, wenn die anderen... Also wenn die A-Auf der anderen Seite auch ein E-Jobber, die spricht eigentlich schlecht.
Die sprechen nicht über dieses...
Das meine ich ja.
Nee, aber das mit den Lightweight-Prozesses und diesem Evented... Ist das nicht das Reaktor-Pattern am Ende sogar?
Das kann ich dir gar nicht beantworten.
Ja, weiß ich auch grad nicht. Gefährliches Halbwissen. Aber...
Piep, piep, piep.
Genau.
Soweit bin ich noch nicht vorgedrungen.
Nee, aber auf jeden Fall ist da Erlang nicht die schlechteste Wahl für einen Jabber-Server. Es gibt ja noch den JabberD, der ist in C geschrieben. Und das ist auch der, der bei uns gerade regelmäßig crasht. Er ist noch so ein alter JabberD. Also jabber.cccde ist ein E-JabberD. Und der hat ja auch echt doll viele User und läuft dafür erstaunlich gut. Und der JabberBerlinCCCDE, der ist halt ein JabberD und der wird demnächst auch gegen E-JabberD ausgetauscht.
E-JabberD ist zum Beispiel auch die Basis von Facebook Chat. Weil alle gehen eigentlich gerade auf Erlang, die High Performance und High Scalability haben wollen. Also alle, die wirklich so mit Millionen von Usern zu tun haben.
Also gibt's auf jeden Fall viele. Nicht alle, aber viele. Naja, und bei dem Jabber ist jetzt irgendwie, ist mir allerdings noch aufgefallen, interessanterweise. Also wenn du diesen E-JabberD hochfährst, dann gibt er dir, wenn du das Log-Level hochstellst, so auch so den ganzen Kram aus, mit welchem Server er jetzt kommuniziert. Und dann ist mir aufgefallen, da stand dann so die erste Nachricht, die hab ich mir natürlich an mich selber geschickt. Da steht dann irgendwie, ja, ich connecte mich jetzt mal zu JabberBerlinCityCTE und da steht dann hinter TLSFalls. Na klar, die Server können ja auch natürlich über TLS-Crypted miteinander sprechen.
Also Transport-Level-Security.
Genau, also SSL letztendlich. Okay, hab ich irgendwie das mal eingeschaltet auf meinem Java-Server, hab ich mir noch eine Nachricht geschrieben, nachdem ich sie natürlich auch restarted hab. Da stand dann immer noch TLSFalls. Dann hab ich mir eine Nachricht an meine JavaCCC-Adresse geschickt. Da stand dann TLSTrue. Und dann hab ich festgestellt, dass der JavaD auch irgendwie extrem uncool so mit, also zumindest dieser javaberlinccc.de, der hat dieses TLS-Feature halt nicht an. Das heißt, wenn man mit Leuten von javaberlinccc.de chattet und selber auf einem anderen Server ist, dann ist halt die Kommunikation dazwischen auch unverschlüsselt. Voll lame, auf jeden Fall.
Ich sag nur dezentralisieren, aber auf mich hat ja mal keiner.
Ja, aber das nützt dir dann auch nichts. Also eigentlich braucht man deswegen eben auch dieses OTR bzw. PGP, also End-to-End-Encryption, wenn man halt wirklich nicht mitgelesen werden will. Ja, und diese ganze Krypto.
Das ist leider nicht so richtig toll.
Ja, aber ich war ja erstmal sowieso geschockt, dass da dieses TLS einfach nicht angeht.
Na gut. Ja, ich finde, wir haben jetzt genug über das Thema geredet. Oder vielleicht nicht, oder haben wir da noch mehr zu sagen? Ich wollte das jetzt nicht hier abwirken, ich wollte nur sagen...
Das ist doch überhaupt nicht.
Ja. Max spielt schon mit seinem iPad rum.
Installiert euch alle mal einen Jabber-Server und macht TLS an und guckt alle mal drauf und benutzt OTR.
Das wäre cool, wenn jeder seinen eigenen hat. Oder? Wo ist das Problem?
Ja, das...
Aber Ende hast du Leute in der Liste, was die für eine Adresse haben, ist doch total schnuppel. Aber wenn tausende Leute auf einem sind und der eine irgendwie gerade nicht geht, dann kannst du auch gleich tausende Leute nicht erreichen.
Ja, das ist total nervig. Und eigentlich wurde der Jabber Berlin CCCD aber für Tim eingerichtet und Tim ist jetzt gar nicht mehr da drauf.
Ja, ich benutze Jabber CCCD. Der hatte einfach auch schon vor ein, zwei Jahren deutlich weniger Downtimes. Also, Jabber Server muss funktionieren. Und das ist auch einer der Gründe, warum ich so auf Erlang so aufmerksam geworden bin. Das ist einfach, in der Erlang-Welt wird Software geschrieben, die einfach zuverlässig funktioniert. Und das ist mal echt was wert.
CouchDB ist ja auch so ein Kandidat.
Genau.
Wobei man auch sagen muss, die MongoDB, die in C++ geschrieben ist, die ist auch jetzt nicht schäbig.
Nein, ich sage ja nicht, dass es nicht möglich ist, gute Software zu schreiben. Aber es ist halt so, in dieser Erlang-Welt gibt es gar nicht so viel, aber das ist alles irgendwie beeindruckende Software.
Naja, das funktioniert schon durchaus sehr gut. Ich finde nur die Syntax furchtbar.
Ja, das ist eine Geschmackssache. So, womit machen wir denn weiter?
Was haben wir denn noch so?
Also, wir könnten ein bisschen noch über den Mac reden.
Welchen?
Na, ich könnte noch so ein bisschen, was heißt, so ein bisschen ranten. Also, was ich, ähm, was mir immer wieder auffällt und was ich nicht so richtig verstehe, ist, und ich bin mir auch nicht so sicher, ob ich die Zeichen richtig lese, aber für mein Gefühl ist der Mac extrem schlecht immer noch, wenn es um IO geht. Also, was ich immer wieder feststelle, ist, was, was ich hier, ich hab, zieh Dateien über Gigabit so, über AFP, also so über den Files Sharing sozusagen, zieh ich so Dateien auf einen anderen Rechner.
Aber Gigabit ist auch nicht so viel, ne? Letztendlich.
Nee, ist nicht so viel, aber die Performance von meinem GUI geht dann irgendwie in den Keller. Also ich merk einfach immer wieder, dass die Gesamtperformance des Systems in dem Moment, wo einfach viel IO aufschlägt, ist mager.
Na, der Kerneltask ist mir auch sehr häufig mit sehr viel Prozent CPU-Last im Auge, wenn irgendwie eigentlich ganz andere Dinge passieren, aber ja.
Ich frag mich nur, was so der Grund dafür ist.
Hat man das nicht irgendwie schon mal?
Ich weiß es nicht. Das ist vielleicht auch kein richtiges Thema. Wir können aber was anderes reden.
Ich guck mal gerade ein Gigabit auf Wolfram Alpha, da kann man immer so schön einhalten, umrechnen, ohne groß nachdenken zu müssen. Ein Gigabit sind, also ich muss natürlich pro Sekunde hinschreiben. Durch acht, oder? Wolfram Alpha ist ja vorne. Da gibt es übrigens eine tolle neue App hier, drei neue tolle Apps von Wolfram Alpha. Jetzt mal kurz als kleine App erforschen zu... Ja, genau, was hier Eveline schon getwittert hat, Wolfram Algebra, Calculus und das andere ist für Musik, aber Algebra ist echt cool, das macht so...
Was für Apps meinst du jetzt?
iPhone, iOS Apps, ja.
Dann sag doch der Name schon.
Gibt es das auch auf dem Mac?
Ja, den benutzt doch keiner. Doch?
Wo soll man sich sonst sein? Ich halte doch klein drunter.
Man kann auch sonst.
Ich muss ja sagen, dieser Mac App Store, der wird bei mir wirklich nicht mehr geöffnet. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Ich gucke nun wieder nochmal rein. So, aber es ist so...
Der schafft das irgendwie so zu dem Google- Android-Market der Apple Stores zu werden. Oder? Das ändert sich auch nie so richtig viel.
Da gibt es auch keine coolen Apps drin.
Das ist so wie das Ping. Das Ping auf dem Mac.
Das ist so der iTunes-Flug.
Hat Apple auch immer mehr Projekte in den Ferien? So Google Style?
Na, Apple kann halt auch...
Na, haben sie auch immer mal wieder zwischendurch. Das vergisst man bloß so gerne. Ich mein, MoMAI nie jetzt als extrem Erfolg darzustellen.
Aber es ist auch nicht so wirklich ein Fail. Es ist nicht eingestellt wie Google Wave oder so.
Ich zahle.
Siehst du das?
Ja, es hat Value für mich.
Und dann auch der andere, der es auch nutzt.
Nee, also ich glaub schon, das ist einige nutzen auf jeden Fall, aber der Mac App Store ist halt so... Ich find da nix, ne? Also ich hab so das Gefühl, da kommen jetzt demnächst nochmal so ein richtiger Schwung-Apps. Also ich hab auch so ein paar Developer schon angeschrieben von iPhone-Apps und immer so im Nebensatz geschrieben, und wann kommt eigentlich eure Mac App? Und sie meinten, ja, ja, ist in der Mache. Aber, ja, bis jetzt. Und Wolfram-Alpha-Apps gibts da ja auch nicht. Okay, aber da könnte man sich ja auch einfach das günstige Mathematiker kaufen.
Aber jetzt sag doch nochmal was für diesen Wolfram-Apps.
Also, dieses Wolfram-Algebra ist halt ganz cool, weil du da so z.B. Formeln lösen kannst. Also, 2x plus 3y ist gleich 2342. Und dann kannst du x ist gleich 15 sagen und dann rechnet der y aus. Also, weißt du, so schön Mathefu, den man früher in der Schule total gehasst hat, macht dieses Wolfram-Algebra so im Handumdrehen für dich. Und dann gibt es eben noch so eine App für Musik, wo du dir dann halt alle möglichen Oktaven mit Tonbeispielen und Tonleitern und Chromatische und was auch immer dir anzeigen. Also, sagst du, ich will jetzt hier, hab einen C und will jetzt nach der chromatischen Tonleiter den nächsten oder den übernächsten und so. Und so kleine, nette Helfer ab. So, die kosten jetzt auch mittlerweile nur 1,59 oder so. Weil die sind ja immer gestartet. Sind die nicht mal mit 50 Euro gestartet sogar? Wolfram Alphardt?
Die waren mal geglaubt, da könnten sie richtig Kohle verabziehen. Da sind sie ja auch schnell mit auf die Schnauze gefahren.
Na ja, das hat schon ein Weilchen gedauert, fand ich.
Mittlerweile dürften sie mehr Geld damit verdienen.
Ach, da gibt's gar keine Bilder bei dir.
Was haben die noch so gemacht außer...
Also genau, das ist so eine Course Assistant-Reihe. Das ist so für Schule irgendwie keine Ahnung. Zum Laden halt. Genau, das Algebra ist halt so richtig irgendwie hier... Willst du mal Geometry oder willst du mal irgendwie Formeln ausrechnen oder... Also du kannst halt auch so was machen. Du hast eine komplexe Formel. Und kannst halt Simplify drücken und der schrumpft dir die zusammen. Das sind halt so Features, die früher nur in Mathematika... Also... Kostet das was? Also das Algebra oder das Calculus? Also ich hab das Algebra jetzt sozusagen direkt nur gesehen und benutzt. Und fand das halt, wie gesagt, echt appealing. Also du kannst eben genau in beide Richtungen, du kannst Simplify und Expand und umstellen lassen und lösen lassen und... Fand ich sehr cool. Also nicht, dass das jetzt mein tägliches, mein täglich Brot wäre, ja, aber hin und wieder hat man ja doch mal diesen Moment, wo man sich denkt...
Das fand ich früher beim Grafiken... Wie hieß der, dieser Calculator, der dabei war, beim Power PC, um die Macht des Power PCs zu demonstrieren?
War das nicht der Graphic Calculator?
Den gibt's ja immer noch.
Und da konntest du da auch, ja, ja, den gibt's immer noch, und da konntest du auch eine Formel nehmen und konntest die nach Belieben umstellen per Track and Drop. Das fand ich großartig, hab's nie gebraucht, aber...
Ja, die Sache ist halt auch bei Wolfram Alpha, da gehen nämlich halt so eine Features nicht und Mathematica ist halt ein bisschen zu teuer, um das mal ebenso auszuprobieren. Wobei man muss sagen, bei Mathematica gibt's eine Home Edition für nur 250 Euro oder sowas. Das kostet halt selten 6000 Euro oder irgendwie sowas in dem Dreh.
6000?
Das ist schon amtlich teuer. Das ist aber auch krasse Software. Ich hab ja mal auf Arbeit, die man damit umgehen sehen und dachte mir, boah, das ist fucking awesome, coole Software, also wirklich.
Und es gibt Leute, die sind schon beeindruckt, wenn sie einem dabei zuschauen, wie man einen Webbrowser benutzt.
Ja, also Mathematica fand ich hoch beeindruckend und wie gesagt, in Wolfram Alpha geht halt wirklich nur ein Bruchteil eigentlich und diese Ups schalten jetzt sozusagen noch ein bisschen mehr Features frei oder...
Also haben sie sich quasi dazu entschlossen, die 50 Euro nicht auf einen Schlag zu nehmen, sondern nach und nach aus der Tasche zu ziehen.
Also auf jeden Fall kleiner Tipp als Abfüll zwischendurch, während Tim noch überlegt, auf welches Thema er sich als nächstes einschießt. Haben wir denn in diesem Themenkomplex Apps und Empfehlungen vielleicht noch weitere? Du hattest noch mal bei Beateuse gearbeitet, was?
Wir sind ja nicht so verzehtene. Max, du wolltest Viber erwähnen, aber ich hatte den Gefühl, du hast Viber schon mal erwähnt.
Brauchen wir wirklich nur zu erwähnen, kann man mit telefonieren über WLAN und 3G und... Funktioniert, wenn man kein Festnetz hat.
Vielleicht leg ich auch falsch. Aber das war's dann auch. Kostenlosen telefonieren jetzt.
Was heißt das?
Aber nur von Viber zu Viber.
Nur von Viber zu Viber.
Das ist doch Viber-Kram. Na toll, super Witz, was? Ja, da kann man auch gleich eine Pille einwerfen, oder? Also wir sollten vielleicht mal über...
Was war das denn für eine Stimme, die ich gehört habe?
Was für eine Stimme?
Na wir hatten ja als Kommentar-Anregungen ja bekommen, wir sollten die großen Themen vorne machen. Hatten wir jetzt alle großen Themen vorne?
Die Frage ist, was ist ein großes Thema?
Na ja, hier dieses Daily-Dink hier.
Ist das ein großes Thema? Aber das ist gerade mal eine Stunde alt. Hast du schon genug damit rumgespielt, um was zu erzählen zu können?
Auf jeden Fall ist es langsam.
Das stimmt.
Das weiß ich schon mal. Und es lädt langsam.
Gut, The Daily, also es gibt jetzt irgendwie wieder so eine herunterladbares Buchprogramm, Zeitschrift, Tageszeitschrift, was auch immer das ist. Was ist das?
Mal wieder so eine... Ach, jetzt muss ich...
Du bist der Einzige, der das ausprobiert hat und du hast das Thema jetzt aufgerufen. Ich hätte jetzt was anderes genommen.
Das ist ein großes Thema. Das ist Rupert Murdoch, der jetzt im Wesentlichen dadurch bekannt ist, dass er... Der hat MySpace damals gekauft, war das nicht so?
Der hat alles gekauft, was nicht bei Drei auf den Bäumen war.
Dem gehört auch Fox News für mich. Der hat mit MySpace wirklich Kohle verdient. Ich glaube, der ist der einzige Mensch auf diesem Planeten, der mit MySpace Kohle gemacht hat, in dem er es sofort wiederverkauft hat. Der hat es gekauft für ein Schweinegeld, wo ich dachte, ha ha, da kann er schön sehen, wie das ein Berg runter... Wie er wieder das Geld verdient. Dann hat er es zwei Wochen später für einen doppelten Preis verkloppt. Und ja, das ist jetzt so dieses... Ich hab ehrlich gesagt auch keine Ahnung, warum das jetzt so extrem gehypt wird, weil es sieht definitiv nicht schicker aus, als diese ganzen anderen Versuche, Zeitschriften irgendwo hinzubringen. Also es ist jetzt einfach so ein bisschen was von diesem Wired-Look, den ich damals ganz nett fand, aber mir auch nie angeguckt habe, und so kopiert. Und es krollt halt unglaublich langsam. Ja, jetzt ist es da. Aber damit kann man endlich, dass es in iTunes jetzt Subscriptions machen. In-Apps-Subscriptions. Ein langsames Coverflow-Interface.
Mal weg von dem Coverflow, das können wir irgendwann ein bisschen schneller hinkriegen. Das Neue da dran ist jetzt, dass das App von selbst die neuesten News runterlädt und auch von selbst bezahlt. Ich hab grad auch die neuen Geschäftsbedingungen bei iTunes irgendwie akzeptieren müssen.
Also das Ding lädt jetzt gerade zumindest im Vordergrund einfach runter. So ist jetzt oben ein Ladebalken zu sehen und der lädt jetzt gerade Inhalte und das dauert einfach ewig.
Und du bezahlst ja aber noch nichts jetzt, oder?
Nee, ich bezahl jetzt nichts, weil... Die App hat auch nichts gekostet. Die ersten zwei Wochen sind gesponsert von Verizon. Ausgerechnet von Verizon.
Aber wie läuft deren Bezahlmodell? Das ist ja wohl der große Unterschied bei dieser App jetzt, oder?
Du machst das per In-App-Purchase. Du kannst ein Abo abschließen. Direkt im App Store. Also du sagst hier, ja ich möcht dich haben und dann...
Aber was heißt Abo? Die wollen dann einmal per In-App-Purchase ziehen sie von dir 50 Dollar ein und dann hast du einen Monat frei und dann legst du den Monat die neuesten News runter. Meinen die das so?
Also die Woche kostet es einen Dollar. Das ist deutlich günstiger. Das ist wahrscheinlich das einzige Differenzierungsmerkmal für den ganzen anderen, dass es einfach günstig ist. Ich hab es auch noch nicht gesehen und ausprobieren können, wie es denn wirklich funktioniert.
Ich dachte mal, dass dieses Autosubscription wäre, dass du wirklich, du musst einmal im Jahr, du willst das und das Tool bucht von alleine jede Woche diesen einen Dollar ab. Das ist nicht der Fall, sondern du musst es schon selber machen und danach lädt es.
Nee, ich glaube, das ist das Neue. Darum haben sie ja diese neuen Bestimmungen da, diese neuen AGBs, dass das dann wirklich automatisch passiert. Also dass du entweder, wenn es sobald ist...
Aber da müsste sich doch was an Programmen geändert haben da im iOS 4.2. Oder meinst du, das war schon drin?
Also ich nehme an, da wird einfach ein Hook sein, dass du einfach sagst, ja, das ist eine Subscription und kein normales mehr. Und dass dann die iTunes-Dollars hinten abbrechen. Deshalb brauchst du ja nichts im Programm drin zu hören. Das Programm muss ja nicht jede Woche nachgucken.
Die können ja nicht heimlich immer einen Dollar abziehen. Irgendwann hast du ja keinen Überblick mehr, wo jetzt ein Dollar abgezogen wird.
Ich hoffe mal, dass... Hier, Weekly Subscription, New Subscription, bla bla bla, dann kannst du Auto-Renewal on machen. Und wenn du das ausmachst, dann cancelt er die Subscription halt at the end of the current subscription period. Und ansonsten, wenn du es anhast, dann zieht er dir halt...
Das ist aber jetzt in diesem einen App drin. Aber irgendwann mal, sag mal, du hast irgendwann mal fünf von diesen Apps. Wo kannst du dann mal überblicken, also die Zusammenfassung dieser Subscription...
Ich hoffe mal, dass da irgendwo so eine Übersicht geben wird bei iTunes.
Jetzt auch noch der digitale Zeitungskiosk.
Ich bin gespannt. Okay, man muss die Subscription auch konfirmen, dass es nicht irgendwie...
Bei Springer wird jetzt die ganze Chef-Etage gerade orgasmen bekommen, dass sie jetzt endlich Rambo-Modelle haben können und damit jetzt das iPad wirklich endlich die Verlage rettet.
Ich bin halt nicht sicher, weil die haben glaube ich alle keinen Bock drauf, 30% in Apple abzugeben, oder?
Stimmt, das ist so ein Vertriebskosten, das hat schon alles seinen Preis.
Ja, schon, ja, auch, aber...
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie hoch das normaler ist.
Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass da einige so ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen haben, dass die jetzt alles so mit 30% durch Apple durchruten müssen.
Wobei ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass Hogwarts Murder auch nur ansatzweise 30% dafür zahlt. Also der wäre nicht einer der preissten Menschen auf diesem Planeten, wenn er sich auf schlechte 30% Deals einlässt. Ich glaube, dass er mit seinen zerkünderten Gesichter irgendwie so was um die 3% oder ich hab keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, was die...
Ich glaube mit 10% kann man auch noch reich werden.
Ja, man kann damit reich werden, aber der macht nicht den Standardtarif, den jeder hinterhergeworfen kriegt.
Das ist nichts, wo wir uns den Kopf zerbrechen müssen.
Wo wir erzählen, dass Apple vor ihm in die Knie gegangen ist und das dann auch noch auf seiner Homepage featuret, das glaubst du auch nicht, ein Traum. Da hat Steve gesagt, Knie nieder.
Und ich glaub, was der nicht gemacht hat, ist niederknien.
Ich bin dein Weihnachtsmann. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ich scroll hier so ein bisschen durch und irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ich bin hier genauso verloren wie bei diesen ganzen anderen... Das sieht immer noch... Weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaube, es funktioniert genauso schlecht, wenn man weiterhin nichts verlinken kann.
Das ist aber jetzt auch wieder so amerikanisch. Das spricht uns eh nicht an. Und jetzt so App Store. Im Hintergrundladen davon habe ich nichts gelesen jetzt.
Macht er doch gerade da oder nicht?
Im Hintergrund? Ohne dass das Programm läuft?
Der lädt, sobald du das startest.
Hast du ja wieder genau solche, die läst. Ich mach das so ein bisschen undemand, aber das Ding, das reagiert ja überhaupt nicht. Das ist ja irgendwie...
Fail.
Das ist echt... failig.
Das ist halt Fail-Geschmäckle.
Also gut, vielleicht kommt das ja noch. Man weiß es nicht. Ich fände sowas mal ganz interessant. Ich hab eigentlich eher auf was anderes gehofft. Ich finde dieses ganze mit Ups, finde ich irgendwie Quatsch.
Jetzt kommt was mit Podcasts, pass auf.
Nee, ich würde mir sowas... Na eigentlich, worauf ich eigentlich warte, ist eher sowas wie EPUB für Magazins. Dass man also diesen EPUB-Standard so weit aufbohrt, dass eben solche User-Interfaces auch machbar sind, aber dass man einfach einen generischen Leser hat. Du willst doch nicht mit diesen ganzen iPad-Ups und den Zeitungen und Magazinen ist doch ungefähr so, als stellen wir mal vor, du hast fünf Magazine abonniert. Das erste musst du dann von links nach rechts durchblättern, das andere musst du von unten nach oben durchblättern, bei dem anderen kommen erst die ganzen graden Seiten und dann die ganzen ungraden Seiten. Also irgendwie alle kommen mit ihrem eigenen User-Interface und du kannst dein Wissen nicht übertragen.
Ja, aber die haben uns doch versprochen, dass man in einer digitalen Welt jetzt auch reinklicken kann und dann gibt es Zooms und jede Firma will ja natürlich auch andere sich individualisieren und so.
Ja, that's from the guys who brought you CD-ROM Multimedia. Weißt du noch, diese Phase, wo alle mit ihren blöden CD-ROM Zeitschriften da rauskamen, das war doch auch der totale Fehler. Das ist jetzt irgendwie wieder genau das gleiche Lied. Und meiner Meinung nach kannst du nur mit so was wie so einem EPUB-Magazin punkten, wo du dann einfach deinen Magazine-Reader hast und der dann auch von allen Multimedia-Skripting sonst wie Geschichten Gebrauch macht, was am Ende auch nur JavaScript ist. Ja, im Prinzip ist es das. Bloß dann eben mit einem definierten Dateiformat, was eben auch für diesen Dokumententyp-Magazin eben auch optimiert ist.
Ich glaube, das wird HTML kurz werden.
Was du halt runterladen kannst, was du einfach downloaden kannst. Web ist nicht wirklich dafür gedacht, dass du da 100 Seiten runterlädst. Da gibt es halt nur PDF und es gibt EPUB. Und EPUB ist im Prinzip ja schon das Richtige, aber es ist noch relativ simpel. Und wenn du eben so was Komplexes machen willst wie das, dann bräuchst du es eben so ein bisschen weitergedacht. Und das ist eigentlich das, worauf ich setzen würde. Ich möchte hier so einen Newsstand haben, der alle möglichen Magazin-EPUBs kaufen kann.
Ich glaube, da ist ein Problem, dass eine Lösung, die noch ein Problem sucht. Warum den ganzen Scheiß nicht im Web lassen? Warum nicht jetzt hier, wenn ich zu Spiegel online gehe?
Weil du es nicht runterladen kannst.
Wozu soll ich das tun?
Dass du es auch klein lesen kannst, dass es alles schon da ist. Weil du willst nicht auf jede Seite 10, 20 Sekunden warten, bis dann dieses dicke Pfeil über Bild runtergeladen ist.
Dann solltest du es halt so machen, dass man nicht mehr blättern muss. Weil sie ihre Zahlen hochtreiben wollen, ihre Page-Views hochtreiben wollen.
Das ändert nichts an der Tatsache, dass du das erst in dem Moment laden kannst, wo du so eine Seite anwählst. Und wenn du dann halt kein Netz hast, dann geht es halt nicht.
Wie im Zug gerne öfters mal.
Ja, du willst das im Flugzeug lesen, du willst es auch mal lesen ohne Internet. Du willst es einfach drauf haben, wie eine Zeitung.
Es muss einfach an den Orten, wo ich es lesen will, nach Internet lesen.
Ich will es manchmal einfach drauf haben.
Nee, es muss einfach da überall Internet geben, wo man jetzt keins hat.
Du meinst, man muss es nicht drauf haben.
Man muss es nicht drauf haben.
Man kann es auch runterholen.
Wir stellen fest, wir können da nicht so sehr viel zu sagen. Obwohl du gerade Webseite erwähnt, habt ihr gemerkt, dass die apple.com Webseite eine neue Search Bar hat. Das ist ja nicht die eigentliche Botschaft.
Das haben sie echt ganz hübsch gemacht.
Jetzt geht bei der Apple Webseite auch mein Lüfter hoch.
Das ist ja alles HTML5.
Und das ist ja total schnell HTML5. Das ist ja nicht so.
Genau, das ist nämlich jetzt alles HTML5. Das ist irgendwie Eat Your Own Dog, so dachte ich zumindest.
Wie das so schön schnickt bei der Mac-Tab und man auf die Produkte da so hin und her und dann schnickt das so.
Sie haben da schon so ein bisschen iKendi eingebaut, aber ich meine, was ich am bemerkenswertesten finde, ist, dass sie einfach jetzt voll auf HTML5 gehen. Und dann dachte ich mir so, oh, alles klar, HTML5. Was haben sie wohl mit den Videos gemacht?
Und?
Also euch dürfte ja aufgefallen sein, dass bis vor kurzem diese Videos immer noch alle moffs waren.
Ich hab da jetzt nichts extrem drauf gehaftet.
Die Apple-Webseite hat schon lange keinen Flash mehr verwendet. Gab mal eine Zeit, da hatten sie Flash?
Die hatten mal Flash.
Videos. Naja, gab ja nichts anderes.
Und das haben sie dann irgendwann sein gelassen. Irgendwann haben sie, ich weiß nicht, das ist so zwei, drei Jahre her? Kann das sein?
Nee, die haben doch nicht Flash genommen für Videos, oder?
Naja, die hatten schon für andere Leute. Wir konnten auch ohne Quicktime da Filme gucken.
Es gab da mal Flash, es gab ja auch mal eine Zeit, da war Flash Teil von Quicktime. Also Flash wurde ausgeliefert auf diesen Max und es war auch das alte Flash 4 oder so, das war in Quicktime drin.
Also zu...
Auch immer. Es gab das irgendwann mal, korrigiert mich, vielleicht liege ich auch total falsch, Tatsache ist, sie haben eine medienreiche Webseite schon immer gehabt und sie haben eigentlich vorausgesetzt, dass du Quicktime hast. Und du konntest also auch diese Apple Webseite eigentlich nicht überall wirklich anzeigen, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe. Und naja, jetzt sind sie halt auf HTML5 gegangen und da fragte ich mich so, was haben sie denn jetzt wohl als Video? Und zweifelsohne war das auch schon vorher alles H264, aber halt in so Moff-Containern. Und ich hab jetzt nicht richtig viel Zeit gehabt, rumzustochen, aber ich bin jetzt auch auf Moff gestoßen. Und ich frage mich so ein bisschen, was das jetzt eigentlich für eine Strategie ist an der Stelle. Ich meine, Moff ist nur der Container und Moff ist ja eigentlich die Basis von MP4. Jetzt weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, was sie da wirklich für Moffs haben und ob das sozusagen nur Moff heißt, aber eigentlich MP4 ist. Ja, also ich kann es mich...
Die Linux-User jetzt in das Chat bitte mal auf Apple kommen und das Jonathan-Eve-Gedächtnis-Video auf der Startseite gucken und sagen, ob es geht.
Mit Firefox oder was?
Mit Firefox, genau.
Das geht bestimmt gar nicht.
Doch, ich glaube schon. Die haben noch... Mit was denn? Die Linux-User haben noch auch so Browserplugins. Gibt es doch auch hier FFmpeg für Firefox oder so, oder MPlayer oder so. Also hier auf dieser apple.com-slash-mac können da Linux-User, die uns jetzt gerade hören, wir haben ja auch Linux-Hörer wahrscheinlich, können die da das Jonathan-Eve-Gedächtnis-Video im Firefox gucken.
Vielleicht fragt einer, was ist Firefox?
So, na gut, also abgesehen davon, ja ansonsten ist es ganz schön geworden und sie haben aber immer noch nicht Sprout Core oder so benutzt. Also ich hab ja mal durch die Sourcen dann geguckt und sah da bisher eigentlich nur so jQuery und Custom JS. Also ich hab mal so ein bisschen gesucht und da steht nix von Sprout Core oder so.
Die benutzen ganz viele.
Das ist so ein GUI-Framework, JavaScript-Foo.
Mit dem du so Mac OS-style programmieren kannst.
Aber das war doch...
Nach uns Scriptaculous benutzen sie auch noch.
MobileMe benutzt glaube ich Sprout Core.
Sprout Core ist für relativ komplexe Apps, die aber auch dann entsprechende Ladezeiten haben.
Du kannst dir einfach mal auf Sprout Core klicken und googeln und dir da einfach mal die Demos anschauen.
Ich glaube dieser Kalender und Mail und so, das ist alles Sprout Core.
Ja, also da haben sie sich tatsächlich nochmal mit Prototype und Scriptaculous und ein bisschen jQuery glaube ich auch scheinbar selber nochmal was gerollt.
Die probieren ganz viel aus. Die haben ganz viele verschiedene JavaScript-Libraries selber gehackt bzw. verwendet von anderen. Und ich glaube, die sind da auch so einen freien Wettbewerb, was da letzten Endes...
Die Navigationsleiste, die dann auch noch so runterfährt, das hab ich noch gar nicht geschneit.
Na, sie machen jetzt so ein bisschen Living Web. Ich find das schon mal gut, dass sie da auch so ein bisschen...
Also diese Find-My-iPhone-Seite mit dem Sparkling, das ist auch immer wieder schön.
Sparkling?
Ja, wenn du auf mobile, also auf me.com heißt das doch, ne? Wenn du da raufgehst und diesen fetten Screen hast, dann sparkle doch, da hast du dieses Logo vor sich hin. Echt? Alles auch HTML5. Ja, hinter der Wolke kommt da gleich so Sparkle vor. Das ist halt auch irgendwie angeblich CSS3, FO oder JavaScript oder was auch immer. Also zumindest ist da kein Flash drauf. Einfach auf me.com, ne, me.com die Login-Seite.
Die Login-Seite?
So, jetzt hört er wahrscheinlich gleich an seinem 11 Zoll MacBook eher den Lüfter.
Echt meinst du, der Sparkle macht so viel CPU-Load? 94% CPU verrisst das Webkit beim Sparkle. Krass.
Ach, warte mal, da passiert dann auch mehr. Da ist ja...
Warte mal, ich muss mich ja ausloggen, oder was?
Der hat dann noch so einen Effekt im Hintergrund.
Ja, das ist der Sparkle. Also warte, Moment.
Achso, nee, ich meinte...
So sieht das dann aus. Und da sparkelt es hinter der Röcke. Sehr verspielt. Und wenn du da halt so über die Button hoverst und so, das ist ja alles so. Das macht so alles wuh und schnu und glow und swoosh und...
Wo muss man denn da hingehen?
Auf die Log-In-Seite.
Na die Log-In-Seite, da krieg ich immer diese ganzen Icons.
Bei dir sieht das anders aus.
Vielleicht weil dein Display kleiner ist.
Übrigens berichtet der Chat, dass es auf Firefox auf Ubuntu abspielt. Das Jonathan-Eve-Gedächtnis-Video.
Firefox auf Ubuntu?
Wahrscheinlich bist du einfach nicht hundertprozentig ausgedacht.
Video?
Ja, die können auch Videos unter diesem Ubuntu. Die können echt alles.
Ja, aber ich meine, was... Was? Was kommt denn... Ich meine, was... Was da für Plug-Ins installiert sind, aber... Was... Was kommt denn da von Apple? Was schiebt denn Apple einem Firefox unter Ubuntu so unter?
Und da Ubuntu, die haben auch so diverse Media-Codecs drinnen. Vielleicht haben die da... Es gibt ja so ein VLC Firefox Plug-In. Und dass die das einfach...
Wo wir gerade bei diesem Video-Thema sind, Tim, was hast du denn für neue Erkenntnisse? Du warst ja letztes Mal nicht so ganz glücklich mit deiner H264-Performance im Nachhinein. War ja auch...
Ich fand unsere Diskussion war ein bisschen abwesend. Also...
Ja, Dennis und ich waren währenddessen auch abwesend.
Was? Was?
Was ist das Thema gerade? Ja, aber da gibt es ja News, um gleich tief einzusteigen. Microsoft hat heute gesagt, sie bringen einen Plugin für den Chrome-Browse raus, wahrscheinlich unter Windows, der auch H264 kann.
Ja, sie schleift wahrscheinlich ihren nativen H264-Support jetzt in einen Chrome-Plugin durch, damit der Chrome wieder H264 kann. Ja, aber nur...
Ja, dann muss jetzt eigentlich nur noch Nokia sagen, dass sie H264 unterstützen und schon ist diese Technik einem für alle mal sicher vom Aussterben.
Ich frag mich halt immer noch, was Google eigentlich will. Also ich meine, was, was, was, was wollen die eigentlich? Könnt ihr mir das beantworten? Was ist die Intention? Worum geht's?
Ich weiß es nicht so ganz genau. Also ich würde mir wünschen, dass sie sagen, ok, WebM, wir stehen jetzt dahinter, wir pushen das so hart wie wir können und wir geben richtig Gas und jede Woche gibt es irgendwie eine WebM-News und ein Plugin für Safari und ein Plugin für dies und ein Plugin für das und Support für dies und Support für das, aber irgendwie hat man auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl wieder, dass es so wie bei vielen Projekten ist, so wie eingeschlafene Füße, ne, also also richtig pushen, so mit aller Kraft, das hab ich jetzt auch nicht so das Gefühl, deswegen bin ich auch so ein bisschen, weiß ich nicht, was die genau wollen damit, also wenn sie wirklich wollen würden, dann könnten sie glaube ich viel doller das nach vorne schieben als...
Aber wenn sie was wollen, also was wollen sie?
Das Web M der Video Codec wird.
Also warum wollen sie das?
Weil sie sagen, dass freier Codec gut ist.
Ja, weil?
Weil sie keine Lizenzgebühren abdrücken wollen.
Weil sich keiner darüber Gedanken machen muss, ob es jetzt, ist das jetzt kommerziell, sind das jetzt viele Videos, bin ich ein Publisher, was muss ich jetzt machen, muss ich überhaupt was machen, muss ich nichts machen, kann ich einfach publishen, werde ich verklagt?
Und weil Google ganz deutlich kommerziell ist und die einfach auch wahrscheinlich online Videoshop aufmachen wollen und damit Kohle machen wollen und dann wollen sie keine Lizenzgebühren abdrücken.
Ja, aber das Geld, was sie da jetzt in WebM in den nächsten 10, 20 Jahren da reinstecken müssen, um das voranzutreiben, das kostet sie mehr als jegliche Lizenzgebühr für ihren Browser über die ganzen Jahre.
Vielleicht machen sie auch ein WebM Konsorzium.
Also wirtschaftlich ist das sozusagen nicht, wie sie da rechnen. Das kostet sie auf jeden Fall mehr da diesen Kram voranzubringen als einfach die paar Millionen da zu zahlen. Wobei ich mich sowieso frage, warum müssen sie da überhaupt zahlen? Jetzt haben wir ja letztes Mal glaube ich schon festgestellt, dass sie ihren eigenen X264-Decoder mit ausliefern. In Chrome. Ich mich halt auch frage, warum tun sie das? Und warum überlassen sie das nicht einfach dem Betriebssystem, was das ja schon kann, sowohl unter Windows, also zumindest Windows 7, also XP halt nicht. Gut, geschenkt, da ist das dann nicht so. Da könnte man ja dann ein Plugin installieren, wo man sozusagen nur für dieses Plugin was bezahlen muss, wenn man da dieses X264 einsetzt. Und auf allen anderen Betriebssystemen müssten sie das ja nicht tun, oder verstehe ich da irgendwas nicht?
Wahrscheinlich, aber das ist ja auch ein komplexes Thema.
Ja, aber Bild zahlt ja da an der Stelle bereits. Und Microsoft auch.
Und Steve auch.
Und Linux nicht.
Gut, kann man jetzt sagen, wegen Linux.
Aber bei Linux kannst du dir halt auch das X264 Codec Pack, keine Ahnung, was installieren und FFmpeg und Mplayer und VLC und die... Also wie gesagt, unter und unter Bundtour hast ja sowieso schon einen Firefox VLC Plugin.
Ich gab auch unter Firefox andere Erfahrungen, meinte der Chat dann auch. Aber wie gesagt, Google, die wollen auch im großen Stil Videos encoden und die wollen Videocontent zur Verfügung stellen. Machen sie doch.
So ich meine, was ist denn jetzt die Zahlung?
Dafür wollen sie keine Lizenzgebühren zahlen.
Das ist aber nicht das, was sie sagen. Sie erwähnen Geld nicht. Das ist in ihrer Kommunikation taucht das Argument Geld nicht auf. Naja, ich verstehe mich, ich versuche das jetzt gar nicht in irgendeine Richtung zu treiben. Ich versuche nur zu verstehen, was sie eigentlich wollen. Also was ist ihr Ziel? Worum geht es ihnen? Geht es ihnen darum, alle Lizenz- patentbehafteten Technologien grundsätzlich zu verbannen? Warum unterstützen sie dann AAC? Warum unterstützen sie dann MPEG 3? Also MP3. Warum haben sie JPEG in ihrem Browser?
JPEG ist aber jetzt nicht lizenzbehaftet.
Ist auch patentbehaftet und...
Properitär.
Ja, das ist alles genau die gleiche.
Also für GIF ist es ausgelaufen.
Ja, für JPEG gibt es doch keine Lizenzgebühren.
Das ist auch...
Das ist halt alles in diesem MPEG LA.
One standard at a time.
Da musst du jetzt nicht mehr noch für bezahlen. Aber das ist... Auch JPEG ist patentbehaftet. Das ist das, was ich sage. JPEG ist ein Standard wie MPEG. Das ist...
Bei H264 ist das... Zum einen muss man dafür noch bezahlen unter bestimmten Umständen. Das ist das Erste und zum Zweiten... Wahrscheinlich ist der Standard noch furcht genug, dass du da noch glaubt, noch dazwischen grätschen zu können.
Ja, was ist mit MPEG 4 AAC? Das schmeißen sie nicht raus. Was ist mit MP3?
Kommt auch noch.
Das schmeißen sie auch nicht raus. Was ist die Logik? Was ist die Logik? Warum jetzt nur das Video? Weil das sozusagen diese Trennung hat mit Non-Commercial-News? Vermutlich, oder? Aber sagen sie das?
Na wieso? Man kann auch komplett frei... Man kann auch ohne Lizenzgebühren abzudrücken MP3-Encoder und Decoder bauen. Das Einzige, was doch bei MPEG 3, ich weiß nicht, ob es immer noch der Fall ist, mal lizenzpflichtig waren, waren sozusagen die guten Einstellungen. Der Encoder selber, gibt es doch Open-Source-Encoder, für die man keine Lizenzgebühren abdrücken muss. Bei JPEG genauso. Ich kenne niemanden, der im größeren Stil für MP3-Encoder muss zu Geld zahlen. Es gibt doch MP3-Encoder.
Also LAME verwendet meines Wissens nur diese Referenzimplementierung von Fraunhofer, die vielleicht...
Du Vaders Dennis.
Schon wieder.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass es sich bei MP3 jetzt um ein freies Format handeln würde. Das ist nicht so. Das ist genauso Software, Patente und Lizenz behaftet wie viele andere, fast alle anderen Formate halt auch. Apple zahlt selbstverständlich für den MP3-Encoder in iTunes Geld. Deswegen haben sie wahrscheinlich auch nur in iTunes und nicht im Betriebssystem. Also wahrscheinlich haben sie ihn auch deshalb nicht im Betriebssystem, weil sie eigentlich weg wollen von MP3, aber sie natürlich es sich heutzutage noch nicht leisten können, ein Programm auszuliefern, was ein Medien-Encoder ist, der nicht auch MP3 erzeugen kann. In meiner iTunes wäre extrem unbrauchbar, wenn man damit nicht auch MP3 erzeugen kann. Und deswegen ist das da auch mit drin, aber dafür zahlen sie auch Geld.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie sicher, dass Sie da für Geld zahlen? Klar, ziemlich sicher. Und was auf jeden Fall der Fall ist, bei MPEG 4 muss man ab einer gewissen Größe nicht nur für die Software Geld bezahlen, sondern für das Encoding selber Geld bezahlen. Und für das Ausliefern. Du zahlst dann wirklich als Content-Produzent.
Und Content-Provider.
Ja, und das musst du bei MPEG 3 auf jeden Fall nicht. Ich hab jedenfalls noch nie dafür bezahlt, dass ich hier irgendwie ein MPEG 3 erzeuge.
Also wenn du Geld dafür nimmst, dann musst du dafür bezahlen.
Wie? Meinst du das?
Für kostenlosen Content musst du nicht bezahlen.
Ja, aber nee, wenn du Content-Provider bist, also sowas wie YouTube, musst du auch H264-Fuhrwahl-Lizenzen bezahlen, wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab. Wenn du jetzt auf deine eigene Webseite irgendwas hostest, non-commercially und so weiter und so fort, private dann wohl nicht, aber als kommerzielles Unternehmen, was so richtig Video-distributiert in großem Stile, schon, nein, so hab ich das zumindest verstanden.
Wer zahlt denn dann für H264? Offensichtlich ja niemand.
Doch, also jedes Gerät, was halt so eine Hardware-Implementierung hat, was halt so ein Decoder eingebaut hat und was ein Encoder eingebaut hat. Also es geht um das Encoding und das Decoding im Wesentlichen. Und außerdem gibt es noch die absolut, wie ich auch, also die ich auch als inakzeptabel empfinde. Also auch ich will nicht, dass es eine Klausel gibt, dass man dafür noch bezahlen muss, wenn du es verkaufst. Aber ich meine, wenn du Geld damit einnimmst, ist es ja nicht so, dass das dann nicht auch eine kalkulierbare Größe wäre.
Ja, aber Google möchte dieses Geld nicht abdrücken.
Das sagen sie aber so nicht. Das glaube ich ihnen auch nicht, dass das ihr Ding ist, weil wenn sie das wirtschaftlich kalkulieren...
Was glaubst du denn, was ihr Ding ist?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Also ich hab wirklich keine Erklärung, deswegen macht mich das ja auch alle so wumig, dass einfach ihre Objectives da so unklar sind. Und ich glaube ihnen einfach, die Welt soll frei sein Nummer, glaube ich ihnen.
Ja, aber was spricht denn gegen die Nummer, dass sie sich durchgerechnet haben, sagen, hallo, wir wollen nächstes Jahr den YouTube-Store aufmachen und da wollen wir Filme verkloppen. Und davon wollen wir so und so viele Milliarden Umsatz machen und dann müssten wir 300 Millionen an die MPEG LA abdrücken jedes Jahr und das wollen wir nicht. Und darum machen wir unseren eigenen Staat.
Also erstens, 300 Millionen, wenn sie 300 Millionen an die MPEG LA abdrücken müssen, dann haben sie 30 Milliarden Dollar verdient und dann ist das bestimmt noch das geringste Problem, was wir haben.
Wieso soll das...
Wir reden hier von Centbeträgen.
Ja, aber was machst du an Gewinn an so einem Video? Vielleicht wollen sie...
Das ist doch dein Business-Modell, aber das rechnest du da einfach mit rein.
Vielleicht wollen sie ja Videos günstiger machen. Vielleicht wollen sie sie einfach...
Ruhig, brauner, ruhig, es läuft.
Zwei Cent. Ja. Die zahlen alle. Das ist überhaupt gar kein competitive advantage. Das ist dann einfach so. Das ist so, wie du für deine CD-Hülle bezahlen musst, wenn du CDs verkaufst.
Aber in dem Moment, in dem sie einfach im offenen Standard nehmen, haben sie diesen wirtschaftlichen Vorteil, dann brauchen sie nämlich diese zwei Cent oder was auch immer das ist, nicht zu zahlen.
Was hat das jetzt mit offenen Standards zu tun?
Nichts! Du erzählst die ganze Zeit von offenen Standards. Ich sage nur, die wollen Geld sparen.
Ja, und ich sag dir, in ihrer Argumentation tauchte dieser Aspekt niemals auf. Irgendwo steht, wir wollen Geld sparen und das ist so, die zahlen bei YouTube keine Lizenzgebühren für das, was sie da machen. Bist du sicher? Ja, weil sie den kostenlosen Content anbieten. Den Content kostenlos anbieten.
Zum einen weiß ich nicht, ob da werbefinanzierte Sachen mit dabei sind, zum zweiten, wie gesagt, vielleicht wollen sie da für Kohle nehmen, vielleicht wollen sie für kleines Geld Video streamen.
Für kleines Geld Video streamen, ja, aber da da, da, da müssen sie zahlen. Ja, aber diese Lizenzgebühren fallen nicht groß ins Gewicht, das ist nicht so. Das ist nicht so, dass da das auf einmal doppelt so teuer wird, weil du H264 nimmst, sondern das ist halt ein Kleinstbetrag, der da noch mit drauf anfällt.
Wieso ist das ein Kleinstbetrag, wenn du pro Video, wenn du sagen, bleiben wir mal bei deinem Beispiel, sie müssen pro Video 1 Cent zahlen, wenn sie Videos für 3 Cent ausliefern wollen, dann musst du pro Video 1 Cent, dann ist das viel Geld.
Okay, vielleicht wollen sie für 3 Cent Videos verleihen.
Selbst wenn sie es für 1 Dollar machen wollen, ist es immer noch.
Wahrscheinlich kostet der Download schon so viel Geld.
Das ist doch eine gemischt Kalkulation und da will man doch...
Ja gut, aber du weißt es auch nicht. Also du denkst, das könnte vielleicht unter Umständen das Geld gut sein. Google möchte gerne irgendwas billiger haben. Ok, Google möchte was billiger haben. Warum muss ich darunter leiden, dass Google irgendwas billiger haben muss? Die haben mit ihrem Browser jetzt irgendwie 10,7% Market-Share erreicht, mit Chrome. Was gut ist, weil ich habe jetzt heute nochmal die Statistiken, die aktuellen, auch angeschaut. Wieso sind die hier auf einmal nicht mehr in meiner Notiz drin? Das ist ja auch großartig.
Gibt es denn jetzt eigentlich News gegenüber der letzten Sendung?
Na ja, also außer, dass immer noch...
Außer, dass Google jetzt irgendwie einen Plaket für Chrome rausbringt und damit deren Versuch, das zu monopolisieren, schon ein bisschen in die Hose geht?
Also für mich persönlich, ich habe halt an News wahrgenommen, so ein paar klärende Blogposts, die halt relativ klar... Was heißt klar? Also die nahelegen, dass es unter Umständen schon so sein mag, dass On2 mit dem VP8 an allen existierenden Patenten so dran vorbei programmiert hat, dass es vielleicht sein kann, dass sie da tatsächlich kein anderes Patent verletzt haben. Nur so richtig genau weiß das natürlich keiner.
Ja gut, aber angenommen, man geht mal davon aus, dass es wirklich so ist.
Dann hast du immer noch das Problem, dass man dann mit zwei verschiedenen Videoformaten in dieser Welt jetzt arbeiten soll. Weil Rom ja sagt, wir machen nur noch das eine. Ich habe ja überhaupt nichts dagegen, dass sie WebM jetzt irgendwie pushen und dass bestimmte Gruppen das toll finden und nur das machen wollen. Wikipedia vermute ich mal, das ist so die Art der Community.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, das würde ich mir auch schnuppern, wenn Chrome nur noch einen supportet. Dann haben die halt Pech gehabt, wenn da Seiten mit einem anderen Format daherkommen.
Aber du weißt doch, wie das ist. Das bremst einfach die Entwicklung des Webs aus.
Wie viele Leute benutzen Chrome?
10,7 Prozent.
Und wenn die plötzlich alle nichts mehr klicken können, dann wären es auch weniger. Da kannst du aber retten.
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich meine, sie haben es ja nur angeguckt, dass sie es tun wollen, aber wann sie es...
Ich finde ja, wenn ich mich entscheiden kann zwischen mehreren Formaten und wenn da Leute gibt, die meinen, sie wollen Web-App benutzen, dann finde ich das eine gute Sache, wenn die das können. Wenn Google meint, sie wollen H264 nicht benutzen, finde ich auch, es ist deren Recht, können die machen.
Ja, aber es ist ja noch nicht mal so.
Was ist nicht so?
Na, sie liefern Flash aus und in Flash ist H264.
Ja, da haben wir irgendeine Agenda hinter, die wir nicht kennen und die wir nie rausfinden werden. Wahrscheinlich kommt nächstes Jahr ein Produkt, dann sind wir so, ah, deswegen haben die das gemacht. Wenn sie damit durchkommen, wenn nicht, dann machen sie das erst gar nicht. Wir haben ja nie raus, dann können wir uns hier zu Tode diskutieren. Und unsere Hörer sprengen ab.
Naja, aber ich finde das eine wichtige Diskussion.
Zweimal?
Jetzt bist du ja zumindest mal dabei.
Ich hab letztes Mal auch zugehört, aber so richtig spannend finde ich das nicht, weil das...
Betrifft dich nicht so direkt.
Genau. Erstens, ich nutze keinen Chrome. Zweitens nutze ich keinen Chrome. Drittens, keinen Firefox. Viertens, keinen EE. Nee, also... Ich finde, die können da ehrlich gesagt machen, was sie wollen.
Ja, es ist schon schade, dass es da nicht einen gemeinsamen Nenner gibt, so fürs Web-Ansicht.
Aber nur ein gemeinsamer Nenner ist ehrlich gesagt auch nicht immer so das wahre. Aber wenigstens mal ein.
Wenigstens mal ein.
Ach du meinst, wir sollten einfach mal neben Unicode noch mal einen anderen Text-Encoding-Standard einführen?
Oh ja bitte.
Webtext? Also wenn man dafür, dass man Text schreibt, plötzlich Geld abdrücken müsste, dann wäre ich da sehr dafür.
Ja.
Also ich will diese Zeiten nicht mehr zurück. Also wo einfach alles unklar war. Ich meine, bei Video war das schon bisher immer ein Elend. Und es war schon immer ein Elend. Mit Video.
Aber warum interessiert dich denn Videos tatsächlich einfach mal so? Ich meine, kann dir doch wirklich scheißegal sein.
Wieso kann mir das egal sein?
Wofür interessiert dich das?
Eben.
Woher weißt du das, dass ich nie Videos machen werde?
Weiß ich nicht.
Vielleicht will ich ja Videos machen, bloß bin ich unzufrieden mit der Art und Weise, wie das im Web distributiert wird.
Wo bist du dann unzufrieden? Du machst jetzt einfach H264 und gut ist?
Es gibt nicht eine Methode, wie ich das in einer Webseite einbinde und dann ist klar, dass das überall zu sehen ist. Das ist zum Beispiel ein Problem und das ist das Problem überhaupt gerade mit Videos.
Das ist sowieso nie wirklich komplett klar.
Und ich will halt nichts Plugins haben.
Solange es halt, also ich meine, so lange jetzt, also YouTube bietet jetzt ja schon WebM-Content an, kann man ja die HTML5-Beta da den Cookie setzen und dann hinten und WebM gleich einsetzen, dann kriegt man ja schon WebM um die Ohren, wenn man das kann. Mit dem Firefox 4 in der letzten Beta zum Beispiel. Und wenn jetzt Vimeo auch noch irgendwann sagt, wir machen das jetzt auch noch in WebM und du lädst einfach dein Video zu Vimeo oder YouTube und die kümmern sich darum, das für den jeweiligen Kleint in dem richtigen Format anzuzeigen, ist das jetzt schon mal nicht schlecht. Klar wär es toll, wenn man einfach selber ein Video encoded ist, auf seinen Webserver schmeißt und es spielt überall, aber...
Also erstens will ich nicht, dass meine Videos immer noch mal sinnlos umgerechnet werden, sondern ich möchte selber das Video für das jeweilige Tage direkt berechnen, ohne dass mir noch mal jemand meine Videos umrechnet, weil dabei verlieren sie einfach Qualität. Das ist mal das eine. Zweitens, YouTube mag das ja tun jetzt mit dem Web-M, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich das irgendjemand sonst noch leisten kann, alle seine Videos doppelt vorzuhalten. Das kostet einfach doppelt so viel Geld und doppelt so viel Geld.
Vimeo wird dafür auch wieder extra Geld verlangen, ja.
Ja, aber von wem?
Von den Leuten, die es bezahlen. Also, ich hab halt auch bei Vimeo einen Plus-Account geklickt, damit ich H264, HTML5-Video kriege.
Ja, aber das ist auch der totale Fail da.
Die haben halt nicht so viel Kohle.
Ja gut, aber die anderen wollen ja doch auch vorankommen.
Ja, dann sollen sie halt H264 rausschmeißen und nur Web-M nehmen, ist doch okay.
Ja, aber das löst ja auch kein Problem.
Ja, das ist ja die Scheiße. Du musst dich, wenn du das selber hosten willst, musst du dich halt darum kümmern, dass du jetzt irgendwie dein Fallback-Video noch an den Start kriegst, dass du irgendwie dich mit zwei Codex beschäftigst, wie du das optimal konformierst.
Nee, du lässt halt H264 weg.
Alter, die ganze Welt macht H264.
Firefox macht kein H264.
Firefox ist ein Browser. Ich rede von Geräten, die Video machen.
Also, ich würde nicht nur Web-M auf meine Webseite stellen.
Jeder Fernseher, jeder Blu-ray-Player, jedes Device, jede Kamera, alle machen H264. Das ist einfach so.
Ja, dann surfe ich mit deiner Kamera.
Warum reden wir dann hier über so ein Nischenprodukt wie Web-M?
Ja, bloß weil dieses Internet.
Google gerade einfach den Spielverderber gibt und ich versuche zu verstehen, worauf sie eigentlich hinaus wollen. Vielleicht haben sie ja irgendeinen Masterplan, der ganz toll ist, wofür man sie lieben muss. Aber ich verstehe es nicht.
Ja, aber wir auch nicht und deswegen können wir auch uns an den Google und so Podcasts denken.
Ich habe auf meinem neuen Computer, wie es mir der Steve diktiert hat, Flash nicht installiert. Ich habe alles gelöscht, was irgendwie Plugins sind, benutze aber den Gruber-Trick. Das heißt, ich habe so meinen Fallback mit Chrome. Also Chrome ist eigentlich mein Flash-Player. Ich nenne eigentlich Chrome auch nur noch Flash-Player. Ich starte das dann sozusagen Web-Content im Flash-Player. Und es ist erstaunlich, wie sich das Web dann so wandelt.
Ja, das ist die überklickte Flash, oder?
Aber es ist noch nicht schön. Also man blickt auf viele leere Seiten.
Aber es gibt auch viele leere Seiten, wo man den User-Agent auf iPad stellt.
Ja, und das ist auf einmal alles ganz anders. Das stimmt. Deswegen, also da könnte sich schon noch eine Menge tun.
Kann es sein, dass dein Drobo hier das Knistern auf der Leitung macht? Nee, ne?
Jetzt geht's ja wieder raus hier mit den esoterischen...
Ich weiß es nicht. Ja, aber das hört man nicht. Das kann auch irgendwie nicht den Kontent da verändern.
Also Tim, hier dein Web-M-Thema, das kommt zur Wiedervorlage, wenn du harte Erkenntnisse über die Strategie von Google erlangt hast.
Genau.
Vorher wollen wir davon nichts hören.
Sonst fliegst du nämlich raus.
Genau.
Dann darfst du die Sendung nur noch vom Klo machen.
Wir schalten live ins Klo für eine Stellungnahme. Na, seid ihr noch alle da?
Wir brauchen hier so ein Stream-Statistik, wo man dann sehen kann, wie da beiden runtergehen.
Gibt's doch kein Statistik? Gibt's denn über Nokia reden?
Jetzt lach mal nicht so, dann geht's nicht so gut.
Guck mal, geht steil bergab tatsächlich hier.
As predicted by me.
Im Stream.
Ach so.
Die höheren Zahlen schwingen.
Ich dachte mal, es ist Nokia.
Das war der Aktienkurs von Nokia?
Nein. Bei Nokia geht's steiler runter als in unserem Stream.
Ja, also die haben mal wieder über das 10% Smartphone-Markt eingebüßt.
Na gut, ist ja nur Anteil. Und wie sieht es mit Money aus?
Money sieht ganz schlecht aus. Also bei Money haben Nokia und Apple die Plätze getauscht. Also vor 2007, als Apple auf dem Markt eingestiegen ist, hat Nokia 55% des Gewinns gemacht im gesamten Telefon-Business.
Mobile-Phone-Business.
Mobile-Phone, genau.
55%, das war eine erhebliche Summe, oder?
Das internationale Geschäft mit Telefonen verkaufen, das ist nicht gerade wenig, kann ich dir die Zahl jetzt nicht sagen.
Multimilliarden auf jeden Fall.
Genau, und jetzt hat Apple 51% des Profits des Telefon-Businesses.
Der seitdem auch wahrscheinlich sehr gestiegen ist.
Naja, von Null halt.
Der gesamte Markt ist größer geworden seit drei Jahren. Das ist wahrscheinlich. Die Leute geben, glaube ich, jeder mehr Geld für Telefon aus, weil es eben nicht mehr nur noch ein Telefon ist.
Es ist wahrscheinlich immer noch ein Wachstumsmarkt auf diesem Planeten, so mit China und so.
Wahrscheinlich, auf jeden Fall.
Die Zahl kann ich jetzt gerade nicht nennen.
Also ich würde ja gerne mal so einen Zeitstrahl von diesen Nokia-Fails jetzt sehen, wann sie neue Betriebssysteme announced haben und neue Plattformen und was sie nicht alles announced haben und irgendwie...
Ja, es ist alles total tot bei denen. Mittlerweile, also der neue Chef da, den sie sich da von Microsoft geholt haben, der hat das ja auch selber zugegeben. Wir wollen doch mal gleich diese Formulierung... Das war wirklich göttlich. Aieelop.
Auf unserer ewigen Verliererliste Sony, Nokia. Können wir gleich abhaken jede Sendung. Hatte nicht Sony diese Woche auch irgendwie wieder so eine Meldung?
Ein Analyst meinte, bei Nokia sieht es wirklich nüchster aus.
Ach, ist ja auch in Finnland.
Was irgendein Analyst meint, das ist ja wirklich ein Null.
Es ist auch in Finnland und wir haben Winter.
Also die Formulierung des Chefs war, es ist Zeit, dass Nokia sich schneller umstellt. Super. Also das finde ich echt glücklich. Klasse die Bemerkung. Das haben sie jetzt sozusagen schon eingesehen.
Aber sie haben halt immer noch keine.
Also ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, ob sie überhaupt noch glauben, irgendwas in der Hinterhand zu haben oder ob sie jetzt im Prinzip schon so weit sind, sich entweder dem Google oder dem Microsoft zum Fraß vorzuwerfen. Weil ich glaube, eins von den beiden wird es sein. Ich sehe nicht mehr, dass das Nokia noch aus eigener Kraft das stemmt.
Hat Motorola nicht auch genug Geld vielleicht?
Nee, Motorola verdient sehr wenig Geld derzeit.
Hatten die nicht diesen Dreuthed?
Die haben sich gesplittet.
Die verkaufen auch Geräte, aber die machen halt wenig Gewinn. Der Gewinnanteil ist verschwindend gering. Das Gewinnanteil am Nokia-Markt ist enorm gesunken. Das Schlimme an Nokia ist, sie haben an allen wichtigen Fronten nichts. Sie sind grundsätzlich schon mal mit ihrem Betriebssystem Scheiße aufgestellt. Sie haben auch bei ihren Geräten einfach keinerlei Visionen, wohin es gehen soll. Sie bauen halt alles Mögliche. Aber es gibt nichts, wo du sagst, das ist jetzt sozusagen das klassische Nokia-Gerät. Das iPhone steht ja auch für was. Aber so N897 wie die schon alle heißen, da weißt du ja überhaupt nicht so, war das jetzt eins mit so einer Tastatur oder so einer Tastatur, klappt das hinten links oben oder unten aus oder hat das vielleicht auch keine Tastatur oder welches Betriebssystem ist da überhaupt drauf. Du weißt es nicht. So werden sie einfach keine Developer finden. Selbst wenn sie jetzt ein starkes OS hätten, was sie nicht haben, bin ich der Meinung, das ist die Tatsache, dass sie in den USA noch überhaupt nicht präsent sind, wird ihnen einfach die Luft abdrehen. Die einzige Möglichkeit, die ich mir vorstelle, ist, dass sie entweder auf Android gehen, dass sie jetzt sozusagen auch sagen, ok, wir kapitulieren, wir nehmen jetzt den neuen Marktstandard Android und tun den auf unser Telefon und keine Ahnung, vielleicht dann noch wie HTC bauen unser eigenes Nokia-Gui oben drauf und alle ihre Tools, ihre Maps-Anwendungen portieren sie dann zu Android oder sie portieren ihre User-Interface zu ihren Anwendungen oder sowas, das könnte ich mir auch vorstellen. Oder sie machen halt Windows Phone 7 oder lassen sich am Ende sogar noch kaufen von Microsoft.
Ich glaube, das macht Microsoft nicht. Haben die gar kein Geld mehr für.
Haben die gar nicht die Zeit für.
Die machen auch komplett verschiedene Geschäfte. Die holen sich nicht. Nokia baut Telefone, während Microsoft Telefonbetriebssysteme baut.
Das passt wunderbar zusammen.
Das passt auf so eine Art überhaupt nicht zusammen, weil alles, was Nokia noch geblieben ist, ist nämlich dieser wahnsinnig billige Massenmarkt, der im Augenblick, wo die Geräte noch nicht leistungsstark genug sind, um das Betriebssystem drauf zu packen. Weil da sind sie wirklich noch dicke dabei. Da hat niemand was gegen Nokia in der Hand.
Ja, aber dieser Markt verschwindet. Jedes Jahr werden Smartphones einfach in absehbarer Zeit 90% aller Telefone sein.
Ja, aber in Indien gibt es genug Leute, die kein Geld haben und genug Leute, die sich erstmal einen Eurofond kaufen.
Ja, aber mit Leuten, die kein Geld haben, kannst du nicht das Geld verdienen, um so einen Konzern langfristig oben zu halten.
Die tun das seit Jahrzehnten.
Die wollen auch alle ihre Android-Infones haben. Wir werden 10 Dollar Android-Infones haben. Dieser Preisvorteil wird nicht mehr gelten, weil ein Armprozessor und ein Touchscreen einfach mal Standard ist.
Im Augenblick haben sie diesen Preisvorteil noch, den werden sie noch eine ganze Weile haben, weil so ein Touchscreen musste billig hinkriegen und du musst dann noch die entsprechende Akku-Kapazität haben.
Apple macht mit einem einzigen Gerät 51% des Gewinns des gesamten Marktes. Da willste mir doch nicht erzählen, dass man mit diesen billig-klimper-Tastatur-Telefonen langfristig irgendeinen nennenswerten Revenue erzählen kann, mit dem man so einen Multimilliarden-Mega-Konzern aufrechterhalten kann. Das schaffen die nicht. Die müssen in Wachstumsmärkte rein. Wenn die nicht in Wachstumsmärkte rein will, dann in die Wachstumsmärkte. Ihr durchschnittlicher Gerätepreis ist irgendwie 60 Euro oder so was. Das ist nix.
Aber was ist daran schlecht, viele billige Geräte zu verkaufen?
Dabei war das Nokia-Thema nur ein kleiner Spaß. Und ihr macht einfach wieder so einen Alarm. Ich dachte, wir reden über so einen Galaxy-Tab.
Nicht so verbissen, bleibt doch mal alle locker hier in den Hüften.
Jungs, ihr habt doch keine Nokia-Aktien und auch keine Microsoft-Aktien. Ihr geht ja hier ran, als wenn es ums euer Leben gehen würde.
Was findest du das?
Ich finde, man sollte jetzt, also ich meine, Nokia ist jetzt im Smartphone-Markt nicht mehr präsent. Okay, brauchen wir nicht drüber zu diskutieren. Aber das heißt doch nicht, dass sie deswegen zwangsläufig tot sind. Was hast du davon, wenn sie tot sind?
Was ich davon habe? Ich hab da gar nichts von. Ich sag nur, dass es meiner Meinung nach so kommen wird. Weil ich nicht sehe, wie sie sich da noch retten wollen.
Ja, das ist auch nicht dein Problem. Das ist von diesem grinsenden Nokia-Chef das Problem. Und es ist einer, der es offensichtlich erkannt hat, weil er es in einem Interview besagt. Er sagt nämlich, dass das Unternehmen schneller ändern muss.
Ja gut, aber was sagt, was meint er denn damit? Ich meine, was heißt denn das? Ich meine, wenn der Chef sagt, es ist Zeit, uns schneller umzustellen, dann ist es ja wohl vor allem er, der sich schneller umstellen muss. Und dann könnte er es ja im Prinzip in dem Moment auch schon getan haben, weil sonst ist es dem zu spät.
Du kannst so ein Unternehmen, also wahrscheinlich hat er eine Idee davon, aber du kannst ein Unternehmen nicht von heute auf morgen drehen. Nicht so einen monströsen Kahn wie Nokia. Und darum braucht er dafür einfach ein bisschen Zeit.
Das ist schon seit einem halben Jahr da, glaube ich.
Oh mein Gott! Und hat diesen weltgrößten, nach wie vor, mit den höchsten Verkaufszahlen, Telefonkonzernen immer noch nicht umgedreht. Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ich sehe nicht eine einzige Entscheidung, die irgendwie in die Zukunft verweist. Wo ist die strategische Entscheidung? Wo ist sie?
Der Steve kam zurück, wer ist der Verstehste, ist auf die Bühne gekommen.
Er hat erstmal alle Geräte eingestellt.
Stimmt, als Steve kam, halbe Stunde später kam das iPhone.
Ich erinnere mich noch, wie gestern. Ja, aber guck dir mal die Keynote an. Der ist ja gerade wieder angekommen.
Als Steve kam, hat es nicht lange gedauert.
Hat er Aufbruchstuhl gesagt.
Es waren zehn Mac-Modelle nicht mehr verfügbar.
Er hat gesagt, die Leute sagen, Apple ist irgendwie doof und kann nicht performen. Ich habe genau das Gegenteil rausgefunden. Apple ist super auszupacken und performen wunderbar. Nur müssen wir hier und da ein bisschen was tun. Der hat die da voll umgedreht. Das war so...
Mindfuck.
Mindfucker. Aber das können halt scheinbar auch keine, die anderen CEOs alle nicht. Das ist komisch. Ich fand die echt beeindruckend in der Hinsicht. Der kommt da wieder an und erzählt den allen. Alle sitzen da so, bald ist hier der Job weg und keine Ahnung. Und der kommt auf die Bühne und erzählt denen, wir sind die Zukunft, wir sind der größte Education, die größte Education Company der Welt. Und wir machen alle Schiffe los jetzt hier. Und die glauben das, die sitzen da nach und klatschen und freuen sich und man weiß, es geht wieder vorwärts.
Wird ja auch recht behalten.
Hat er ja. Aber sowas würde ich ja gerne noch bei anderen Konzernen sehen.
Er hat vor allem auch wirklich Maßnahmen ergriffen. Er hat schmerzliche Dinge gemacht. Er hat die halbe McIntosh-Produktpalette irgendwie runter gestrichen.
Er hat das Board of Directors rausgeschmissen.
Wie lange hat das noch gedauert bis zum iMac? Also, Herr Elop, wo ist der iMac?
Naja, aber der ist halt auch auf die Bühne gekommen. Der hat ja gesagt, wir schmeißen unser ganzes Board weg und machen neu. Und dann hat er irgendwie diese Trailer von allen neuen Board-Members, die erstmal hier nochmal Stimmung gemacht haben. Dann hat er irgendwie gesagt, dass wir in zu vielen Bereichen oder dass wir uns auf unsere Kernkompetenzen konzentrieren müssen, hat die erstmal überhaupt aufgezählt und hat halt die Marschrichtung da losgetreten. Und dann gab es ja noch diese Think Different Kampagne gleich noch oben drin, wo sie sowieso nochmal alle in Stimmung und Wallung gebracht haben.
Nokia, also ich finde einfach, Nokia hat noch nicht genug geblutet. Also was die mir angetan haben mit diesen Geräten, die ich benutzen musste, das war so eine Beleidigung.
Wir machen jetzt noch damals das 6310i, 7210i?
Das war wenigstens noch ein Telefon. Hab erst heute wieder einen Ladestecker reingesteckt.
Als Telefone noch Telefone waren.
Und meine Schwester hat es in die Ostsee verhindert.
Ich sehe schon jetzt tausend Leute, sich Tickets an die Ostsee klicken, das krieg ich.
Nee, aber auf Ebay gibt es immer noch 6310i.
Ich hab noch ein Zuhause, aber drücke ich auch nicht raus. Das ist mein Emergency-Notwahl-Telefon.
Schön fände ich ja diese ganzen Meldungen von Samsung und auch von Windows. Samsung mit ihrem, wie hieß das Teil? Und Microsoft mit ihrem Windows Phone 7, die irgendwie im Pressegewitter dann alle kleinen beigeben mussten, dass ihre großen Zahlen, die sie veröffentlicht haben, natürlich keine Sales waren, sondern alles nur Shipments.
Das war so Ende letzten Jahres, da hat der Grube auch geschrieben, dass sie irgendwie Amazing-Werte hätten. 2 Millionen oder was?
2 Millionen, genau. Da hab ich auch irgendwie so ein bisschen mich gefragt, was, wer...
Ja, ich war so ein bisschen erstaunt, weil sonst hat man von dem Gerät ja irgendwie nichts gehört. Beim iPhone hat man gehört, den Hype, Spiegel, Spiegel berichtet irgendwie...
Wovon hat man nichts gehört?
Vom Galaxy Tab.
Ne, muss man halt nicht totgestellt haben und davon nichts zu tun haben.
Du liest halt einfach nicht in Gadget und Gizmodo und peng.
Also wenn du nicht technisch, also in der normalen Medien mit Galaxy Tab, das kennt kein Schwerns, das kennt kein Mensch.
Also, weißt du, also so...
Ja, Max, das kennt kein Mensch.
Naja, wie gesagt, also...
Ja, geh mal in die nächste Shopping-Mode und schrei mal laut iPad. Da wirst du ja sehen, wie viele Leute sich umdrehen.
Wie viele Leute nervös gucken, wenn in der U-Bahn so ein iPhone klingelt. Ich meine, da sind 20 Leute, die ihre Taschen greifen.
Nee, das sagt ja nichts über so ein iPad. Ach komm, Kinder, das ist doch jetzt wirklich...
Was du willst behaupten, alle Kinder wissen, was ein Galaxy Tab ist.
Es ist scheißegal, ob alle Kinder wissen, was ein Galaxy Tab ist, aber ich meine, sollen wir uns jetzt hier noch drei Stunden einen runterholen, dass Apple Marktführer bei Tablets ist?
Wieso holt sich hier gerade einer einen drauf runter?
Man kann ja schon mal erwähnen, dass die anderen Herren, die ja auch immer so, also es ist ja schon immer so, dass die dann immer kommen.
Ich find das geil. Um ehrlich zu sein, ich find das super und ich sag dir auch warum. Weil dieser ganze Dreck da draußen, diese furchtbaren Geräte, diese hässlichen, ohne Liebe dahingerotzten, glickligen von Ingenieuren verunstalteten kack Scheiß-Teile, haben keinen Erfolg zu haben. Und es ist so ein Blumengarten, das irgendwie ein ordentlich designtes Gerät jetzt einfach mal abräumt und auf dem Markt einfach mal den Zampano macht. Und alle müssen sich am Riemen reißen. Die müssen alle ihre Gürtel ein bisschen rütteln. Die müssen sich da mal ordentlich den Spiegel gerade rücken, um einfach mal sich Gedanken darüber zu machen, über User Interfaces, über Qualität, über Kohärenz, über Ästhetik, all das. Sie müssen alle in die Schule. Das ist super. Toll, super, super. Was hab ich gelitten in den 90ern? Diese PC-Zeit, dieses Windows-Elen, dieses ganze eklige, diese furchtbaren Begriffe, mit denen man leben musste. Ja? Dieser Fritz-Box-Appeal. Das ist einfach krank. Und so kann dieser, ich meine, verstehst du, dieser Planet, der steht unmittelbar vor seiner Ausrottung. Und wir erlauben es uns, die Hirne dieser Menschen irgendwie zu verunstalten und nie dazu kämpfen, diese totale......fertig zu machen. Das ist einfach krank. Wie sollen wir es schaffen, diesen Planeten zu retten, wenn die Leute mit so einem Scheiß arbeiten? Das geht nicht. Und das hat einfach zu verlieren. Jetzt mal fünf Jahre, müssen sie einfach alle nur noch einstecken. Und dann wird dieser Welt auch ein besserer Platz. Und das meine ich wirklich ernst.
Das glaube ich.
Das ist wirklich meine... für mich eine Genugtuung ohnegleichen, dass das jetzt endlich mal so weit gekommen ist. Und ich hoffe, dass das noch echt lange anhält. Und dieser Dreck muss weg. Amen.
Das ist eigentlich ein gutes Schlusswort für heute. Oder haben wir noch was?
Ja, einmal in den Äther geblast.
Es kotzt mich an wirklich. Man muss nicht der gleiche Meinung sein, aber das ist das, was mich treibt. Ich glaube, wir haben es auch. Oder? Ist die Sendung schon wieder überlang geworden? Ich habe gar nicht auf die Uhr geguckt.
Nö, ist ganz entspannt.
Sind wir bei sportlichen 3 Stunden oder so? Haben wir wirklich nichts mehr?
Na, das ist nur noch so Klangkram.
Jetzt könnte man Max nochmal das Wort erteilen.
Max wollte was Schönes über sein Händler, sein Vertrauen sagen.
Ach nee, heute habe ich keinen Bock mehr.
Max ist an die Wand geföhnt worden. Das muss auch mal sein.
Wir müssen den Planeten retten.
iPads für Ägypten.
Bessere Revolution durch iPad. Das müsste jetzt irgendwie noch kommen.
Ja, also ist leer der Zettel.
Ja, also ich meine, ich hab nur noch so Kleinkraben. Das ist auch alles so ein bisschen Glaskugelkram. Nichts wirkliches.
Ich würde ja auch manchmal gerne auf das Display gucken, damit du das nicht so herrschst.
Da soll ich dir sagen, was ich mir jetzt hier noch notiert hab. Das sind alles so Themen, die ich anbringe, wenn's draufkommt. Was weiß ich so. Homesharing. Oh nee, es gibt. Ja, nfc kann man jetzt auch drüber rumrätseln, aber weiß man auch nichts drüber.
Naja, was dazu ist.
Möchtest du das Thema noch aufgreifen?
Nee, nicht so richtig. Also ist vielleicht mal doch noch demnächst so ein Thema, aber irgendwie hoffe ich irgendwie auch nicht.
Ja. Na gut, Dennis? Du noch was?
Ich habe fertig.
Du warst fertig. Dann machen wir Schluss, wa?
Spielst du noch mal hier unseren Song?
Zum Abschluss meinst du?
Ich will noch mal hören.
Okay, dann machen wir das zum Abschluss.
Wollen wir zur 60. Folge, die ja dann die nächste ist, wollen wir dann den Namensumzug dann endlich vollziehen? Nachdem wir jetzt so bestimmt gefühlte sechs Monate uns der Entscheidung annähern und eigentlich das auch in der letzten Folge schon längst beschlossen haben?
Meinst du das? Haben wir das schon beschlossen?
Ja, wir haben jetzt einen Song.
Dann setzen wir uns jetzt noch mal nach der Sendung noch mal zusammen und beschließen das dann mal oder auch nicht.
Ja, und halt dann Max wieder auf.
Genau.
Das, was wir heute fast geschafft haben in der Sendung, nicht Flash zu spielen, aber auch nur fast.
Naja.
Inke Winkel. Herzlich willkommen bei Bum, zack, return.